fight against crime is never a linear
one we should celebrate our successes
should we not
so i would
say to the um the policing minister
actually i'm hugely relieved and glad
that
while during lockdown while everybody
was at home
there were fewer burglaries of homes
i'm also
hugely relieved that
during lockdowns while there were fewer
people on the streets there were also
fewer thefts on the street
as well but i would just quote to him
from the office of national statistics
in april who said the police since
restrictions were lifted following the
third national lockdown in early 2021
police recorded crime data show
indications that certain offence types
are returning to or exceeding the levels
seen before the pandemic while violence
and sexual offences recorded by the
police have exceeded pre-pandemic levels
and on overall crime i am sure that the
policing minister would not want to make
the mistake that his business secretary
did of somehow dismissing fraud that is
responsible for some of the huge
increases in crime and say that that is
somehow not a crime that affects
people's daily lives when what we know
is that is causing huge problems and
huge harms particularly for vulnerable
people across the country
and of course
this is peter can i just push my
honourable friend she's coming up with
some telling
statistics but did she
did she realize that my constituents
when i talked to them of the spite of
the police the police say morale has
never been lower
the numbers have never been so small
and on the other side we have a
government that's been there since 2010
and has diminished the resources to the
um justice system you know harder than
any other department so if you get the
balance totally
and the confidence of the my
constituents has plummeted
well my own friend makes a really
important point and i want to pay
tribute to the police officers right
across the country who are working
incredibly hard in our communities
working hard to try and crack down on
crime to prevent crime walking towards
danger when the rest of us walk away
and who are valiantly trying to hold
things together but too often are being
let down by this government and this is
particularly the case when it comes to
doing violence with violence against
women and rape
on rape
the prosecution rate the charge rate has
gone down from 8.5 percent in 2015 to a
truly shocking
1.3 percent
that means that today in england and
wales it's estimated that around 300
women will be raped
around 170 cases will be reported to the
police
but only around three just three
are likely to make it to a court of law
never mind a jail cell
so just think what that means
it's not just on rape it's on so many
other cases as well
no charges within a year of an offence
on 93 percent of reported robberies
95 of violent offences 96 of thefts 97
of sexual offenses
over 98
of reported rapes and over 99
of fraud
this is a total disgrace
one police officer said to me this is
awful he said it feels like once serious
offenses are effectively being
decriminalized
because there is no consequences i give
away tomorrow friend i thank my
right-hand friend for giving away and
she's making a very very powerful
contribution i i wanted to move on
beyond the police to the issues she
raised around fraud fraud is now what
the biggest crime facing us and the cost
to the economy is uh coming on something
like
190 million
190 billion pounds a year does she agree
with me that as well as funding the
police it's absolutely imperative that
we fund all the enforcement agencies
that are fighting this sort of incr
economic crime and whilst the americans
are raising the money we here are
lowering the investment that we're
putting into the enforcement agencies
i think my honorable friend makes a
really important point and we pay the
price if economic crime is not enforced
the current system just isn't working
everybody will know the nightmare it is
if you try to report fraud maybe getting
passed from pillar to post between
action fraud and between your local
police force but then she is right too
and the more some of the more serious
issues where this is also about the
relationship between the police the
series fraud office between other
enforcement agencies that need to take
action i hope this will be debated as
part of the discussions on economic
crime but this is a really damning
picture of crime rising
but this shocking drop in prosecution's
shopping drop shocking drop in action
but was the home secretary's response to
this well soon after she took up the job
she said let the message go out to the
british people we hear you and to the
criminals i simply say this we are
coming after you
well to the home secretary i simply say
this you better start running faster
because they're all getting away
and to be fair to the prime minister
yesterday
his main home office focus was anger at
the passport office
that is probably something all of us can
agree on
for the newlyweds having to cancel their
honeymoons or the hard-pressed families
who fear who are now facing losing
thousands of pounds on long-saved money
to go on a well-deserved holiday
ministers told us this is being sorted
out but most of us will say from our
constituency casework this is getting
worse
and they are being badly let down so the
prime minister was right to be angry
yesterday although who does the prime
minister think has been in charge of the
passport office for the last 12 years
the prime minister now says he wants to
privatize it if it isn't sorted out the
immigration minister however told us the
vast majority the private sector is
already being used in the vast majority
of the processes in the passport office
the bit that's not is the decision
itself so that just leaves us back with
the home office failing to get a grip on
those private sector contracts and
failing to take basic decisions
and it's part of a pattern
a pattern of home office failure while
the prime minister casts around to get
someone else to step in
we have ukrainians who are fleeing war
who've been waiting weeks on end for
visas because the home office added long
bureaucratic delays so that many
desperate families have now given up
they could not afford to wait and have
found somewhere else to live somewhere
else to give them sanctuary instead
of 80 000 applications only 19 000
applications to the uk homes for ukraine
have arrived
i will give way to the honourable member
and then i'll give way tomorrow
for giving way she's very generous with
the time i'd like to personally thank
the home secretary she makes a point
about ukrainian refugees there was a
family moved next door to me two weeks
ago the the the family got in touch with
me within within minutes the um
secretary of team had got back to me
they're now in in in our village in
kirby and ashfield they thanked the home
secretary they thanked the prime
minister and they thanked the people of
great britain
well
i would just say to him i think that
people of great britain have shown that
they want to help
desperate families who are fleeing
ukraine um i think it however
the facts are really clear there have
been 80 000 applications but there's
only 19 000 people here
and the home secretary says oh it's
because they're staying where they are
yeah a lot of them are because they have
now given up because it's become so
difficult i give away from them
does she agree with me about the really
troubling reports that i've had
particularly in cases that i've dealt
with but in the media that the home
office will issue
a number of visas for ukrainians but not
all of the ukrainians in that family and
therefore the family of quite rightly
doesn't want to leave someone behind and
they then don't come here and that's
classed as a ukrainians not taking up
the visa rather than home office failure
and at the same time the home office
lines are bogged up we can't get through
and when you do get through you're told
i don't even have a computer in front of
me i'm just on a phone line i don't know
what to say it's failure at the home
office that she's presided over
well the member is right i have also
heard of cases where one family member
does not get their vision of course the
whole family has to wait they're not
going to be separated at time of crisis
and really for home office ministers to
think that it's somehow a triumph to
take four weeks to issue basic visas to
people who are fleeing war in europe is
totally shameful
it now takes more than a year to get a
basic initial asylum decision because
home office is now taking just 14 000
initial decisions a year half the level
it was taking in 2015 a basic
incompetence that means the backlog has
soared and so too has the bill for the
taxpayer
it takes nearly two years
to get a modern slavery referral which
means that victims don't get support and
prosecutions just don't happen
so no wonder even the prime minister who
is not known for his laser-like focus on
delivering policies has lost confidence
in the home secretary and is getting
other people to do the jobs instead
looking to privatize the passport office
channel crossings delivery handed over
to the mod homes the ukraine scheme
handed over to dia to dealer the visas
handed over to the new refugees minister
and the asylum processing decision
making now so slow they really are in
the ludicrous and unworkable situation
of paying rwanda over a hundred million
pounds to fake decisions for us this
home secretary all at this rate crime
will be given to the justice department
we'll have the fire service given to
defra because the home office under this
home secretary has effectively been put
into special measures because it cannot
get the basics right and if the home
secretary can't get the basics done on
any of those core decisions she should
get out the way and let someone else
sort it out
because mr deputy speaker there is an
alternative to this shambles on crime
and prosecutions it was obvious a decade
ago that this was where we were heading
as a result of government policies i
warned in 2013 about the risk of falling
charge rates
i warned about the failure of the home
office to help the police tackle
increasingly complex crimes and fast
fast-changing crimes
and i warned then about the risks that
if there was no proper urgent plan to
modernize policing none of which has
happened about the dangers if police
were ripped out of the heart of our
communities
of what it would be and now our towns
and our cities and our rural communities
are all paying the price they're all
feeling like the criminal justice system
isn't there for them when they need it
so where is the action now to turn this
around in the queen's speech where's the
action to help the police modernize to
keep up with fast-changing crimes was
the actual reform and raising police
standards that we need to improve
confidence and where's the action to get
justice and improve safety for women and
girls there's nothing to establish the
specialist rape investigation units in
every police force nothing to establish
specialist rape courts to speed the
cases up and make sure they've got the
expertise nothing to set up the domestic
abuse and stalking perpetrators register
that we have been calling for for years
nothing to establish a mandatory minimum
sentence for rape all the things that
labour has been calling for nothing to
tackle anti-social behavior where the
powers are just not being used or to
sort out community penalties which have
too often dropped and nothing to prevent
crime and anti-social behavior in the
first place
nothing to make sure that neighborhood
police are restored to our streets or to
set up neighborhood prevention teams
something we have repeatedly called for
the home secretaries wants to boast that
she's delivering the biggest increase in
police funding in 10 years well who's
been in power for the last 10 years she
still hasn't even restored the police
that her party cut and she isn't getting
them out onto the streets there are
still 7 000 fewer police in our
neighborhoods compared to 2015 7 000
fewer instead the police are weighed
down by more bureaucracies stuck back at
their desks doing paperwork the only way
to improve their visibility moving the
desk to nearer the window
and have they have
mr speakers to be deputy speaker to be
fair they have proposed a victims bill
and we will support that
but it's only in draft
and it was first promised in 2015 then
again in 2016 then again in 2017 and
again in 2019
and yes again in 2021
this year it didn't even get a proper
mention in the humble address and
certainly nothing from the prime
minister yesterday the prime minister
home secretary herself rightly made a
personal commitment to strengthen
victims of rights back in 2014 when she
first said she backed a new victim's law
and she was right to do so because at
that time nine percent of victims nine
percent of cases were dropping because
victims were dropping out of the
criminal justice system because they
lost confidence
but since then
those figures have almost trebled
1.3 million cases were dropped last year
because victims gave up and dropped out
and yet she's seriously telling us she
does not have time in this parliament
for victims again
instead their top priority is a rehashed
public order bill even though they've
just done one public order bill because
they're again failing to work with the
police to sort out swift injunctions
against serious disruptive protests or
to help the police sensibly use the
powers they've got
there are police there are bills that
should command cross-party support we
support a protect duty that could keep
people safer from potential terror
attacks and we remember with sadness
all those victims of the manchester
attack and i would ask the government to
listen to the calls from other bereaved
families from other major incidents and
i would ask her again to look at calls
for a hillsborough law which she will
know have been made
by by members across the house and by
families who lost so much we also
welcome mr deputy speaker the long
overdue economic crime bill we've called
for years for action to strengthen
companies house and we will be pressing
for stronger action on money laundering
including illicit finance used for
terrorist activity
and on terrorism and national security
we always stand ready to work with the
government in the national interest we
agree with the need for a register of
foreign agents again promised for years
and we need much greater vigilance and
action against hostile state activity
but my honourable friend did raise a
significant issue that the home
secretary did not answer and i would ask
her to consider it and be ready to
answer it again in future because i do
think there should be some transparency
on the issues around contact with
foreign agents and it would be very
helpful if she could for confirm whether
or not the prime minister while he was
foreign secretary met with the ex-kgb
agent alexander lebedev in italy in
april 2018 and whether any civil
servants were present it would be very
helpful to know that information
we support stronger action on modern
slavery we hope that this bill will be
an opportunity to go further but the
home secretary does need to reverse some
of the damaging provisions from the
borders bill which will make it harder
to prosecute trafficking and slaving
gangs as the retiring
modern slavery commissioner has warned
and we have to say where is the
employment bill with the long-promised
single enforcement body to crack down on
forced labor and abuse because without
these measures this is still not a
serious plan to tackle modern slavery
in the absence of any serious action
then on the cost of living in the
queen's speech or any serious action to
push prosecutions up the government did
talk instead about leveling up and
community pride
the trouble is i just don't think they
get it
because there is no leveling up if
people can't afford to eat can't afford
to pay their bills or can't afford to go
to the local shops
and there is no community pride if town
centres don't have police offices or see
no action when there is vandalism or
when there is street drinking or
shoplifting or litter
or if too often the windows are broken
and nothing is done
so how can people have that local pride
if there is no neighborhood police to
help prevent crime solve problems or nip
them in the bud
or if people feel there are no
consequences for criminals
and the very communities to whom they
keep making false promises about
leveling up
are our towns that are being hardest hit
by anti-social behavior or persistent
unsolved crimes
and trust within our communities depends
on us having trust in the laws and trust
in there being consequences
that's why labour's called for the
police to be getting back on the street
to have the neighborhood prevention type
cri neighborhood prevention teams in
place
and to have partnerships in place that
work
both to prevent crime but also to tackle
the criminals and to bring them to
justice
because if people stop believing that a
fair and valiant criminal justice system
will come to their aid if they are hurt
or wronged that is corrosive for our
democracy too
and that's why it is so damaging to feel
like we have a government that shrugs
its shoulders as victims of crime are
let down
a conservative government
that is not
a party of law and order anymore that
too often is a party of crime and
disorder a party that is weak on crime
that is weak on the causes of crime that
is letting more criminals off and
letting our communities down britain
deserves better than this
order if everybody could resume their
seats
um just to remind everybody that if
you're participating in the debate you
would be expected
to be here for the wind-ups at the end
of the debate there are wind-ups uh
today and in subsequent days unlike
yesterday and secondly i'm not putting
um a time limit on
um at the moment but i would urge people
to be at least aware of the length of
their speeches
robert sims
thank you very much uh deputy speaker i
rise to support the queen's speech and
the program unveiled by the government
i think that
one can see politics getting back to
normal
and i'm sure the contest in the house
today will be one of those watched
in the next two years as we glide into
the
likely date of a general election
um and um
both sides
are quite feisty performers and i'm sure
many of us appreciate that
um the program set out
is um setting out to help grow the
economy
um for safer streets and indeed support
the recovery of the national health
service
uh i think in terms of the economy we're
in a lot better shape
than one might have thought when we had
the prolonged period of lockdown
we have a growing economy this year will
be the fastest growing economy of many
in the g7
and we have a budget which is moving
towards balance we have falling national
debt
and there are challenges um with cost of
living and inflation but the government
have so far put 22 billion pounds worth
of support in and is monitoring the
situation and i'm sure as things unfold
there will be further support as and
when needed
this is a government that you could
never argue hasn't given support to the
british people over the past two or
three years
and i think what we have to do is to
wait and see
how
things unfold in terms of energy
gas prices have fallen over recent
months and let's all hope that that
continues and that the inflation rate is
lower than some predict
that's not to say there aren't
challenges out there
but i think this government has proven
it can rise to challenges
i think that some of the measures within
the queen's speech i think are useful to
help and support the growing economy
particularly starting to deregulate some
of the euro regulations that we put into
british law when we left
but logically we need to review now to
see if we can get ourselves as a more
efficient more competitive economy
so i welcome those bills that are
looking at that particular area
we have a major challenge of course with
energy
and um
it's my great pleasure to commend the
right on member for chelsea and fulham
who i think is doing an excellent job
with his energy brief and the fact that
this government is grappling with issues
like nuclear power
and with oil and gas and with renewables
in order to increase our capacity i
think is much to be
commended
indeed it is sensible even if we're
heading for net zero at some point in
the future that we use the resources
that god has given us and the british
economy has proved able to get out of
the ground
and we are going to need oil and gas for
a long time and i think this government
is proving that it wants to make use of
these resources to make us a richer and
more competitive country and nuclear
power is very important
we can see the mistake the germans made
in
announcing a closure of their nuclear
power stations and their dependency on
russian gas
and we ourselves need to replace many of
those magnolic stations that are going
to go offline
and i think it's an exciting time
because i hope soon we get a decision on
size well but i'm particularly pleased
that rolls royce has come up with its
partners with a scheme for smaller
nuclear power stations which i think is
going to be a game changer not only a
game changer for the united kingdom but
could well be a game changer for exports
that this country could undertake to
many countries that wish to avail
themselves of safe nuclear power
so i think that's good
there's one area i'm still a bit
concerned about and that is
agriculture i still think we seem to
spend a little too much time talking
about trimming hedges and less about
producing food
and i think one of the things that um
the pandemic has proven the current
world of shortages has proven is that
resilience and local production is quite
important
and i would be very disappointed about
the food that we were producing reduced
below 50 percent and if anything we
ought to be producing more
and i therefore think that there does
need to be a particular rethink in this
area i'm not a great fan i have to say a
bank of england independence i've always
been a little skeptical about it
and some of the problems we face
of course
i'm very grateful to my honourable
friend just on his first two subjects um
i wonder if he would uh reflect
on the fact that both in terms of
nuclear power and now agriculture we
have freedom and flexibility that comes
from his and my vote to leave the
european union and in particular on
nuclear power he will recall the blood
curdling predictions that were made
about our failure of in that particular
industry by departing from your atom uh
all those years ago and does he would he
agree uh that along with the french now
we can position ourselves as really the
only two serious nuclear powers in
europe
that's absolutely so the original design
teams for british nuclear power were
taken apart and in order to have a
productive nuclear power industry you
need continued investment in new plants
and the good thing about what's happened
at hinckley c and indeed with sizewell
and with rolls-royce is that we are
getting the design teams together we're
collaborating with other partners and
that will be a major
game changer in terms of britain being
able to produce the power that we need
in the future
and going back to the bank of england i
i'm a little concerned that they've
merely gone on printing money
i'm old enough to still be a monetarist
in its broadest sense
and one of the reasons that we have
higher inflation is that we've allowed
for it because of monetary growth
and i think if we'd stopped printing
money sooner and had put interest rates
up sooner the consequences of the
current spike in inflation would be less
severe
nevertheless we are where we are and um
i think at least it's only the ecb
printing money at the moment and britain
can get back to more sensible
policy and
we have
very low levels of unemployment and high
levels of employment
and i think there are many other
measures in the
law of speech
in which we're trying to improve
education
and uh outputs in that area we really do
have to educate our population so they
become more productive we get
productivity up and if we get the
investment right and we get education
right then there's nothing that we can't
do in the future in terms of the home
office i'd like to thank them for the
hard work they put in in the last
session
my constituents are very appreciative
that we now have powers to deal with
travelers which tend to cause problems
every summer in dorset
they're also pleased that we're starting
to deal with illegal immigration
immigration
has to be fair
and if people
follow the system pay the fees fill out
the forms and wait in the queue it is
fundamentally unfair that people arrive
in boats and try and jump the queue
and uh the government therefore i think
is taking action and i think a lot of
the action will put some of those people
off coming in an illegal way
which i think is good i'm also
particularly pleased with the public
order measures announced today
my constituents look at people
trying to wreck petrol stations getting
on tankers
taking action which is dangerous
i have to say my sympathy was with the
woman in the range rover who was trying
to nudge protesters uh i actually think
that when people disrupt people's lives
we all a lot of people work hard they
try and get their kids to school keep
them in school uniform and they take
people to hospital and
protesters who aren't demonstrators but
are disrupting other people's
livelihoods
i think need to be
curtailed
and i think these measures therefore i
think are welcome
and i'm glad that the government is on
the front foot when it comes to dealing
with these things it is vitally
important
i mean we i think part of the problem
the reason we have to legislate is that
we've seen examples of city banks where
people outside of hip buildings and
smashed
uh windows with hammers where
unfortunately the judicial system has
let people off
and i think sometimes i think those
people who are making decisions of the
judicial system do not understand the
seriousness
of where this leads if you let some
degree of anarchy then it can easily
over spill
and break out
so i think these measures i think are
welcome
of course thirteen and a half thousand
police officers i think are welcome
um i still think the police need some
reform i i think it's the one area that
mrs thatcher didn't reform and i think
that sometimes the productivity that we
get out of the police force isn't all
that we need and i think there are some
specialists that we need in the police
forces so just the head count of uh
police officers i don't think
is not important but i think it's
important sometimes particularly we're
dealing with fraud to deal with
people that are experts in it rather
than people who just happen to be
officers
and my final points uh mr deputy speaker
are that we put a lot of money into the
national health service it's important
we get the productivity it's also
important it doesn't disappear and we
can't deal with care
we've made a number of commitments
people are paying higher taxes at least
in the short term
because of uh dealing with the backlog
and dealing with care and i think it is
so important that we live up to the
pledges that we've made i welcome the
loyal speech i welcome what the
government is doing um uh there are one
or two uh concerns i have but broadly
speaking i'm supportive
steward macdonald
thank you very much indeed mr deputy
speaker the debate today is about
preventing crime and delivering justice
and we heard the home secretary's claim
of belonging to the party of law and
order delivered without any sense of
irony
but this government's record is one of
seeking out every opportunity it can to
put itself beyond justice and above the
rule of law
we have had a decade of successive tory
governments obsessed with chipping away
any institutions or activities that can
strain or hold them to account trade
unions charities the electoral
commission our courts our eu membership
obviously now it's human rights and
protesters yet again
in the firing line
to this government even international
law is almost inconsequential broken
quite readily whether in a specific and
limited way or a complete trashing of
the refugee convention you're here so
deputy speaker this is a government too
often pursuing pet obsessions and
short-term headlines instead of dealing
with the basics while people struggle to
heat their homes and put food on the
table because of the cost of living in
crisis instead of the action we need the
government imagines up a brexit
freedom's bill still trying to escape
brussels six torturous years on after
the brexit referendum
mr deputy speaker there were newspaper
reports of a cabinet rebellion but a
cabinet rebellion to stop imports of
foie gras being outlawed
how about mr speaker a rebellion to
protect workers rights or human rights
or to help our constituents heat their
homes and put food on the table this is
a government that is out of touch
and these skewed priorities are just as
evident in the sphere of justice and
home affairs
two departments cut to the bone by a
decade of austerity pursuing obsessions
pet projects and ridiculous headlines
instead of taking the action and making
the investment that is required to
deliver the decent public services that
we need them to deliver
this government is just not getting on
with the job
people just want their passports
delivered on time
because despite all the fuss made by the
brexiteers it doesn't matter what colour
those passports are if they arrive too
late the home secretary very generously
agreed to take away individual cases but
i think she will find that her inbox is
absolutely overflowing with thousands of
emails if we take her up on that
and if the government is to insist on
ukrainians applying for visa something
that we continue to argue that they
should not those visas need to be
delivered speedily
and efficiently because leaving those
fleeing war in limbo is unforgivable the
home secretary would seem to talk up the
fact that 19 000 had arrived here i
salute the generosity of british people
opening their homes but there are 27 000
in ireland already a country that's
something like 113th the size of this
country this country is not being
allowed to step up to the plate by the
bureaucracy put in place by this home
secretary
in fact mr deputy speaker the whole
asylum and immigration system needs sped
up decision making improved and the
hostile environment ditched and for
those who are victims of that hostile
environment we need an overhaul of the
windrush compensation scheme because it
is appalling that people continue to die
without seeing a penny of what they are
doing
and if the government is serious about
the lessons learned from that disaster
we need a more serious
set of actions to implement wendy
williams recommendations including a
migrants commissioner
all of these very basic issues need
addressed but that is not what we get in
this queen's speech instead we have
further attacks on our rights but before
i turn to the main offenders in the
legislative programme let me highlight
the bill for which we will offer some
support and bring some light to the home
secretary's afternoon
mr overhaul of espionage laws is badly
overdue as we know from the russia
report and from the law commission and
various other sources
we need a more resilient state with
espionage laws fit for the 21st century
and able to keep pace with ever-changing
threats that we face
however we will always watch out for
proper oversight and mechanisms to
ensure that these powers are not abused
by government and will press the case
for a public interest defence you're
here mr speaker we welcome the economic
crime bill again long overdue with
honorable friends such as member for
governor central among the voices that
have been calling for action for years
on end
we've previously welcomed the online
safety bill and we recognize it's truer
now than ever that feeling safe requires
regulation of the online as much as the
offline
and we do also support the ideas
mentioned in relation to the modern
slavery bill particularly around action
on supply chains
but any modern slavery bill worthy of
the name should be repealing some of the
provisions of the ods borders act passed
just last month that will undoubtedly
make life worse not better for victims
of trafficking including those who face
being sent to rwanda we're here and we
will engage positively though cautiously
with discussion around protect duty and
that draft bill
but these are not the dangerous
obsessions or pet projects i was
referring to alone mr deputy speaker
those are of course
coming in to us in the form of
legislation to meddle with the human
rights act and to undermine yet again
the right to protest
mr deputy speaker the human rights act
works well and has benefited many
the government knows this because it was
told so by its own independent review
body which noted that many so-called
problems with the act are more to do
with perception than the reality
perceptions that require to be remedied
through a focus on human rights
education not a radical overhaul the
joint committee on human rights has also
done its
excellent work highlighting the
enormously positive impact of the act
and the protection of human rights in
the uk concluding firmly that no case
for reform have been established
this is about people being able to have
a practical means of enforcing our human
rights challenging unlawful government
policies and securing justice you're
here it's about ensuring people
interacting with the state whether it's
a police or in care homes or hospitals
are treated with dignity and respect our
public services are better not worse for
being fully accountable to our
constituents in the courts here instead
of having to travel to strasbourg to
vindicate their rights and this is what
the government risks undermining and
damaging and as i say not delivering
justice but seeking to protect itself
from it so we will oppose these
proposals every step of the way you're
here well these proposals mr dr speaker
tell us something much more fundamental
about the british constitution because
the human rights act is after all a
piece of legislation absolutely crucial
to the devolution settlement something
that hasn't been recognized at all in
the debate today along with the scotland
act it is absolutely fundamental in
setting out what the scottish parliament
and government can and cannot do it's
the same for wales and of course pivotal
too for northern ireland
not for the first time here is a tory
government fixing up the balance of
powers in the united kingdom not through
negotiation agreement and endorsement
but unilaterally without consent and
absolutely without cause
in most states in most countries such
fundamental changes would require
agreement approval in all the impacted
legislators sometimes even double
majorities sometimes endorsement through
referenda but here in the uk the tories
can rewrite the constitutional
settlement to suit themselves in the
blink of an eye such as a lack of checks
and constraints upon this government
mr deputy speaker a home office focused
on scotland would be tearing up the
immigration system that has served us so
badly left is without the people we
desperately need for our economy and
public services and undermine the rights
and security of so many of the people
that we have already welcomed it would
utterly reject an asylum system that is
expressly and increasingly designed to
make people suffer
and if we really want to prevent crime
and deliver justice we would be over
hauling the out-of-date misuse of drugs
act that exacerbates one of the most
persistent and difficult public health
challenges we face today
this is a scourge that is inextricably
linked with so much crime over crowded
prisons serious and organized crime
groups
county lines modern slavery drugs deaths
ruined life
the misuse of drugs act is not working
and in too many respects it's now
undermining efforts to tackle all of
these fundamental problems even very
obvious evidence-based policies such as
overdose prevention facilities remain
hugely difficult because of that act now
there were some very welcome steps in
the government's drugs strategy but for
real progress to be made we continue to
make the case for that act to receive a
radical review and overhaul mr deputy
speaker these are just some of the
things that we desperately need from
this home secretary and this government
but they will never be delivered it is a
department and a government that
delivers nothing of substance for the
people of scotland instead undermining
our rights and undermining the scottish
parliament this government will not
deliver mr deputy speaker more than
anything this queen's speech shows us
that we in scotland need to get on with
delivering for ourselves
nick fletcher
i am
preventing crime and delivering justice
surely if we get the first bit right we
don't need a second
wishful thinking i know but nevertheless
true
sadly we don't live in a perfect world
so justice is needed and the best
justice is swift justice justice delayed
is just as denied in the new year the
legacy of covert lives and so covid
lives in so many ways
i know that in the last session we've
been much to alleviate the pressures on
the justice system but we will have to
see
we have made new laws to protect our
borders
to me it never made sense to spend huge
amounts of money on a justice system and
continue to let people come in illegally
am i saying these people are all
criminals not necessarily not
necessarily but it doesn't look good on
anyone's cv how did you arrive in this
country well i gave a people smuggler
all my cash and i hope to beat the
system
unacceptable no it had to be dealt with
and i hope with what we have put in
place it will do just that
we have given toughen sentences for many
crimes and even though i'm not a
believer necessarily that a 25-year
sentence will deter some of the
devastating crimes that happen it will
at least keep these people off the
street for a much longer period
and help the poor victim move on
as for the victims i welcome the victims
bill too this is the right thing to do
and i hope it will make a huge
difference in how victims are treated
and hopefully encourage more to come
forward
well today i want to talk about
prevention
you see my position as chair of the appg
issues
on appg on issues affecting men and boys
i am fully aware of the statistics about
men in crime
ninety-five percent of the prison
population are men
just let me know about you again
95
of the prison population are men
if this was a statistic for any other
demographic there will be a public
outcry
so why isn't that
i'll tell you the house why not it's
because that's what we've become to
expect of a large number of our
population
men are bad
but i say to this house no
no no
that's not true
far too many men and boys are being
forgotten left behind
ignored
and now they have been increasingly
vilified toxic masculinity impose a
curfew on all men yes that was seriously
suggested
all men are bad
we cannot let this constant vilification
happen
i say here and now this has to stop me
we need to deal with this head-on and
ask ourselves this simple question
why why are men committing so much crime
why are so many women being murdered
attacked and abused why are so many men
being murdered attacked and abused why
do i have the answers to these questions
no not yet it's not simple but we need
to get there and i believe we could get
there a lot quicker
we need help with this
a minister for men and boys and minister
for their health and well-being a
national men's health strategy if we are
serious about fighting crime then let's
tackle the cause as well as the symptoms
mr deputy speaker i believe if we were
to start to ask these questions we will
protect our women and girls so much more
we will also protect our men and boys
too
but we must start asking the questions
now i have spoken with many people in my
position as an mp and as chair of the
appg and they agree with me
that we can't arrest ourselves out of
all crime
more police are great and we are getting
many
but if there was police on if we every
police officer was to go out on the beat
there would still be some streets
without a police officer
it's great that we are lighting roads
but i'm afraid attacks will still happen
on some of those roads and also behind
closed doors
what we have to do is ask why
why is this the case is it drugs
alcohol mental health or a bad childhood
experience
what drove them to drugs alcohol
depression and why aren't they talking
about their dreadful past
is it being the victim of a sexual abuse
or pornography is it the internet is it
being brought up in a dysfunctional
family or a community that does not
bring hope
is it peer pressure or gangs
why do young people join a gang
lots of questions but there are answers
and if we really want to protect one
another surely that's what we should be
doing finding those answers
i wrote an article last week in the
yorkshire post with an analogy that if
we have three faulty cars out of a
thousand would we ban all cars
will we build a hundred more hospitals
or wrap the pedestrians in bubble wrap
no we would try and find out what had
gone wrong with those cars and that is
what i believe we should do here with
that small minority of men and boys
i have been told in this position as
chair of this appg that i may get some
opposition
but i tell you the house i haven't well
not yet anyway
and the reason why i haven't is that if
anyone really thinks about this they
will see that i'm trying to help society
as a whole
so who would a men's minister speak to
well hopefully lots of men and lots of
women too
but in this place i expect them to speak
to the minister for education housing
health dwp dcms defense base the list
goes on but we need someone to see all
the problems that men face collate it
all and then speak to the home office
and say this is what's going wrong
it has to happen
we have to ask these questions and we
have to find the answers
i have a wife a daughter and a son i
want them all to go about their business
safe and happy we all want that so let
us use our heads with this
yes swift justice where required yes
long sentences were required but let us
try and prevent the crime happening in
the first place let's see what's gone
wrong with a small minority of our men
why are they in the criminal justice
system or why
they may end up being so and then when
we know we need a concerted effort to
fix the problem of source we need to fix
the faulty cars before they head for the
road
i know that the house will agree with me
that we will find it hard to manage
without cars
while we will find it much harder to
manage without men thank you
come again thank you thank you mr deputy
speaker
i don't often get the chance to
speak in the house i think
being the shadow minister without
portfolio it means you're the shadow
minister with a lot to do but often
without the opportunity to say very much
but i'm delighted to be able to respond
to the debate today at the home
secretaries
just leaving the chamber but
in her absence
uh i want to say
and i think it won't do either her or i
very much could and i may even get
chased from this place by my own
colleagues but i like the home secretary
and i also like the police minister and
one of the things that i admire about
the home secretary even though i
profoundly disagree with her
is that she believes that definitely
won't do me any good the honourable
gentleman from a century position
but but one of the one of the things i
admire about the home secretary is that
she although i profoundly disagree she
believes in things
but despite the virtuoso performance
today at the dispatch box i don't think
she believes some
of the accusations that she leveled at
the opposition i don't think for a
second that the government thinks
that an opposition led by a former
director of public prosecutions who
prosecuted and made sure terrorists were
put in prison and the worst short of
criminals and offenders or any sort of
threat to
national security so we can argue about
policy and about records and around
delivery but let's not kid ourselves or
the british public because
frankly
they don't believe it either
but i want to before i come on to my
main
remarks about the
the
loyal address itself i do want to use
the opportunity given the topic of
today's debate
to place on record my thanks and my
admiration for merseyside police led by
our chief constable serena kennedy we
have been
blessed with
good leadership in merseyside using all
of the tools
to provide a robust policing response to
things that matter to people in saint
helens and across
that merseyside crime and anti-social
behavior tackling them at the root cause
and giving no quarter to those criminals
who would
terrorize our
communities and i stand squarely behind
our police force the men and women of
merseyside police who day and daley put
themselves in harm's way to keep us in
our our communities safe
turning to the
the wider aspects
of the program or lack thereof that the
government set out i think
there was a chance here a guilt-edge
chance actually for the
government to grab this cost of living
crisis by the scruff of the neck and i
think more than that actually it was a
chance to lay the work after the
pandemic
for prosperity and renewal across our
communities to set a pathway to a secure
future
one that i think has never felt further
away from any of our citizens but is so
badly needed and i
i i somewhat regret i mean the house
won't be surprised to hear this but i
regret to say that i think the
government missed the
opportunity to do that now it matters
because it's not just about the theater
of the state opening it matters because
it's a profoundly worrying juncture i
think
for our country inflation is soaring and
predicted to rise
further to some 10 percent fuel and food
prices are sky rocketing
and the tax rises imposed by this
government 15 of them
are hitting working people particularly
to introduce
a national insurance hike
attacks on working people is the wrong
tax at the wrong time
on their own people and it's clear from
when i speak to
residents my neighbors in saint helens
their families pensioners businesses
and many other local community groups
this crisis
is really affecting people
and they are really worrying about how
they will cope and that was the stark
reality mr deputy speaker that i heard
from community
groups in saint helens recently at a
meeting that i convened
and with some of those working with
our community and residents who are
affected by this now they tell me and
statistics that have been
borne out and provided
by very reputable sources that nine and
ten have already seen a rise in the cost
of living are already experiencing more
expensive energy bills and are seeing
more costly groceries on their weekly
shop nearly a quarter of adults finding
it difficult to pay their usual
household bills and worryingly food bank
usage in saint helens north has risen by
nearly 900 users over the last year
including 300 children in the united
kingdom in the 21st century in a town
like saint helens and our food banks are
also
it's not often cited but they're
wrestling with a 30 reduction in
donations because people who previously
gave to the food bank
have to look after themselves now
because they can't afford
to do that anymore and of course our
transport costs are rising and making it
harder to get to work to see family and
friends and be connected now this would
have a huge impact on
inequality because even before the
crisis the sixth of households in my
constituency were in fuel poverty which
is why i was very pleased that a central
plank of the labour party's offer to
the people in the local election
campaign was about putting up the 600
pounds back in their pocket now by
levying the windfall tax on the excess
profits of the oil and gas company who
are printing money to all intents and
purposes because of the increase
in costs now at a time i think when the
government should be using every policy
lever it can to deliver security it had
no answer this week now mr deputy
speaker i've said this before our
communities are resilient we've been
through a lot these last two years in
fact over the last 20 or 30 years but
people came together to meet the
challenges particularly under the banner
of saint helens together with the spirit
of generosity kindness and solidarity i
can't read what some commentators wish
to believe
communities in the north of england are
not homogeneous we're not
all the same the challenges we face are
new ones but our sense of place is
important and that's the case in saint
helens we're proud of that and we remain
stayed fast
in our ambitions for a better and secure
future and that's why and it's a point
that i've consistently made it's not
just about me criticizing the government
part of that
part of my job as an opposition mp is of
course to do that but it's not enough
because i have agency i'm a member of
parliament i'm a political leader too
and so just attacking the government or
what it's failing to do it just doesn't
wash for people in saint helens
or
my constituents because they want to see
action
and that's why
in taking responsibility we as political
business and community leaders are
addressing the big challenges facing our
towns villages in the liverpool
city region now whether that's
regenerating our town centres to a
historic innovative 200 million pounds
partnership with the english citizen
cities fund
or the 25 million of innovative projects
secured from the town's fund investing
record amounts in children's services
and focusing on educational attainment
the next generation creating decent jobs
secure jobs skilled jobs training and
opportunities through world world
leading initiatives like glass futures
our regeneration of former colliery
sites like parkside they're not just a
monument you know to those who work
there proud as we are of that heritage
they're not just a monument
they are places that are going to create
new employment opportunities for a whole
new generation of people across
our
coal fields
we are revolutionizing public transport
taking steps to bring
buses back into public ownership and our
bid to bring real home to where it
originated with the rain hill trials to
saint helens with our bid to host the
headquarters of great british railways
in our border now that approach
was endorsed again last week where
labour in
saint helens
increased its vote share
stood for election on its record in an
ambitious manifesto and is now back
forming a new administration in our
country with a strong mandate to
continue so i close by
saying disappointed as i am
expectedly of course with what the
government has or indeed hasn't come
forward with in its legislative program
it's not an excuse for me or anyone else
to advocate responsibility i know that i
have a job to do for my community and we
are taking responsibility because we're
proud of our past we're ambitious for
our future but i would stress to the
treasury bench people are worried and
there are huge fears around the cost of
living and what it means for their
families and it does cloud the present
and it makes it more difficult to be
optimistic about the future i wish the
government would do more to help me and
saint helens my constituents but also
help people across the country we should
do more i wish it would give us
help to get through
this cost of living crisis but also push
on with our plans to build a better and
brighter future but as always you know
winston helens if they don't we just do
it ourselves mr deputy speaker
okay sunderland
mr deputy speaker it's a great pleasure
to be called in this debate um
law and order is a subject that's close
to all of our hearts and judging by the
passionate contributions so far in this
debate i think it certainly is
i'm not going to talk for long today but
what i want to do is to do two things
first of all i want to provide a
constituency perspective a local
perspective which i think is relevant
but also what i want to do is outline
the reasons why i feel that the measures
outlined yesterday in the queen's speech
for law and order and the prevention of
crime are really important
which is my constituency is the safest
major town in berkshire
and it's the 21st safest town in the uk
it's a great accolade and these um stats
that are taken from the uh the crime
rate dot co dot uk website and i would
urge everyone to look at them
the overall crime rate in brattle was 60
crimes per 1000 people in 2021 and this
compares favorably to berkshire's
overall crime rates coming in 25 percent
lower
than the rate of 75 per 1000 that's
really good east berkshire is a pretty
good place to live the offer is
excellent good schools we've got good
roads we've got near full employment and
i'm very proud to represent people who
live in brattle constituency
um in krothorn which is um deemed to be
a small town on the analysis it's
probably a village
but it's um 43 crimes per 1000 people
coming in 76 lower
than the berkshire overall crime rate at
sandhurst the overall rate is 45 crimes
for 1 000 people coming in 69 percent
lower than the berkshire rate and lastly
finch hampstead certainly a village
categorized as one of the top five
safest small towns or areas in the whole
of berkshire
and has a rate of 36 crimes per 1 000
people
the most common crime recorded in my
constituency is violence against the
person and also sadly sexual violence so
we have work to do and therefore i
welcome a number of the measures that
have been announced in the queen speech
i don't want to wax too lyrical about
what we've already heard the home
secretary has covered all of the detail
but we've got the public order bill
we've got the economic crime and
transparency bill we've got the modern
slavery bill the national security bill
we've got the draft protect duty bill
and the online safety bill but what i
want to do briefly is just focus on
three of them firstly the draft victims
bill in my view will set out to restore
victims confidence that their voices
will be properly heard and that
perpetrators will be brought to justice
that's really important for my
constituents
the online safety bill which creates a
new regulatory framework that improves
the use of safety online that will
safeguard freedom of expression making
the uk one of the safest places to be in
the world to be online
and lastly the bill of rights
real relevance locally it will ensure
that there is a proper balance between
the rights of individuals our vital
national security and effective
government therefore strengthening
freedom of speech our common law
traditions and reducing reliance on
strasbourg case law post brexit and
rightly so
in addition some other areas to focus on
firstly
13
500 new police officers in this
parliament
so far as part of that manifesto
commitment to put 20 000 extra police
officers on the streets we're getting
there in thames valley alone so far an
additional 368 police officers with the
further
233 projected
outflow this year this is great news for
bracknell that's great news of berkshire
and it's great news at thames valley
drug strategy in county lines
the commitment reducing your drug
strategy is really important
we need to break up county lines break
up criminal gangs we need to help those
struggling who are the victims of crime
but we've seen so far the closure of
1500 county lines 600 operations against
organized crime groups and more than 220
000 drug seizures these are really
impressive figures and we can't go
further
i welcome all of these bills therefore
on their inherent merits and because
they will make a difference
crime prevention
200 million
offered for a 10-year youth endowment
fund the public order bill we've
discussed it but it's so important that
people can go about their daily business
to get to work the ambulances can get to
hospital
nobody has the right to impede how
anybody else lives their life
and those who chain themselves to
railings and glue themselves to the road
they need to be in jail fact
i just want to finish with three key
points that are very important to me
locally and to my constituents
firstly anti-social behavior
needs stronger powers we have a lot of
it in bracknell and across the wider
constituency right across the uk i think
we need a bit more
in terms of dealing with anti-social
behavior in terms of police response in
terms of arrest at the sea
anti-social driving is another feature
locally on saturday evening
at birch hill sainsbury's in bracknell
we had
a big car meet fine i love cars a
motorsports fan i chair the motorsports
appg
but activity like that needs to be
managedly controlled we had
people spinning cars donuts tyre smoke
huge noise it got to the point where
residents were being assaulted this
cannot happen i would urge first of all
sainsburys to lock their car parks at
night if the shops aren't open what an
easy way of dealing with it but also i
would urge bradley forest council the
thames valley police and crime
commissioner thames valley police to
deal more responsibly with these
incidents because they just cause misery
for all those concerned we've got to cut
down on speed we've got to cut down
anti-social driving we've got to cut
down on noise nuisance it's really
really important
two further points before i finish
luke inge a constituent of mine
was jailed at the age of 18
for a fray
he's now 37 years old he's still in
durham prison
he's done his time in my view here's
what's known as an ipp prisoner an
imprisonment for public protection
prisoner he has an internment sentence i
think we need to review if i may
minister ipp prisoners to make sure that
we're not looking people up beyond the
point in which they have to be he's done
his time let's please release him and my
last point
young stacy queripel aged seven years
old
she was found dead murdered in woods in
bracknell 29 years ago i therefore think
we need to focus a bit more on cold
cases and cold case reviews i want to
see more police resources
given to that particular crime and all
those like it nobody has been brought to
justice in 29 years and the family still
resides in bratwurst i think we can do a
bit more in terms of cold case reviews
to conclude mr speaker i'm very happy
with the announcements made yesterday
i'm very supportive of the government i
think the bills will make a difference
but i also think we can go further thank
you
sami wilson
thank you mr deputy speaker
and i appreciate being called early in
this debate can i say that the
queen's speech
i think was being looked forward to by
many people not just in this house but
those who've been affected by the huge
problems which were risen as a result of
coming out of the pandemic
the hospital waiting lists the impact on
the economy and now of course the cost
of living increase as well as events
internationally and in the world whether
that's in eastern europe or further
afield and we wish the government well
in seeking to address those problems
we will be critical of many of the
measures
but we believe that it is important that
the government has highlighted the right
priorities to deal with the cost of
living crisis i believe
needs to be addressed very very quickly
because so many people are now
struggling
to face the ordinary day-to-day expenses
which um they face not for luxuries but
for basic necessities
and in my view
the government does need to act quickly
through putting money back in people's
pockets
i believe that
individuals are best
placed to decide how they spend their
money
and i want to understand the problem
which the prime minister and the
chancellor's outlined about huge debt
and the debt and having to pay that debt
back
nevertheless the inflationary pressures
which have occurred over the last number
of months
have given the government a windfall
it has given the government finance
which is available for tax cuts
and against the background of having
imposed the heaviest tax burden
on the people of this country since the
1950s
i think that one of the ways of dealing
with
this issue
is to make immediate tax cuts there's a
benefit in doing that it puts
money in people's pockets immediately
and secondly by not having complicated
schemes
it then ensures that the
the benefits
and the people obtain
are seen to be
come directly from um the westminster
parliament
one of my concerns
about the the the union is that very
often
things which occur and benefits which
occur because of
scotland wales and northern ireland
being part of the fifth biggest economy
in the world
are hidden
because the money is devolved down to
the regions we get complicated schemes
and then of course the benefits are seen
not to come from being part of the
united kingdom but from the actions of
devolved administrations and i think
that
the government should consider
how can you quickly address this issue
and secondly how can you ensure that
people understand
that the benefits have come because
they're part of the united kingdom as a
unionist
i would advocate that that's a stance
that the the government should take
we welcome many of the initiatives which
the law and order and and justice issues
which are in this um the bill
i think that it's right that we address
the the issue of slavery and i hope that
that does delve into this the supply
chains where many of us
obtain cheap goods
because firms are careless as to where
they source those goods i don't want to
get
cheap clothes
because somebody has been exploited
in a third world country and the the
suppliers are the the people who sell
those goods haven't looked in
to
where the supplies come from i also
welcome the initiative on economic crime
and i hope that
the the government will recognize that
it's not just those who engage in
economic crime but those who assist them
in against engaging in economic crime
have to be dealt with
in the legislation and as far as
destructive protests i'm not averse the
protest mister that we speaker indeed i
haven't i have involved myself in many
protests over the years of my political
involvement
but i think that we have to
get the balance between giving people
the right
to
have their say about issues which
concern them
while at the same time ensuring that
they do not deliberately and callously
and selfishly
deny others the ability to go about
their business
i witnessed it firsthand the good people
of canning time where i stay when i'm in
london
who
in their frustration at being denied the
ability to go to work as one guy said to
me and i'm not repeating exactly his
words because i don't think it'll be
parliamentary i don't think you would
you would help me but as one guy said to
me as we stood on a packed uh platform
and cunning time
he pointed out he says
i i don't get the work today i don't get
any wages
and yet those people sitting on top of
the tube
think that it doesn't matter
their
concerns are more important than my
ability to go to my work and i think it
is right that the government does take
action to ensure that um those who
engage in this selfish
um
behavior
those who
smugly think that their cause is more
important than anybody else's um
welfare should be dealt with
of course not all of these measures will
apply to northern ireland because
many of these things are devolved to the
northern administration but there are
many other measures in this bill which
will not apply to northern ireland
because northern ireland is not treated
as the same as the united kingdom
and i look at some of the things which
the prime minister said yesterday we
were going to to have to for example
to encourage economic growth
we're going to have a bonfire of
regulations european regulations will be
no bonfire they'll not even be a
matchstick
in northern ireland when it comes to
european regulations because of course
we will stay within and do stay within
the single market
of the european union it'll be illegal
for these regulations and this bonfire
of regulations to apply to northern
ireland and yet that is one of the key
ways in which the government says it
intends to level up
economic activity within the united
kingdom and yet northern ireland will be
exempt
dealing with fuel bills
the energy
legislation which will be um
put through this house cannot apply to
northern ireland because northern
ireland is part of the single
electricity market
any attempt to give the support
to putting in an uh an energy
infrastructure
would fall foul of the the
rules when it comes to state and which
apply to northern ireland
and when it comes to
the issue of support
many of the support mechanisms indeed we
have had the the example in this house
where the chancellor
couldn't even fulfill the manifesto
promise of the party opposite
that when we left the eu
the government be free to reduce
vat on fuel bills
it couldn't do it
why because that reduction in v.a.t
could not apply to northern ireland
and yet
we're told that
this protocol and i heard the
former prime minister yesterday uh say
that this
we couldn't possibly
to do anything
to um disrupt the protocol
the protocol was put in place and in a
crime and a debate on crime and on
threats of crime i think it's important
to remember
that northern ireland's different
position in the united kingdom mr w
speaker
was due to the threats
that were made by the irish prime
minister
by
certain political parties in northern
ireland some of which sit here some of
which don't sit here and indeed by some
members of this house
that if we did not
have separate arrangements for northern
ireland
then we would face violence in northern
ireland the protocol
is
the baby
of threats of crime and threats of
northern ireland
in the united kingdom
i thank the honourable member for giving
away would he agree with me he's just
mentioned the the the former prime
minister the right of a member for
maidenhead and that she made an
unfortunate reference yesterday which
was inaccurate in that she seemed to
allude to the fact that we could have
avoided this if we had backed her
proposals when in fact we would have
been in exactly the same position had gb
diverted from the the eu regulations and
that was very unfortunate and it gives
us an opportunity now to rectify that
error yeah and in fact under the foreign
prime minister proposals not only would
northern ireland be subject to single
market routes it'd been subject to
custom union roads which have meant we
couldn't even have benefited from the
early trade deals which the government
has now done across the world and
thankfully that is not the case and we
we still do have access to those trade
deals and firms in northern ireland are
benefiting from it and indeed i can
think of one in my honourable friends
constituency in southampton where a firm
has set up exclusively
to export machinery which it will
produce to the australian market as a
result of the deal which we have now
with uh with australia
so there are benefits uh huge benefits
of being separate from the res from the
eu but uh mr deputy speaker i think it
is important that we highlight
that
many of the issues
which and many of the measures which the
government intends to introduce
for the rest of the united kingdom
cannot apply to northern ireland as a
result of the northern iron protocol one
of the reasons why as my uh honourable
friend the member for lagoon valley said
yesterday
that until this issue is addressed
then the northern ireland assembly
cannot possibly function
we are told that northern ireland
without the protocol but could become a
hive of economic crime which has been
dealt with in this bill because people
would bring goods into northern ireland
smuggle them through northern ireland
across the irish border and contaminate
the eu market
of course
very little trade actually goes through
northern ireland
into the aries republic
indeed supermarkets which don't even
have shops in the irish republic are
subject to these trades what economic
crime they're going to involve
themselves and i don't know
but nevertheless that's the rationale
which is attached
to the protocol
and
the only leverage which we have
and indeed for the sake of good
governance in northern ireland
this issue must be addressed
because
we will not
no you no unionist in northern ireland
will accept
the divisiveness of the protocol and
economic damage
that means that when it comes to the
working of the assembly you'll not get
consensus if you don't get consensus
then that you'll you'll have all kinds
of divisions and so the assembly can
possibly work and therefore it is
important that um this issue be
addressed mr deputy speaker
in conclusion let me say this
that
if justice is to be done
to the people in northern ireland
and if we are not to give into
the threats of criminal behavior by
those who are opposed to getting rid of
the northern ireland protocol
then um
the government must take action i hope
i'm disappointed that there was no
action
highlighted in the queen's speech
but i would say to honourable members in
this house
this is not solely a northern ireland
issue
i've already highlighted vat on fuel
bills was on it reduced because of it
there's another bill which is absent in
this
the uh and the queen's speech
we were promised and i think i i believe
that there's almost universal support
for improvements in animal welfare
i don't think that most people in the
united kingdom want to see the continued
import of trophies as a result of
hunting across the world
i don't think i'm weather conservative
i don't think that most people want to
see the import of foie gras where
animals are cruel
birds are cruelly treated in order to
produce that
i don't think that most people want to
see the importing of
furs
and yet those bills have
that those measures are not in the
queen's speech even though they were
the government indicator that would be
doing it why
because northern ireland being part of
the single market
would be you can't ban them in that part
of the united kingdom it will become the
back door
and therefore many of the animal welfare
measures
which are um
not in this bill are not in this bill
because of the northern armed protocol
and i i we haven't even tested the state
aid rules in the rest of the united
kingdom so this measure this issue needs
to be dealt with and i would implore the
government do not delay on this there
may be divisions in the cabinet
there may be divisions even
with some of the the conservative party
and there may be some in this side of
the house who really don't care that
it's impacting on the good friday
agreement the stability in northern
ireland and the ability of people in
northern ireland to share the same
benefits as arrests united kingdom but i
can assure you that this party my party
will be doing everything we can
on a weekly basis to raise this in the
house of commons to resist with
ministers and to use whatever leverage
we have back home to ensure that uh the
political institutions were not
contaminated by the good
now then
nobody should feel unsafe in their
streets or in their homes which is why i
think preventing crime is probably the
most important part of this queen speed
so and each time we have a debate on
this subject in this place it always
seems that the labour party seemed to
side with the criminals and i'm not sure
yet why that is but it always seems to
happen every single time and the queen's
speech it serves as a bit of a reminder
to to everyone here that we are the only
party who's serious about law and order
in the uk that is true now the vast
majority of decent hard-working people
in this country will welcome the new
public honor bill because we see it is
these mindless people uh almost on a
weekly basis now they've got nothing
better to do than wreak havoc on our on
our streets on motorways at petrol
stations and quite frankly you know the
hard-working people of this country have
fed up to the back teeth black teeth of
these people disrupting their very ways
of life and destroying our property time
and time again and i've seen them myself
when i've been out and about been gluing
themselves to property digging up lawns
throwing paint around performing
zombie-like dancers in the middle of the
road with no regards for decent
hard-working people in this school yes
zombie dancers a bit like a stranger's
bar at night time with the honourable
member for stoke stoke on trent north
talking kids wherever he is
but they've got no regards for decent
hard-working people in this country and
their guerrilla type tactics
they're disrupting emergency workers and
putting people's lives at risk and the
public have had enough
now we're pretty good at handing out
fines during the pandemic joint during
lockdown was dishing out big fines some
i think some are justified and some not
but i hope the government would look at
handing out some bigger fine to these
these uh these public nuisances who i
think it's a good idea to damage petrol
stations let's i suggest a 10 000 pound
fine going upwards to about 20 grand
that'll teach them i think you know when
they go back to mom and dad with these
10 grand fines that might be the
deterrent that they actually need
but let's just remind ourselves what
we've been up to as a party in
government
we're recruiting 20 000 new police
officers and i think already over 13 000
new police officers on our streets
making our streets safer
we've enshrined the police crime and
sentence and courts act into law giving
police extra powers to prevent crimes
and keep dangerous criminals off our
streets and this act
it stops the automatic early release of
daily dangerous violent and sexual
offenders and widens the scope for
police powers such as stop and search
and places a legal duty on local
authorities to actually work together
with the fire and rescue service to
police and criminal justice agencies and
labor voted against this and i'll tell
you what else they voted against they've
only voted against everything
in the police and crime deal
but in ashfield we're really benefiting
from a conservative government we've
just had 550 000 pounds through the
safer streets fund and this is going to
put cctv up in in some real dodgy areas
i've got in my time this is going to
make women and young girls feel safe
there's going to be safe hot spots where
they can reach out for help
and it's it's wonderful news for one of
the most deprived areas of of my of my
constituency we're putting up new
security gates from from the fund which
will which will secure alleyways these
are again asp hotspots these are making
people residents feel safe in their own
homes this is real action and on top of
that we've got new police officers with
the operation reacher teams in in
eastwood in ashfield these these are
going out and these are taking the most
undesirable people off our streets and
locking them up but the police have
always been a little bit frustrated that
the sentencing has not been enough for
these criminals but we've sorted that
through this new bill you know people
can get locked up for longer you know
what and i say so they should be it
makes people feel safer in ashfield and
eastwood it makes me feel safer and it
makes my family feel safer and it's only
right that when these criminals are
arrested and taken to the police station
and taken through the court system they
should be put away for as long as
possible make us all feel safe but
labour have also got no idea to about
the illegal crossings um the dinghies
the boats coming over the channel they
seem to be confused uh mr deputy speaker
they don't know the difference between
between an economic migrant um and a
genuine asylum seeker it's a shame
really you know you could have a chat
with me and my constituents in asheville
they'll put you right come up to my
witherspoons in kirkview and they'll
tell you the difference and they're
pretty good at it
i've got the giveaway
the member is saying that people on this
side of the house don't know the
difference between economic migrants and
genuineness he calls them asylum seekers
then the home office doesn't either
because the home office has
concluded that the vast majority of
those people in those boats are refugees
and should be recognized as such so
what's they got to say to the home
secretary i think thank you i think i'm
related for the intervention i think
that's that's the fault of the old
failing asylum system where people when
they get here they know how to fill the
forms out they you know they they've got
these lefty lawyers that say put this
this and this and this they fill the
forms out and hey presto about 80
percent get asylum say and it's wrong
it's absolutely wrong it's a it's a
burden on the taxpayer they're abusing
the system it's a bit like some benefit
cheats they do it don't they they they
abuse they say they're disabled and
they're not yes they do they do so come
on let's be right about it
but but mainly no mistake about it mr
deputy speaker if that lot got in power
uh cherished the thought of what not
joseph perished the thought if that lot
got in the cherished thought
if that like got in power this rwanda
plan would be scrapped within five
minutes they want to see open borders do
you want to let anybody know
you can find it now
i'll rather give way to the member for
he confirmed it now
but manoa state the rwanda plan would be
scrapped we'll be scrapped within five
minutes of that lot getting in power
uh but i welcome the comments made by
the member for centaurus north he's not
his place uh right now but he made some
sensible comments on food bank news mr
deputy speaker but i'd welcome anybody
on the opposite benches to come and
visit ashfield to my food bank which i
help out on on a regular basis and we've
got a great project in place at the
moment where
i'd rather give way
speaker thank you
my royal friend from ashfield would know
that there are two elements to most
sentences rehabilitation which is really
important because we can rehabilitate
criminals in prisons and put them back
on the streets uh hopefully reformed
characters but also deterrence
does he agree with me that deterrence is
an important function of any sentence
and that actually longer sentences may
well have the deterrent effect of saying
to people think twice please before you
commit that crime
i think my honourable friend for his
intervention it makes a good point not
only is it a great deterrent but the
longer they locked up in prison then
that's the longer amount of time they
cannot commit these horrible crimes he
makes a perfect point but i go back to
my point made about the the honourable
member saint ellens uh north who made us
some great comments about food banks but
my invitation is to everybody on that
side of the house come to ashfield and
work with me for a day in my food bank
and see that the the brilliant scheme
we've got in place well when people come
now for a food parcel they have to
register for a budgeted course and a
cooking course and what we do at the
food bank we show them how to cook
cheap cheap and nutritious meals on a
budget we can make a meal for about 30
pence a day and this is cooking from
scratch
we're glad to give away
the uh one of my mother giving away can
you ask me ask me a simple question
should it be necessary to have food
banks in 21st century
i think the honorable gentleman for for
his intervention makes a great point and
this is exactly my point so i invite you
personally to come to ashfield look at
our food bank how it works and i think i
think you'll see firsthand that there's
not this used this this massive use for
food banks in this country we've got
generation after generation who cannot
cook properly they can't cook a meal
from scratch they cannot budget the
challenge is there come come i'll offer
anybody you know you sat there with with
glazed expressions on your faces looking
at me like i've landed from a different
planet come come to ashfield come next
week come the week after come to a real
food bank that's making a real
difference to people's lives and we're
going to end now mr dr speaker because
you know they're not listening you know
the these these are a generation of mps
that never listen but the good news is
well it's bad news actually because this
labour party that they're out of control
they're out of touch and thankfully
they're out of power that's me done mr
deputy speaker
[Laughter]
well what i will say to the previous
speaker is that all of us have food
banks in our constituency we don't
really need to visit his because we're
perfectly well aware of the requirement
for them but the requirement for them is
not because people don't know how to
cook
it's because we have poverty in this
country at a scale that should shame his
government
now before i address the substance of
today's debate mr deputy speaker and in
particular their government's plans for
a british bill of rights
like others i'd like to refer to results
the results of the local elections last
week and because in scotland they were a
very important reminder that this
british government has no mandate in
scotland and no bad no mandate for any
of the policies it's seeking to impose
on scotland in the programme for
government and it's really no surprise
mr deputy speaker that the conservatives
lost so many votes and have been reduced
to third place in scotland when i was
campaigning on the doorsteps of
edinburgh south west i heard over and
over again the contempt in which this uk
government is held and it's not just the
endemic law breaking it's the rank lack
of respect for the frequently expressed
views of the scottish electorate for a
different way of doing things and for a
second independence referendum given the
broken promises of the first and mr
deputy speaker i'm particularly proud
that in my own constituency of edinburgh
south west and the pentlands hill ward
my colleague and friend fiona glasgow
displaced a tory councillor to win yet
another seat for the snp on the city of
edinburgh council and i'd like to take
this opportunity to congratulate her for
the fantastic campaign that she run
it's always good mr deputy speaker to
see women of independent mind elected to
public office
now it was suggested by the leader of
her majesty's opposition yesterday that
this queen's speech has no guiding
principle and he's right insofar as it
abjectly fails to make meaningful
proposals for reversing the cost of
living crisis
and that cost of living crisis is really
hammering my constituents as well as
constituents across the united kingdom
there's nothing in this speech about
cutting vat on fuel bills there's
nothing about taxing big companies not
just the energy companies but other
companies with excess profits there's
nothing to increase benefits and there's
nothing to reinstate the 20 pounds that
was cut from universal credit instead i
heard on the radio this morning that the
cabinet met yesterday to chuck around
ideas to deal with the cost of living
crisis but didn't come to any
conclusions
mr deputy speaker the lack of urgency
and the lack of focus of this government
is as insulting to my constituents as it
is callus nor does this queen speech
contain any measures to compensate my
constituents for the serial incompetence
of the home office not just in respect
of the handling of immigration and
asylum cases but also now the issuing of
passports lots of working-class families
in my constituency have lost out on hard
work for holidays and it's an absolute
disgrace and i'd like to know if the
government's going to compensate them
mr speaker i might not agree with
everything the leader of her majesty's
opposition says we disagree on the right
of scotland to self-determination and
i'd like to see him do more to stick up
for women's sex-based rights and the
rights of same-sex attracted people but
i do consider the leader of the
opposition to be a man of integrity and
i don't want to live in a state mr
deputy speaker where the government with
the assistance of their little helpers
in the right-wing press are able to
influence the police to reopen a closed
investigation into their political
enemies it stinks
and most of my constituents can see the
difference but what seemed between what
seems to have been a working meal and
the endless
parade of parties with suitcases of
booze and karaoke that took place at
number 10 during lockdown
people are not stupid
yesterday we were told in the queen's
speech that this government is going to
ensure the constitution is upheld i have
to say mr deputy speaker i had to
struggle to stop myself from laughing
out loud
this prime minister can't even uphold
the ordinary laws of the land and in
2019 he rode roughshod over the
constitution when he unlawfully proroged
parliament and that was just the start
of it in 2020 his government introduced
legislation designed to go back on an
agreement they themselves had signed
with the european union
and now they're still at it with the
northern ireland a protocol
mr speaker mr deputy speaker i think
there is a guiding principle of this
queen's speech and i think it's this
it's to diminish the ability of this
parliament and the courts to hold this
government to account
and we see it in the bill of rights
we see it in the public order bill and
we also see it in the brexit freedoms
bill which is going to expand executive
power to amend appeal or replace eu
retained law by way of secondary
legislation so this house can't
scrutinize it properly so much for
taking back control
now on the bill of rights mr deputy
speaker as has already been said
by my honorable friend the government's
independent review and the human rights
act
and the cross-party joint committee of
human rights of which i'm a member have
found that they claim that the case for
replacing the human rights act with the
british bill of rights has not been made
out
the independent review suggested only
very minor changes to the human rights
act noting that the vast majority of
submissions to that review
spoke strongly in support of our human
rights act
but this government didn't even bother
to address the findings of their own
independent review and instead publish
their own consultation on the same day
that the independent review reported
it's really quite extraordinary
and yesterday the right honourable
member for hulton price and howden who's
not in his place and for whom i have a
great deal of respect but i disagree
with him on this issue he tried to
suggest that the main reason for
modifying the human rights act is that
it will give the government the ability
to deport foreign criminals who've been
released from prison
well in our recent and very thorough
report on human rights reform dated 13th
april the joint committee of human
rights examined that claim in some
detail
and we found it to be unsubstantiated by
the data produced by the government and
for anyone who's interested those
arguments are set out at paragraphs
223 to 234 of our report
we also found that the government's case
that human rights legislation is in
serious need of reform is not proven
this is not evidence-based policy making
and we concluded that the government's
purporting to solve non-existent
problems
and offering solutions that will only
cause confusion and detriment to those
who need their rights protected
we said that if the government really
wanted to strengthen human rights they
would improve how they are respected in
general and improve education so that
everyone knows their rights and improve
access to the courts for those needing
to enforce them
improving awareness and understanding of
human rights and access to the courts
would have a far more beneficial impact
than the government's current proposals
now mr deputy speaker that's a
cross-party report and it was unanimous
so the government should listen to it
and they should also listen to listen to
the conclusions of the independent
review that they themselves commissioned
now of course there's a particular
scottish angle
to reform of the human rights act and
this has been highlighted in a previous
report of the joint committee of human
rights where we recommended that any
proposals to reform the human rights act
should not be pursued without the
consent of the scottish parliament again
that was the recommendation of a
cross-party committee and it's in tune
with the position of the
scottish government
now
human the human rights act itself is a
reserved matter but human rights per se
in scotland are not reserved and we have
our own scottish human rights commission
a-listed by the united nations which is
very concerned about the government's
plans to replace the human rights act
with the bill of rights and indeed where
the joint committee of human rights is
taking further evidence about that this
afternoon
mr deputy speaker the human rights act
which we already have in this country is
in fact a bill of rights
and there's two characteristics of a
bill of rights first of all that they're
universal the rights apply to everyone
not just the people who the government
find it convenient to give rights to
and secondly that it's a higher law and
that's why we have the section three
interpretive obligation
in the human rights act as it stands and
if you take these things out as the
government's proposing to do then it's
not in fact actually a bill of rights
now everyone knows that the tories or
some of them at least have been wanting
to get us out of the european convention
of human rights for some years
but the reality is those same tories
they're cheering now but your leader uh
their leader mr deputy speaker signed an
agreement with the european union
when we left which means we can't leave
the echr so actually this british bill
of rights idea is just a sneaky little
way to try and diminish people's ability
to enforce uh their rights
under
the echr
now nobody has so far this afternoon has
mentioned the plans for a ban on lgb
conversion therapy and i'd like to say
that i support that
ban although i do think the evidence for
how much it's a contemporary problem is
questionable but it was certainly a very
serious problem in the past
i'm just going to develop my argument
before i give way however i'm concerned
the honourable members are coming under
pressure to support a ban on what's
described as trans conversion therapy
which ignores the interim report of the
cast review and the testimonies of
tavistock clinic whistleblowers and d
transitioners
now there's an exponential rise in the
number of girls seeking to transition mr
deputy speaker and many of these girls
will be same-sex attracted and it's
important that this possibility and
other explanations for gender dysphoria
such as autism are able to be explored
in a respectful way with the qualified
therapist before young women embark on a
road to medicalisation
experiencing gender dysphoria in
childhood or puberty doesn't necessarily
mean that you are trans
thousands of adult lesbians and gay men
like myself will know this to be true
and i think it's really important that
honourable members understand that trans
inclusive means assuming all children
who say that they are the opera opposite
who say they are the opposite sex
are transgender and it also means
insisting they don't need psychotherapy
if they say they don't want it
and hillary cass former president of the
royal college of pediatrics and child
health has been commissioned to report
on nhs gender identity services for
children
and her interim reports published a
couple of months ago has provided
worrying information about the lack of
normal clinical standards being applied
to children with gender distress
more work needs to be done but the
interim results show a high proportion
of care for children
those with autism or experience of abuse
and children who'd be likely to grow up
as lesbian or gay presenting for gender
services so i'm advocating for
evidence-based policy making let's wait
for the outcome of the cast report
and let's not be influenced by those who
want to criminalize therapists who
simply want to do their job and act in
their patients best interests we
urgently need proper informed debate in
public and in parliament and this must
centre on the well-being of children and
young people now we can only have those
sort of debates in this place and beyond
if we have free speech
the tories say they believe in free
speech and they want to better protect
it as a right
but mr deputy speaker actions speak
louder than words
the police act passed in the last
session the public order bill and the
online safety bill all contain potential
threats to freedom of expression
and one of the problems with the online
safety bill is the introduction of a
legal but harmful category for the
removal of content and this will create
a situation in which people will be
prevented from saying things that are
legal
but prohibited and there's a really
significant danger that the bill as
drafted will lead to censorship of legal
speech by online platforms and that it
will give the government unacceptable
controls over what we can and cannot see
online
now as a former sex crimes prosecutor i
completely
applaud
the desire to protect children online
which underlines the online safety bill
but i'm very worried that this category
of legal but harmful will will enable
vexatious complainants to exploit that
lack of definitional clarity to try and
shut down lawful speech
on topics of public concern that are
harmful and should be subject to
censorship and i don't know the
honourable gentleman over there wanted
to intervene earlier yeah
i'll give away him
it's my lucky day mr deputy speaker
the honourable members making the most
interesting speech
does she share my concern that the
weight between primary and secondary
legislation when it comes to the bill
she refers to is worrying
because some of the definitions are so
fundamental such as freedom of speech
that they should be laid before this
house
rather than knotted through by some
instrument or another whether negative
or positive procedure
i do
share that i don't think it's safe to
leave setting out definitions which was
an impact upon free speech to a
government minister in secondary
legislation particularly not a
government minister in this government
but really what i'm most worried about
is the online platforms because i don't
think the online platforms can be
trusted to police speech in a way that's
properly cognizant of the law
not just the law on freedom of speech
but also the law and freedom of belief
and domestic anti-discrimination law i'm
coming to our close very shortly but i
just want to take twitter as an example
because this is really important
twitter's hateful conduct policy does
not include the protected characteristic
of sex
and so twitter routinely censors
perfectly legitimate contributions to
the public debate on women's sex based
rights while routinely ignoring threats
of violence and worse to women
participating in the debate
and in october 2019 the joint committee
on human rights published a report on
democracy freedom of expression and
freedom of association in which we noted
that twitter has omitted sex from the
list of protected characteristics in its
hateful conduct policy we recommended
that they should remedy this and in may
2019 our twitter executive promised us
she would look into the issue but nearly
three years later nothing has been done
and this is a very real concern for the
online safety bill because when women
have challenged twitter's unfair and
discriminatory moderation policies
twitter have replied that they do not
consider themselves bound by the
equality act in relation to the services
they provide in the united kingdom
and their argument is that because
they're a company established in ireland
as opposed to the uk
they're therefore exempt under paragraph
two of schedule 25 to the equality act
now i'm not sure that that's right
but it's a loophole that could be closed
in the online safety bill and i've
already had some informal discussions
with ministers about
closing that loophole
so to conclude there's no point in
saying that we need a bill of rights to
protect free speech and then handing
over the policing of speech to private
companies such as twitter whose record
shows that they can't be trusted
so on free speech this government needs
to put its money where its mouth is
resto
mr deputy speaker and it gives me great
pleasure to speak in this debate as it
always does to speak on behalf of the
great people of peterborough
um whether i have this is the best job
i'm ever going to have and whether i
have it for two more years or for 22
years uh it's always a pleasure to talk
and the about the issues that concern
the great people of peterborough and one
of the great concerns they have is
around crime and disorder and they would
fully expect me to come to this place
and talk about some of those issues and
we're very pleased actually to note that
the number of police officers in
cambridgeshire is now at record levels
they've actually surpassed their
recruitment targets for the second year
in a row and it's incredibly welcome
that we now have more police as i say
than ever before that's 145
new police officers this year above the
um what's and this is on top by the way
of what is normal expected recruitment
levels and this is above uh their target
that's 1 671 police officers in
peterborough and cambridgeshire and
they're in
on the streets of peterborough right now
patrolling preventing crime and doing
the things that the people of
peterborough would expect them to do
we're also um at i think 13 570 extra
police officers uh recruited so far
that's above our 12 000 target which is
obviously good news for
the country
now i'm going to just really speak about
three
measures included in the queen's speech
in this this debate i'm going to talk
about the public order bill i'm going to
talk about the british bill of rights
i'm going to talk about the draft
victims bill
now
on the public order bill one of the most
popular
pieces of legislation from the last
parliament was the police crime
sentencing and
courts bill
and in front of what sort of way i was
delighted when i saw expected expectedly
labor politicians opposing this bill
both here obviously nationally and also
locally in my constituency because it
showed them quite honestly to be out of
touch with the genuine concerns of the
british people
i think
sometimes members opposites seem to
think that somehow twitter is somehow um
resemblance the actual representative of
public opinion well i've got news for
them mr deputy speaker it is not and the
people of peterborough are hugely
supportive of uh measures taken against
those who glue themselves to uh roads
those who disrupt ambulances disrupt
hard-working people going about their
ordinary business action against those
mindless fools who do that is hugely
popular in peter but as is by the way
measures against unauthorized uh travel
encampments which currently blight the
picturesque village of thorny in my
constituency preventing people uh using
thorny park for football games the cubs
are supposed to be using it i think this
weekend uh for for some activities and
unfortunately um this unauthorized
encampment is preventing people from
enjoying that public space leaving
rubbish human waste and all sorts of
other
unspeakables in their way and costing
the taxpayers thousands for clear up
i'd thank the honourable member for
peterborough for giving away and um
enjoying his speech but
we all this summer we're frustrated that
road's been blocked ambulances not been
able to get through fire engines
but would you not agree with me that
actually the police already have the
powers to deal with these things and
that they should be using the powers
they have rather than adding others
which will restrict the rights of people
in reasonable fear
peaceful protest
the honourable mate lady makes a a
thoughtful
intervention and i agree with her that i
wanted to see the police quite often
actually act much tougher on people
blocking ambulances gluing themselves to
the sides of roads but what these powers
will do mr deputy speaker is give the
police further powers strengthen uh
those uh powers that they have in order
to get rid of those nuisances she quite
rightly um
identifies
this will add of course i will
would he not agree with me that
stopping people blocking roads
sending criminals back to the country
they come from
and ensuring that people are
are not enslaved to produce the goods
that we are project that we consume are
just common sense measures that most
people understand and most people agree
with
well my the honourable friend is
absolutely right he identifies that
these are issues that hard-working
people in this country
sentiments hard-working people in this
country completely agree with and i'm
glad to be on their side and i'd like to
ask honorable members of the labour
party to do me a favor please oppose
the public order bill because what that
will do it will allow me to demonstrate
to the people of peterborough that once
again the labour party are not in touch
with them their values or their concerns
so do us all a favor on this side of
house vote against the public order uh
bill and give us an opportunity to
demonstrate once again how out of touch
they are the second thing i wanted to
talk about was the bill of rights a
british bill of rights and i'd like to
remind members of this in fact was a
manifesto commitment uh to introduce
this a manifesto commitment by which i
was elected on and this conservative
government was elected with an atc
majority we have to do this we promised
the british people we would and and
that's i'm thrilled to say that's what
we're going to do it will rip up
labour's human rights act which um uh
enshrined the european court of uh human
rights into british law it will stop
criminals dodging deportation by
vexatious and continuing legal
challenges it will stop judges from
strasbourg overriding british
judges and it will protect free speech
and press freedom but more importantly
what it will also do as someone who
understands and understands that human
rights are important what it will also
do it will also restore public
confidence in the law and in human
rights and that's why it's so welcome uh
to be part of the uh queen's speech the
last thing i want to talk about is the
draft
uh victims bill
i feel sometimes
that
the criminal justice system
doesn't feel that doesn't resemble and
it certainly isn't on the side of the
victims of crime
this
principle the fact that we are looking
to legislate on this shows that this
government is on the side of victims we
want criminals to be scared
of the law we don't want the law-abiding
majority to be scared of criminals and
the victims code putting that on a
statutory footing will ensure that
victims voices are heard because mr
deputy speaker i recall a story of a
constituent who came to see me
in one of my advice surgeries i was told
by this local mum about her son
how this young man
was beaten up very very badly in a bar
in peterborough and she described
the experience of the criminal justice
system as almost re-traumatizing you
know she was pushed from pillar to post
and the very structures and the very
resources that she thought were in place
to support her and her son
they were fine wanting
and this really did
kind of stay with me she felt let down
uh and they felt that they didn't have
enough support when it really mattered
and that in some exchanges they were
meant they were made to feel almost like
the criminal themselves
rather than the victims of the crime and
mr deputy speaker we really must do
better and the draft
bill victims bill is uh designed
specifically to do just that so it's got
to be hugely welcomed mr deputy speaker
people in peterborough as i said at the
start of my speech
want to be seen want to have they want
to be tough on criminals they want to
make sure that we protect the british
public and they want to see natural
justice to be done we had that in part
in the last session of the police crime
sentencing and courts act as i said one
of the most popular pieces of
legislation in my constituency and in
peterborough i know mr deputy speaker
from the measures announced in the
queen's speech that once again members
on this side of house and this
government have shown themselves to be
in touch with the people of peterborough
and in touch with the british public
kerry mccarthy
thank you mr deputy speaker the
member for peterborough that's just
spoken um it was actually very revealing
what he said because he actually put on
the record that this is very much this
whole package of legislation most of it
is about party political advantage and
posturing and said not to straw men and
trying to create divisions that don't
really exist
um rather than actually trying to
address the real issues facing this
country at the moment in particular the
cost of living crisis and i don't think
he referred to that in his speech
what we have is the government wasting
parliamentary time bringing back with
the public order bill the culture wars
nonsense that we saw with the worst part
of the policing crime sentence in a
courts bill at that point it was about
attacks on statues which was obviously
very much based on the um what happened
in bristol and it's interesting he talks
about public opinion but a jury jury
trial actually then acquitted um some of
the protesters by the the colston statue
and um yeah that was very much an attack
on the whole black lives matters
movement and although i didn't agree
with the the fact that the statue was
removed in the way that it was it didn't
need a piece of legislation increasing
the maximum sentence for um damaging
statues to 10 years it was just about
party political um point scoring as i
said and now we've got the um measures
on climate change activists and again
that's trying to create a false divide
most people if you ask them want to see
greater action on climate change and
support the right to peaceful protest
while thinking that the tactics used by
some protesters are ill-judged
inconsiderate and counterproductive and
people who are very much involved in the
environmental movement will share my
opinion that some of the things that
we've seen do not help the cause at all
but i'm not convinced there needs to be
legislation on this rather than the
government working with infrastructure
providers to obtain injunctions again i
think that the reason this has been
brought forward is very much about those
headlines and um trying to stir up
antipathy
and it's also interesting that the
people that try to do that don't even
manage to pay lip service to the need to
address climate change when they do
the leveling up
um
they're related but i'm a little
confused is she saying that she's
content
for protesters to be
brought before the court in injunction
and punished either with a imprisonment
or a fine through an injunction process
a civil process
but wouldn't
support the same through a criminal
process
no i didn't say that at all what i'm
saying is i think the reason why the
government is bringing forth this
legislation is suspect and i'm not
convinced that the police are actually
need these powers if the government can
prove as the bill goes through that the
police are calling for these powers
because they weren't calling for the
increased powers that were brought in
under the policing bill they said that
they didn't feel those measures were
necessary so you know i i um
it the government it's now down to the
government to actually prove that the
injunction system doesn't work but as i
said i think that the um pro some of the
protests are ill-judged and um
uh inconsiderate to people going about
their daily lives and i think we're all
would all speak as one on that point the
leveling up and regeneration bill again
um
looks at first sight like it's a lot of
it is more about spin than substance if
it does genuinely give more powers to
local communities rather than
development developers that's a good
thing although the government's past
action on this front doesn't really
inspire confidence i do hope that as we
look at that
piece of legislation we can look at
what's happened i have a particular case
in my constituency where originally land
brisbane to meadows was designated for
housing by a previous administration
we've had real delays with
updating the local plan partly because
of the west of england haven't updated
their planning strategy and i think the
government rejected it so we now even
though we have a one city ecology
strategy that says we want to protect 30
of the land as green space
we can't
oppose the planning application on those
grounds because the previous local plan
is still in place and i think the
minister may have some experience of
this sort of issue in in previous roles
but um i would i hope that when we get a
chance to discuss this bill we can talk
about how we can make sure that um
planning rules do take into account a
city's desire to address the ecological
um crisis
i would quite like to have a
conversation with the secretary of state
about architecture and again this is
just there was he was quoted at the
weekend talking about poundbury which
was the village that um
the prince of wales has set up um
i happen to think the
i
on aesthetics rounds i i don't like
poundbury i don't think that it's um a
brilliant architecture um so i disagree
with the prince of wales and the
secretary of state on that but he in his
comments the the secretary of state just
set up this completely artificial
argument he was saying the opposition to
new housing development comes from quote
a few modernist architects who sneer at
what the rest of us actually like and
people who dislike anything that seems
small c conservative and that just isn't
the case the opposition to new housing
development is about people wanting
protect green spaces thinking that
there's not infrastructure available you
know worried about the impact it will
have on the road systems um on on local
facilities so it's not about people
saying we would accept this new housing
if only the architecture was was more
modern or that it's just it's just as i
said it's just it's just made up and
it's it doesn't do you for good
political debate if people are
constructing these straw men arguments
around these these things
privatization of channel four i think is
um an unnecessary and indeed a spiteful
move channel 4 is not broken and doesn't
need the government to fix it public
ownership is not a straight jacket as
the government
is trying to say it is the channel
invests more in independent production
companies outside london including in
bristol where it has one of its regional
hubs than any other broadcaster
um privatizing channel four could mean
one billion pounds in investment lost
from the uk's nations and regions with
over 60 independent production companies
at risk of going under
having to give away
um thank you very much thank the
honourable member for giving away she's
making a very very important point um
in my previous career i worked in our
organization which worked with channel 4
to encourage independent production
companies across this country and to
help them into the international market
and watching sunday's bafta awards it
was clear that channel 4 is an integral
part of our culture in this country so
would the honourable member agree with
me that everything we can do to protect
it rather than try and change it is what
the government should be doing
i entirely agree channel 4 is doing a
brilliant job and it's financially
viable and there's absolutely no reason
to seek to privatize it um
the long overdue online safety bill um
has had its second reason of of course
in the last session it's good to see
that fraud is included many of us will
have had constituents who fall and pray
to scammers it's disappointing however
that with so much of a delay in bringing
forward this bill and have with having
gone through the pre-legislative
scrutiny as well there's still so much
room for improvement the government
needs to focus on how harmful content
can be amplified and spread including
breadcrumb crumb in which leads to
smaller sites which often contain the
worst content um but the bill stands
this is these sites may well slip
through the net because the focus is all
on the larger providers i'm also
concerned that in the bill the
definition of what is harmful to
children will be left to secondary
legislation rather than set out on the
face of the bill that the government
hasn't accepted the laws commission's
recommendations on self-harm that
misogyny isn't a priority that state
disinformation from countries like
russia will still be allowed to thrive
and much more i hope that we can
significantly improve the bill during
committee and report stage
i welcome the renters reform bill and
the scrapping of no four evictions but
again there's been such an inexcusable
delay the legislation was promised three
years ago in that time the number of
people evicted in bristol from private
rented property through no fault of
their own has more than doubled
if i can speak now briefly about the
mental health act reform bill
it's another measure that's been long
promised but it's still only being
published in draft there's been some
terrible stories about people with
autism and learning difficulties being
detained long term without their consent
and also a disproportionate use of
sectioning for people from the
black community but this is a piecemeal
measure it only addresses one part of
the problem we know that mental health
services are not fit for purpose that
far too many people are waiting far too
long for diagnosis and treatment or not
getting help at all we know that when
children need residential services they
often face being sent hundreds of miles
away from home as beds aren't available
and that far too many people resort to
turning up at a e in mental health
crisis there is a balance to be struck
between giving
mental health patients control over
their treatment but making sure that
people who would be helped by stay in
hospital get this the help they need
the
um very recently it's been reported that
foi requests from 22 nhs trust reveal
that over half of the 5 403 prisoners
assessed by prison-based psychiatrists
as requiring hospitalization were not
transferred from hospital to prison
between 2016 to 21 and that's an 81
increase in the number of prisoners
denied a transfer in the previous five
years and there's a very high threshold
for that transfer request being met it's
people with is prisoners with major
psychotic illnesses or chronic
personality disorders they're being kept
in in prison rather than actually
getting the help that they need which is
not just you know i suspect that the
honourable members over there will think
that i'm being a wet liberal on this but
this is as much about preventing
reoffending
and um as as as supporting the prisoners
themselves
um
finally there are quite a few measures
missing from this bill that i'd have
hoped would be included including the
animals abroad bill given that we've
long accepted trophy hunting as well of
course given that we long ago accepted
that the production of foie gras and fur
in this country was inhumane and should
be prohibited there is no excuse now
that we have left the eu for not acting
to ban imports to it just shows the
warped priorities of this out of touch
government that would rather give in to
the demands of the pro hunting lobby on
its back benches and actually some in
the cabinet as well than enact one of
the few genuinely popular promises it
has made and trophy hunt is just an
example where very senior figures and
the conservative party have spoken out
about it got lots of good publicity on
this time and time again but where is
the legislation
except that
regardless of whether people are
supporters of the labour party
conservative party liberal democrats or
whatever there's a huge majority of
people in the united kingdom who
actually want to see these animal
welfare issues addressed but does she
also accept that one of the reasons why
it'd be difficult to implement any such
legislation is that northern ireland
cannot be covered by this and we've come
the back door into the united kingdom
for any of these things would be banned
by legislation here
okay i i agree with the i'm thankful for
the honourable members support for the
animal welfare measures given that i've
already been speaking for rather longer
than i intended to i don't think i can
unpick the northern ireland protocol um
today but um i hope that as we get on to
well actually there's not many tourists
here so maybe i can speak for another
half an hour but but um i i hope that
that is something as we we come to
talking about the the future of northern
ireland that we can look at the impact
it would have and whether we can still
proceed with this ban on imports without
completely upsetting the balance of
politics there
finally um mr deputy speaker what is
also missing from this the queen's
speech was any action to address the
cost of living crisis according to the
food foundation one in seven adults now
live in homes where people have skipped
meals eaten less or gone hungry energy
bills are skyrocketing rising inflation
is starting to bite we've heard about
the 15 tory tax rises and it is the
government's responsibility to mitigate
this suffering whether it's in through
measures in the queen's speech or
through introducing an emergency budget
which is much needed what we are seeing
in operation now is an active choice by
the chancellor by the prime minister by
the government to allow this pressure
this financial pressure on households to
continue a windfall tax on bp and shell
would hardly dent their enormous recent
profits of 12 billion pounds but while
my constituents remove items from their
shopping baskets spend their days on
buses to keep warm stress over bank
balances in the red the government has
refused to ask each act even tesco has
come out in support of a windfall tax
and i think the boss of bp said that it
wouldn't stop them from investing
labor has been clear that the best
solution to the cost of living crisis is
a green one yet this speech promised
nothing to help insulate homes which
would lower bills and emissions nor did
it promise to rectify this government's
nonsensical ban on new onshore wind
to conclude um
mr speaker i look forward to debating
some of these 38 bills in the queen's
speech i think it's a massive missed
opportunity i hope that we see an
emergency budget soon and that the
government wakes up to the real crisis
facing it
marco longing yeah yeah yeah yeah thank
you uh mr deputy speaker i was going to
confine my speeches to the public order
bill but i'd like to um to follow in a
few comments that the honourable member
for east antrim uh made because the more
i listen to him then why i think he
speaks a good deal of common sense and i
would like him to know that i for one
and a number of my colleagues uh agree
with a lot of if not everything and what
he says and we have a steely result to
make sure that we are one united kingdom
because that's what we voted for when we
voted for brexit
mr deputy speaker um my daughters for
someone fat without a mobile reason
can sometimes describe me as a grumpy
old man
i i really don't know why
i really don't know why
but there are a few things that can make
me a little bit miserable
but one of the things that has really
grated on me in recent years has been
about the minority of protesters who
have pretty much used guerrilla warfare
yes to disrupt the everyday lives of the
vast majority of our constituents
not just my own constituents but
everybody's
the good people of dudley north are
ordinary folk
working hard to make a living
a living that is increasingly harder to
make in the current climate so i cannot
fathom how the privileged and entitled
few
think it is acceptable to stop our
carers
and nurses from being able to get to
work to care for our sick and elderly
they think it is acceptable to block a
uh fire appliance from getting to a
serious fire burning a local business to
the ground or more tragically perhaps
stopping people from inside the burning
building from being saved of course this
applies to any
uh blue light service this isn't just
about the fire service
so this minority of criminals mr deputy
speaker do truly discuss me
they have no concept of the real world
out there they have no concept of the
misery they bring to those less
fortunate than themselves
furthermore mr deputy speaker i'm hoping
that yourself
and the front benches
will join me in making working here
more bearable for our own staff
and some of myself and my colleagues
i'm not going to dignify his existence
by tarnishing hansard with his name
but there is a noisy man outside who
dresses up as a clown
that harasses and chases member of
parliament
and our staff
from his little camp on the crossing
island on parliament street
is someone who is someone who else who
serves no public benefit
whatsoever on that point
i think the honourable member for dudley
north for giving
i know the character that he alludes to
and i've been witness to some
ferocious verbal attacks on my colleague
here uh from this uh character who just
patrol uh the uh
like a like a public nuisance but what i
would suggest what i would suggest is
could you please suggest to him and that
if he is interested in in changing
things in his country that he comes to
dublin north and stands against you at
the next general
election thank you mr deputy speaker in
fact that invitation has already been
made
i'm actually i'm actually going to print
off a set of nomination papers but i
just wondered about the 10 people he
might need
the people he might need to get the form
uh actually um valid
so mr deputy speaker
and i mean this when i say that my staff
cannot hear
distressed constituents on the phone
through the awful racket
he causes
all of our staff
who have offices in one parliament
street are caused considerable stress
and anxiety by the disruption he causes
their theirs and our work and i have no
doubt that staff in dcms and hmrc
buildings opposite would say anything
different
is someone wanting to
intervene i don't know i heard some
noises
it's like a hoover so it's like an
irritating thing in the background i
don't know what it is
they support him
so anyway uh mr deputy speaker he needs
his loudspeaker system confiscating and
needs to be moved on
personally i'd like to see him locked up
in the tower with a loudspeaker playing
land off open glory on repeat at maximum
volume
the met police really should deal with
him he's causing misery to hundreds of
staff he and him
our business representing our
constituents
would you like to would you like to
intervene sir
oh
the honourable member doesn't know
parliament works but we do often make
sounds across the chamber when we
disagree with him i disagree with him
i'm happy to swap offices and i'll take
his office he can have my office and
then there will be no problem and you
don't need to shut down free speech
either win win
i'm actually very comfortable the
honourable member to come to dudley
north and make these very arguments
because he will be out of office
completely
please do come and make those very
arguments and i'm not going to allow
someone outside who's a public nuisance
forcing this kind of behavior and for us
to have to make changes for him
mr deputy speaker
our police whether in dudley the met or
elsewhere need to have the tools
they need to better manage and tackle
the dangerous and highly disruptive
tactics used by a small minority of
selfish protesters to wreak havoc on
people going about their daily lives
our police have already enough to be
doing without the unnecessary burden of
a privileged few who sick seek to rinse
taxpayers money
mr deputy speaker i won't
come as any surprise that i
wholeheartedly support the public order
bill
if this disruptive minority want to glue
themselves to anything maybe the bill
should make it easy for them to have
their backsides glued to a tiny cell at
her majesty's pleasure
they would be most welcome thank you
catherine mckinnon thank you
mr deputy speaker and um it's it's
custom to say it's an honor to follow
the speech of the memphis dudley north
and
not not not being personal in any way
but it's incredibly frustrating
when we are facing a catastrophic rise
in the cost of living a war in europe an
economy that is just starting to recover
from the kobe 19 pandemic and
yet this is a queen speech that we are
dealing with today it should have been
full of ambition and vision for our
country but instead we have cynicism
half measures a total lack of vision we
have an eclectic mix of bills that's
more about stoking division setting up
dividing lines it doesn't come close to
tackling the issues that the public care
most about the catastrophic fall in
their incomes and the cost of living
soaring as a recession looms
the very beginning of the queen's speech
talked about supporting the police to
make our streets safer
and we know the government has no
shortage of hard-line rhetoric on crime
we heard it from the uh home secretary
earlier browse the headlines on any
given day and there's a good chance
you'll see something about how harshly
criminals will be punished if they get
caught but let's see if they get caught
bit that is really crucial and after 12
years of conservative cuts the police
and the justice system often do not have
the resources to investigate even the
most relatively straightforward crimes
the impact of this has been devastating
the anti-social behavior that blights
significant parts of our country and my
constituency has effectively been
decriminalized as cuts to frontline
policing and the criminal justice system
have caused a proportion of reported
crimes ending in prosecution to plummet
if the minister wishes to disagree with
the very obvious statistics on this then
he's welcome to we'd love to hear it
mr deputy speaker i'm i'm grateful to
the honorable lady for um uh for giving
way um just to to let her know that
obviously antisocial behavior is an
important issue across the whole of the
country and we definitely recognize that
and certainly in my own county of of
hampshire uh the police and crime
commissioner has established an
anti-social behavior task force using
the resources the extra resources which
the government has now provided for the
third consecutive year has she had the
same conversation with her own labour
peace and crime commissioner to
establish exactly the same kind of
assertive response in newcastle upon
time
i appreciate that the government states
his commitment to the issue
but we have seen an accumulation over
the last 12 years of the impact of
public service cuts right across the
board whether it be education youth
services um and to our police
that have sent the message to
constituents across my constituency and
elsewhere
that that people are getting away with
it
and there is very little that people can
do the relatively small increases in
police numbers
aren't going to change it either the
northumbria police have lost 1 100
officers and we still need
632 more to get back to 2000 2010
levels but replacing police officers
isn't going to take us all the way
either ministers have shown very little
interest in replacing
lost backroom staff as well who are
essential to releasing that police
resource onto the streets the minister
seems to think it's solved but residents
in my area would disagree and right
across the country
we need to put community safety
as a priority and it means more police
out there tuggling crime out there
tackling anti-social behavior out there
tackling dangerous driving his own back
benches have been calling for it
repeatedly today the things that the
police came into the force to do
and it means tackling the backlog in the
judicial system something that the
government has simply ignored and and
continues to ignore
and we know the distressing impact that
anti-social behavior can have on victims
destroying their mental health and
impacting every part of their lives and
in worse cases it can be life ending and
when i speak to people in my
constituency in lemington new begin hall
kingston park west denton gosford and
they're very clear that what they want
is greater support and protection from
anti-social behavior and crime and they
want greater strength
and legal protection as victims
yet victims are too often treated as an
afterthought the community trigger which
is supposedly the main instrument to
support anti-social behavior victims
it's largely unused
meanwhile support for victims remains a
postcode lottery due to the lack of
dedicated government funding
it's also disappointing that the
long-promised victims bill is still not
enacted after being promised in no less
than four queen speeches and three
manifestos putting the victim's code on
a statutory footing it is so overdue and
i urge the government to take up the
victim commissioner's recommendation to
include victims of anti-social behavior
in it we must give them the same rights
as victims of crime we must end the
postcode lottery in support for victims
with proper dedicated funding
but taking on crime is also vital to
rebalancing our economy or leveling up
as the government likes to call it not
only does it leave people fearful in our
own communities but it also damages the
prospects of attracting people and
businesses to areas that quite often
badly need the investment but the
leveling agenda it's leveling up agenda
itself seems up in the air with little
sense of the government's priorities the
modest changes expected in the leveling
up and regeneration bill simply aren't
enough especially if the government has
already passed up the chance to
transform northern economies
by delivering on the long promised
eastern leg of hs2 in the leveling up
white paper the government identifies 12
missions to drive and measure change
i don't have time to go into them all
but take the mission of 90 of children
to meet the expected standard in reading
writing and maths by the end of primary
school by 2030 i'd love to see it happen
we'd all love to see it happen but
is it possible to achieve this when the
highest performing areas currently don't
reach 90 percent it's really hard to see
how a government that's presiding over
half a million more children sinking
into absolute poverty can possibly
achieve that goal giving all that we
know about the impact of poverty on
achievement at school
promises are one thing delivery is
another and indeed there is no mention
of child poverty at all in the queen
speech or in the leveling up white paper
even though we know it accounts for much
of the difference entertainment at
school across the country and impacts on
so many areas of life from health wealth
and happiness
it's become a reality that must not be
named but in failing to do so the
government is failing our children
i want i want to just to touch on
transport because the transport bill
will include long-awaited and
much-needed measures to roll out
charging points for electric vehicles
making the shift to low-carbon vehicles
will save drivers money increase energy
independence and we'll clean our air and
on buses we know the nearly 40 000
vehicles on britain's roads need to be
replaced both as part of the switch to
zero emission vehicles and to encourage
people to switch from private to public
transport with a new modernized fleet
so the dfe's target is to fund four
thousand zero carbon buses in this
parliament
but there are forty thousand that need
replaced the dfts dft's approach of
funding zero emission buses through this
ad hoc centrally administered funding
pot forcing local authorities to spend
precious time and money writing bids
feels like an outdated and half-hearted
solution if i'm honest to the urgent
problem of decarbonizing our transport
system
i often imagine my communities with full
electrification of cars and buses
how quiet how clean the air would be
it's within our grasp we just need more
urgency and we need to streamline the
process of returning bus networks to
public control so green buses can become
an integrated and efficient
and accountable in like they are in
major cities in london and the same we
want for newcastle
fundamentally we need to remove fossil
fuels from transport we need to make
electric vehicles affordable for
everyone and ensure that every community
has the infrastructure to charge them we
need the right regulation and funding
for a clean efficient bus network and we
need investment in cycle and walk paths
to allow people to travel safely that's
how we create safe and healthy
communities
so mr oh madam deputy speaker
crippling energy bills and runaway
inflation are hitting families hard and
the catastrophic fall in disposable
income alongside the crisis in ukraine
will define our politics for the
foreseeable future
the very first line of the queen's
speech should have acknowledged that we
are living in a cost of living crisis
and and make a commitment to bringing
forward a budget to support
households yet it's not what we got
yesterday and we're left with grudging
half measures
previously announced by the chancellor
it's scant comfort to constituents
facing another increase in the energy
cap in the autumn when energy bills are
expected to reach a staggering two and a
half to three thousand pounds on average
it's just not good enough
two and a half years into his
premiership
it's not at all clear what the prime
minister's guiding mission in office is
other than staying there at all costs
it's remarkably thin policy program from
a government with an 80-seat majority
that tells us it's going to level up our
country it shows a government seriously
lacking in ambition far more interested
in stoking culture wars that it thinks
it will benefit from in the next
election than supporting the british
people and british businesses through
the multiple domestic and international
crises we face i will work with labor
colleagues to try and improve these
bills to try and improve the
government's program but quite frankly
after 12 years it's time for a labour
government
somewhat hendrick
well i'm deputy speaker it's um a
pleasure to follow my friend the member
for newcastle klontine north
who spoke passionately about the cost of
living crisis and the problems we face
that haven't really been addressed by
this government's uh bill
i would like first of all to
talk in the new session of parliament
about the platinum jubilee
it comes weeks before this year's
celebration this this address marking 70
years since her majesty queen elizabeth
became the monarch of the united kingdom
as well as other territories and
countries where she's head of state
particularly
poignant for myself who
was fortunate enough 20 years ago at the
golden jubilee
as a result of efforts of people in
preston the council other stakeholders
and myself found preston to
receive city status
um as a result of the golden jubilee
competition where 40 towns from across
england
competed for that status i don't know
which
town is going to be chosen this year but
good luck to
whichever town and whichever member of
parliament is representing that town
because i do know that we've seen
considerable investment in preston as a
result of the raising of the profile due
to city's status
despite this joyous occasion celebrating
the queen's platinum jubilee the people
of preston and this country cannot help
but be distracted by the real-time
tragedy of this cost of living crisis
when it comes on the heels of two two
plus years of hardship and sacrifice
caused by the global pandemic
in the queen's speech the government has
made clear it is not interested in
easing the pain of people suffering
right now and in many months to come
between last month's spring statement by
the chancellor and last year's queen
speech
no tangible access
no tangible action i should say to
address the cost of living crisis has
really been brought forward
the countries in a state of emergency
and on the brink of a potential
recession
people need help now and i echo the
calls that
the government will have heard from the
side of the house for an emergency
budget to try and address this situation
at a time when high inflation is
outstripping wage and benefit increases
happening conjunction happening in
conjunction with recent tax increases
this queen speech is a missed
opportunity to address the issues that
matter most to people
their livelihoods and future
today's debate is focused on crime and
justice
the party opposite fancies itself as
tough on crime yet has a pm and a
chancellor who've been issued fixed
penalty fixed notice penalties for
breaking laws that they wrote
crime is up while criminal enforcement
is down with thousands of criminals
getting off without being charged or
held accountable
the same is true for fraud and computer
misuse with online fraud soaring during
the pandemic and well before yet very
few fraudsters are being arrested
the figures that i have uh
and have been reported uh 460 400 416
000
cases of fraud have been reported in the
last year
35 million pounds have been stolen as a
result of that fraud
only 156 fraudsters have been arrested
and you would conclude from that that
crime indeed does pay
and i've had many cases of con yeah sure
i'm sure the honourable general would
one would want to acknowledge that uh
while he is right that fraud and
computer misuse
has been rising and has been included as
in in the overall crime numbers just in
the last few years that quite a lot of
those offences are committed by people
who are operating
internationally and online
and therefore particularly difficult to
bring to justice when they're in other
jurisdictions
and in fact the minister will know
there's been a big shift away from
things like car theft and telephone
theft and
many people are finding now their
identity is being stolen and
fraud being taking place as a result of
computer
crime and computer crime is a big
problem i think certainly we see the
problems in cyberspace
in terms of defence and i'm very pleased
that the cyber security centre is coming
to lancashire and will hope to be doing
a great deal in that area but i am still
quite amused at the resources being
committed to police forces up and down
the country to tackle this sort of thing
and the lack of
wherewithal from companies house to
actually try and tackle this thing in
terms of
fraud with businesses
as i say i have a number of cases in my
own constituency which i've written to
the government about when it comes to
online
cases of fraud
the online safety bill which was carried
over into this session
and what we've seen there is delay has
allowed disinformation to spread like
wildfire online and we've seen that
particularly during russia's illegal
invasion of ukraine which
obviously speaks to the point i've just
made about
cyber crime and cyber security
and what we want to see is more effort
regarding scams to be included in the
scope of this legislation which i know
our our side of the house the labour
party is committed to there is also a
data reform bill which will reform the
way data is handled in the uk after
brexit
and the government said that the changes
would help increase the competitiveness
of uk businesses and boost the economy
but just reinventing the wheel by
finding an alternative to gdpr just for
the government to claim freedom from eu
so-called red tape i think is is just a
waste of time and it's uh it's um a
posture really and isn't really going to
to solve any any problems by just
creating new standards of data security
and on the question of security itself
with the current state of inf affairs
internationally
i think the government needs to be
reminded how critical
national security is
we welcome the national security bill
and we want to see
limiting state threats activity in the
uk
as has been witnessed with the russian
invasion of ukraine and state-backed
interference here in the uk before that
there are changing threats to the uk and
foreign interference and legislation
must keep pace with the reality on the
ground so we do
want better security and we support a
national security bill but we want to
see that transformed
quickly and the cyber centre that i
spoke about obviously built constructed
and have the experts in there as soon as
possible
on the question of the public order bill
this really should be about tackling
injustice but it's not about
tackling injustice it's about
restricting further uh rights to to
protest in a legitimate way now there
are extreme cases we've seen it here in
this chamber when people were gluing
themselves to the glass
on the balcony on the gallery that
overlooks this this build i mean that
sort of thing
law exists at the moment to deal with
that sort of thing
but normal activity around
uh demonstrations is something that as a
free country we we've come to expect and
i think if the government is too
heavy-handed on this then the public
order bill will i think do a great deal
more
to to cause problems than it will in
allowing people to
protest freely the talk as well about an
energy security bill
talking about building on the success of
last year's cop 26 environment summit in
glamour in glasgow
with a pledge to build up to eight
nuclear power stations and increase wind
and solar energy production in the uk
again
i as a labour member and my
party will support an energy security
bill
particularly
i think the uh increase of the provision
of nuclear power to me is a no brainer
what we've seen too much of i think in
this country over the last 20 years and
i do stress the last 20 years i think i
would include the labor government um as
well is a lot of talk about nuclear but
not as much
being done as should be done and i
certainly welcome
the the considerations given on nuclear
power to small modular modular reactors
which i think will be provide very
efficient
nuclear power from engines that were
originally designed to power nuclear
submarines rather than provide power
to the public and i think there's great
developments and potential not only in
this country to see us move towards a
carbon-free future but i think also for
exports abroad
and in
the area of my constituency
we have springfield which is formerly
british nuclear fuels and is now part of
the westinghouse corporation which is a
world leader in producing uh nuclear
fuels and i think uh the
thousand plus people that work at
springfield can look forward to extra
work if this government and any future
labor government is committed to
delivering on the ground instead of just
the talk that we've had
over the last 20 years
yes
would you recognize that the government
has actually invested some
220 million pounds at rolls-royce
exactly on this very point for small
modular reactors so it's not just talk
as he asserts
yes and
a good friend of mine mike tynan has
been very involved in looking at um
particularly through the advanced
manufacturing center in sheffield uh he
still lives near preston he's formerly
westinghouse he's done a great deal of
work in that area and i'm glad that this
government after 12 years finally sees
the benefits of this for the future but
it's taken the instability
of the wholesale energy market
to to bring that about and
i would have liked to have seen this
much earlier in this government's
tenure as well as
within our own tenure at the time it
shouldn't take a wall for us to move in
this direction one of the things i am
concerned about though on the question
of energy security
is the whole question of rein
restarting the debate about fracking now
in lancashire we've had experimentation
an experimental
phase of fracking
which um i was originally quite agnostic
about and when the coalition was in
government and the lib dems and um
the current lib dem leader was energy
minister at the time i was quite
agnostic about fracking i'm not now
because i've seen
the having moved from an experimental
phase
towards the production production
what we've seen in lancashire is uh
tremors of seven and eight on the
richter scale
now we were assured at the time that any
any tremors above uh you know one or
sorry two or three on the richter scale
uh would would be dangerous and the
government would
would actually look at whether or not
they should continue with that now what
we've seen now is the uh
the secretary of state
looking start to look again at fracking
now his argument was well the wholesale
energy market has brought this on
well in fact it was nothing to do with
the wholesale energy market when when
the decision to put moratorium on
fracking was decided it was to do with
safety
about production
but this idea about
lifting that moratorium because of
energy prices was never a consideration
i think it's a desperate attempt to try
and um
to to bring that dangerous sort of
business to certain communities
particularly in the north of england uh
when it's not warranted on on safety
grounds or for that matter energy
grounds when nuclear can provide that
extra energy that we we do need so i
support the government in what it's
trying to do on nuclear but i think it's
making a mistake if it thinks that it
can
revisit the area of fracking
we obviously welcome steps for a
low-carbon economy and the commitment to
nuclear as i've already said and the
impact it will have on our energy
independence
now this
debate today is also about justice
and when discussing the delivery of
justice
we would be remiss not to mention food
injustice because that's what we're
seeing in this country at the moment
justice isn't just about what's
happening in the courts it's about
what's happening in society and fairness
in society
and as a labour and cooperative mp one
of the founding principles of the
cooperative movement is tackling hunger
and food insecurity which is so critical
in the face of a cost of living crisis
in one of the cr richest countries on
earth no one should go hungry hungry
and what we've seen is two million
people affected by the cost of living
and two million people
mainly uk adults
have been have had a day when they went
entirely without eating food but i'm
deputy speaker and in this day and age
that should not be
a situation that we accept
what we want to see
is a fair food act which enshrines a
commitment to zero hunger
by 2030 and that is a sustainable
development goal that should be put into
uk law and the cop what we want to see
is a comprehensive national food
strategy which were not included in the
queen's speech
now as i say if we were really concerned
about justice i think justice about
people being able to eat is a priority
which this government
has not really
considered and should have been in that
queen's speech
we also are aware that as many as 60
million people may be in poverty by 2020
through 2023
which is only you know less than a year
away
and 1.3 million are currently suffering
in this country in extreme
poverty and that comes from the
resolution
foundation now while it's not
specifically mentioned in the queen's
speech it's no secret the government is
preparing new draft legislation to
unilaterally scrap key parts of the
northern ireland protocol
including chucking away good checks on
goods between great britain and northern
ireland stripping away powers the
european court of justice and
eliminating all requirement for northern
irish businesses to follow eu
regulations
now this all comes from a government and
prime minister who negotiated and agreed
to this protocol
in september 2020 this government was
prepared to break international law in
quote very specific in a very specific
and limited way now when it comes to the
protocol before backing down yet here we
are again as global britain issuing
thinly veiled threats
to brussels under the guise of
protecting peace and stability in
northern ireland all the while
jeopardizing relationships with dublin
brussels and washington and any
credibility we would otherwise have with
international trade partners
the government at the moment is
trumpeting the australia and new zealand
trade deal which is looking to bring
through this house as mentioned in the
queen's speech when the degree to trade
that we've lost as a result of the
shenanigans over brexit and what's
happening with northern ireland at the
moment is phenomenal and no amount of
trade deals that we're likely to do
over the next five years will replace
that loss of trade which wasn't what
brexit should have been about according
to its own
government's own
declarations uh in the run to the
referendum
now the prime minister said the brexit
freedoms bill introduced yesterday would
allow the uk to get on with growing our
economy by making the most of our brexit
freedoms quote by liberating the economy
in the wake of the uk's departure from
the eu
yet by overturning the pro protocol the
uk is risking the possibility of trade
retaliation during a cost of living
crisis which is a perfect storm in terms
of the livelihoods of people in this
country and the businesses that
tend to support those livelihoods
we are just now beginning to see the
fallout for of brexit we would have seen
the fallout earlier but for covid
and now the effects of covert are being
masked by obviously increases in energy
prices as a result of the ukraine war
but the cost of living crisis is is
factored by several things which have
i've just mentioned madam
deputy speaker
the government is returning to the 2019
payback of using the eu as a bogeyman
following last week's dismal election
results
but people know the rules and are tired
of being taken for fools when it comes
to brexit and the so-called benefits but
i'm deputy speaker the country cannot
continue like this with a cost of living
crisis with the government sleepwalking
into a threadbare queen speech will do
little or nothing to increase the
livelihoods and the living standards of
the people in this country thank you
order we're not under huge time
constraints today which is unusual and
so i'm not going to put a time limit on
but we'll leave it up to
uh people to judge for themselves how
long they should speak but i should just
give an indication
that
10 minutes is usually the maximum for a
back bench speech for all sorts of
reasons which i don't need to explain to
anyone who feels the atmosphere of this
chamber
round
nice and lively alex cunningham thank
you very much deputy speaker it's a
pleasure and probably an unusual
pleasure for me to follow my honourable
friend the member for preston perhaps
that's because the government hasn't
been able to muster enough mps uh to
actually speak in support of their
legislative program and defend it
perhaps because it's impossible to
defend
the problems that our constituents face
are grave and numerous a snowballing
cost of living crisis stagnated growth
energy bills soaring by 54 percent
inflation at a 30-year high the tax
burden at a 50-year high record-length
nhs wasting lists criminal prosecutions
at an all-time low the logbook of tory
failures grows more comprehensive by the
day
our inboxes are full of correspondence
from people who are struggling to make
ends meet school children have to go
hungry in the holidays pensioners were
forced to choose between heating and
eating the same pensioners who suffered
yet another the government's broken
promises when they ditched the pledge to
maintain the triple lock on pensions
more than 2 million adults across the uk
have gone without food for a whole day
over the past month because they simply
cannot afford to eat it's a national
scandal that brings shame on the
government
professor sir michael mahmad a public
health expert at university college
london said it best if one household and
seven is food insecure society is
failing in a fundamental way these
figures on food insecurity are all the
more chilling because the problem is
soluble but but far from being solved it
is getting worse
in a queen speech with 38 bills there
was nothing that would help address the
worsening cost of living crisis in the
effects of obvious need for ambitious
reform and support the government has
offered nothing in response
no wonder our regional newspaper the
northern echo run the headline today
have they run out of ideas and the
answer is an overwhelming yes they have
and the people of hartlepool they
actually agree with that last week they
cast eight thousand three hundred and
sixteen votes for the labor party and
six thousand four hundred and
eighty-seven for the government's party
the government have even dropped plans
for the employment bill that was
promised in the last queen's speech that
means that at a time when everyone is
straining to make that pay packet go
further and they need their wages
protected the government have rolled
over at the feet of the likes of pno
ferries and others who fire and rehire
at will screwing down wages and treating
loyal workers like dirt and of course
there's nothing on slave labor in the
bills either the queen speaks like any
real substance needed to address the
challenges the uk faces sadly we know
that this deficiency of leadership in
government will hit low-income families
the hardest and it's in regions like
mine where income levels are the lowest
in the country and poverty rates are
amongst the highest that will bear the
brunt of the
crisis now the secretary of state for
leveling up that's here the funny voices
on television this morning himself even
admitted in the media over the weekend
that the government-created cost of
living crisis is going to further
entrench the existing inequalities we
see across our regions in some ways it
is no surprise we know from past
experience that inequalities widen when
the conservatives are in power and now
by their own admission that economic
mismanagement has made it more difficult
to achieve their flagship policy of
leveling up
as we've long suspected the government's
apparent commitment to supporting growth
in our regions is nothing more than
bluster and election hearing and it
completely lacks the ambition and will
to do so
the leveling up and regeneration bill in
this queen's speech is inexplicably thin
with so much inequality right to be
addressed it's ridiculous that getting
the funding needed is a lottery for
local authorities
in the place of bold reforms we have a
centralized pot of money controlled by
whitehall with overworked councils who
are trying to provide services to the
communities that this government left
behind have to bid against each other
for scraps and even when they have a
demonstrable need they may still fail as
billingham in my constituency did and
all the while leafy suburbs nearby were
somehow successful in their bids perhaps
the queen's speech should have had a
bill compelling the government to be
fair to all our communities
the secretary of state said that the
government would be implying leveling up
directors to help councils write their
bids
so the government is actually going to
use taxpayer money to employ people to
help places that the government has
disproportionately cut funding from bid
for parts of money that the government
controls
why does the government insist on making
areas that have been left behind by
their failed policies jump through
ridiculous hoops just to access basic
pots of funding
but it is the scandal of growing poverty
that's really on my mind
i agree completely with the director of
the northeast child poverty commission
amanda bailey who yesterday said we all
want a northeast of which every child
can thrive and fulfill their potential
including through education but they
cannot do that whilst already high
levels of hardship continue to grow
through their failure to take decisive
action the government is removing
opportunities from children and young
people in my constituency as the child
poverty action group have said this is
the legislative agenda that risked in
leaving increased levels of child
poverty currently turning almost 4
million and expected to rise further as
its only real legacy
the failure to deliver a leveling up is
also seen in our struggling town centres
while i would be interested to see the
detail of the government's non-domestic
rating bill for little information
available and concerned is not going to
provide the overhaul that is really
needed i would urge the government
instead to look at labor's ambitious
plans that would scrap and replace the
outdated system of business rates and
that descent disincentivize investment
and holds back growth these benches
would also immediately cut tax for small
business by raising the threshold for
small business rates relief supporting
cash flow and investment this year
it's time we made the amazons of this
world pay their fair share too huge
online companies have thrived throughout
the pandemic and it's important that tax
burden appropriately reflects that it's
not fair that high street businesses are
taxed more heavily than online giants
and it's high time the government level
this playing field and bring business
taxation into the 21st century
central to the current rise in the cost
of living is the increased cost in
energy prices affected by domestic
consumers all over the country but of
course it's also felt tremendously by
industries and in particular energy
intensive industries like those in my
constituency there is nothing in the
queen's speech to support them despite
many months of dire warnings to the
government that some of them will simply
no longer be able to competitively
produce their materials in the uk
the job marketing constituencies like
mine rely on the sector and once again
it is my constituents who will be the
hardest hit if the government do not get
a hold on this issue
production lines across the country are
dependent on the industry's continued
functioning as we're dramatically shown
in the co2 crisis of last year
if the government was serious about
keeping down prices for consumer groups
for our constituents who are struggling
with rising prices then it would have
provided comprehensive support for these
industries
another area in which the queen's speech
is completely lacking is health
the pandemic brutally exposed existing
cracks in our health care system but the
government have done nothing to fix them
instead allowing them to yawn even wider
to gaping holes in provision a record
six million people are waiting for nhs
treatment and they're waiting longer
than ever before often in serious pain
and discomfort which limits their
ability to carry out their lives as
normal i've said in every queen speech
and budget debate since i was elected 12
years ago and i will call for it again
my constituents need a new hospital
and let me make it clear i mean a proper
whole new hospital which will help my
community address the health
inequalities that blight is not a
refurbishment or single new wing added
to an existing hospital which is now the
government's currently holding up to
count amongst our hospital bills they
just try to fudge the numbers all the
time
what this print speech shows is that
tory ministers simply do not understand
the enormity of the cost of living
crisis that is being faced by people on
t side and across the country instead of
measures to deal with rocketing food and
energy costs the government is choosing
to forge ahead with a tragic half-baked
and recycled ideas from previous queen
speeches and that they failed to
previously implement and once again the
number of unnecessary ideological bills
that will do nothing to help the people
of this country
why is the government plowing ahead with
a media bill that will see channel 4 a
unique institution that is owned by the
british public but cost them nothing
sold to a foreign bidder
all it demonstrates that it is not
serious about supporting british-made
programming and our home-grown creative
industries across the uk there's another
broken promise over action on conversion
therapy after promising a comprehensive
ban why won't a ban cover trans people
or consenting adults it's now time to
end this cruel practice for all no
exceptions the transport bill is yet
more evidence of the government out of
touch with the country under the tories
rail passengers are paying more but
getting less in return fares have risen
twice as fast as wages but services have
been slashed and our constituents are
being priced out of real trial travel
and constituencies
don't even have proper infrastructure
to support improved rail services for my
constituents so how do they stand to
benefit from this bill similarly there
was nothing to improve our dire bus
services and at the same time the tory
mayor has poured tens of millions of
pounds into t side airport which
continues to lose money and that may
increase after logarithm ended their
flights to heathrow at southampton an
announcement made yesterday the mayor
has blamed heathrow charges but i met
with heathrow airport this morning and i
suspect this is more to do with logan as
arrangements with the mayor and
extremely low usage rates so i'm
determined to get to the bottom of it
another bill to suggest to the
government perhaps legislation to ensure
there is full transparency where public
money is being used i think it'd be a
very good idea we needed a queen speech
that would tackle that cost of living
crisis with an emergency budget
including a windfall tax to get money
off people's energy bills instead we've
got the last scrapings of the battle
from the government that's run out of
ideas and is unable to tackle the
challenges our country is facing they
should make way for one that will do so
leila moran you madam deputy speaker
the liberal democrats exist to build a
build and safeguard a free fair and open
society in which we seek to balance the
fundamental values of liberty equality
and community and in which no one is
enslaved by poverty
ignorance and conformity
poverty
given that we have had a set of council
elections where if there was one message
the country sent this government
was that they were struggling that they
needed help
at this time of a cost of living crisis
and then you compare that to what was in
her majesty's gracious speech
it speaks to a government who is not
listening to what the people of this
country are asking it to do
it's a government that is more
interested
in stoking culture wars and in replaying
past souls in this country rather than
looking forward to a future that we can
all agree on
you just have to look
at the way
that they are attacking our human rights
promoting human rights is right at the
heart of what liberal democrats believe
it's in the dna of our mission but in
this queen's speech what we have seen
is a replacement
of the human rights act with a so-called
bill of rights a bill of rights that
weakens and limits
undermining our current human rights
protections that is not i don't think
what people across this country have
asked for
and it certainly isn't their priority
right now
but let's put aside what is in the
speech which is underwhelming
and then let's look at what has been
missed completely
we've got
no
law to make misogyny a hate crime
no reform of the criminal justice system
that has failed women and girls in
particular for far too long
there's been nothing for the 4.1 million
victims of fraud
and i should say madame deputy speaker
i've had personal experience of this
recently my official twitter account was
hacked
i found myself looking at my online self
trying to flog playstation fives to one
my unwitting twitter followers luckily
none of them took it on and no one was
inconvenienced but
it took an age to get control of that
account back
when we then reported it to action fraud
i got a phone call eventually
from a lovely gentleman i must say who
told me that in his team of five five
people and that was the whole of that
support network three were off with
covered and the other one was on holiday
and i'm pretty sure i got the call
because i was an mp and we'd reported it
because we were worried about security
concerns i think that says a lot about
the emphasis that this government puts
on online crime
worth 27 billion a year
and the provision in the online harms
bill we don't believe is enough which is
why the liberal democrats are calling
for the creation of an online crime
agency to effectively tackle illegal
content and activity online but this
government i'm afraid is not listening
and it's not just the legislation that
is missing i would like to put on record
i really hope that there are some loose
ends going to be tied off in this
session from the last one and in
particular
i want to talk about the vagrancy act
we finally finally and there was much
celebration across all sides of the
house when we consign that to history or
at least in theory because actually in
reality it has not yet been scrapped
the government has put out a review that
closed last week that public
consultation and i just want to madame
deputy speaker put on the record i
sincerely hope that this christmas we
will not
have the vagrancy act in force and we
will no longer be a country that
criminalizes people simply for being
homeless and i look forward to truly
celebrating when that happens
now that campaign was brought to me
by oxford students who when they were
turfed out of clubs at the late hour
would have a conversation with homeless
people on the streets of oxford and that
was how they found out that this was one
of the things that the police used in
order to move them on
and there is another campaign that those
students different students those ones
have now graduated but new students
that i think is really really
troublesome and i wanted to raise in my
speech today and i sincerely hope will
find its way into one of the 38 bills
and that is a campaign
to stop the use of gagging clauses for
university students and in particular
young women because it's mainly young
women who are the victims of this
from being
encouraged to not speak out about their
experiences of sexual assault
in university
now the prevalence of sexual violence
among young women and girls is well
known and there are doubty campaigners
on this across all sides
of this house
the group make it happen it happens here
support survivors of sexual violence at
the university of oxford and there is
one survivor and i'm going to call her
lucy and she's given me uh permission to
tell her story today
um to show just how widespread
this issue is now she was assaulted in
her college dorm room by her ex-partner
who lives in the same college
and with support from oxford sexual
abuse and rape crisis center she
reported the assault to the police
during the easter holidays
on return to the university she was
terrified her assaulter would find out
that she'd reported him to the police
and therefore try and hurt her again and
so on advice to the crisis by the crisis
center she spoke to the principal of her
college about putting in place measures
to protect her
months went by months
and eventually the college set up what
is known as a no contact agreement
now this banned both students from
entering each other's accommodations and
set out separate times
to enter the dining hall which sounds
perfectly sensible
except that the agreement was
conditional and by the way the condition
was expulsion if they broke this it was
conditional on neither party making any
information about the assault the police
case or indeed the college
available
in any way publicly
that's shameful
what it did and this is lucy's own words
she says and i quote i signed it feeling
terrified that if i didn't agree to it
he would be able to enter my
accommodation without consequence
but i was incredibly upset about the
effective gag clause
i was terrified of telling absolutely
anyone
anything because what if college
interpreted that as publicly available i
felt i couldn't talk to anyone my
friends or my mental health support or
my gp
i felt very alone
and the thing is madame deputy speaker
this isn't an isolated case it happens
here which is a group supporting victims
like lucy has received testimonies from
survivors across several different
colleges under similar gagging orders i
am aware of young women who are my
constituents who are scared to talk to
me directly about it because they are
fearful that that would then invoke this
gagging clause and they would be
expelled and so they fear they have to
choose between their voice and their
future
the irony of this of course is that in
cases of sexual violence it is that
discrepancy of power
that is at the core it's not just about
sex it's also about power and so these
young women have gone from a situation
where they were robbed of their power
into another situation where that power
is taken away this time by the college
now i want to congratulate those
survivors
for having the courage to come forwards
to either it happens here or indeed to
lucy for coming to me and i would urge
others to do the same
to oxford student union and especially
fiona samuels who have been brilliant at
bringing these cases forwards and i'm
pleased to report madam deputy speaker
that lady margaret hall the the college
that lucy attended has now taken an
important first step and they've signed
a pledge committing to never use these
types of non-disclosure agreements in
cases of sexual misconduct harassment or
bullying and for this they should be
applauded
but you know what's shameful is that
they are the only oxford oxbridge
college who have signed this the only
one not single other there are other
universities that have done it but
actually this is rife across the country
in many other universities
i am grateful to the university's
minister who has called on all colleges
to sign this and also to the home
secretary who earlier today condemned
such use of gagging clauses and agreed
to meet with me so that i can relay more
stories of these victims
but for these survivors of sexual
violence delivering justice begins
surely with allowing them to tell their
story we should be helping those victims
reclaim their power these gagging
clauses in the cases of sexual
misconduct do nothing to help this in
fact they do the exact opposite they are
immoral they have no place in modern
society and i simply urge the minister
please can we find a way to address this
in this parliament
richard bergen
thank you madam deputy speaker
and we
meet at a time of a cost of living
emergency and that's why i'm so taken
aback by the fact we've seen too many
tory mps in this debate even though
there are far too few here too many tory
mps in this debate instead of calling
for action
and support that millions of people
across our country need have instead
resorted to
alf garnet's cosplay ranting about
so-called benefit cheats ranting about
asylum seekers and fixating on a single
protester outside parliament and how he
annoys them at the time of this debate
millions of people are having to choose
between heating and eating
pensioners are riding buses in order to
keep warm parents are going a whole day
without eating to keep the kids fed
it's a cost of living emergency and if
we recognize it as an emergency that
means that this queen's speech should be
used to implement emergency measures to
help people now in the queen's speech
the tories have offered nothing the
government is sitting on its hands and
refusing to act the government
is standing idly by whilst others suffer
why
because actually it hasn't been a bad
crisis
for everyone the tory party exists and i
understand that not all tory mps will
realize this exists to ensure wealth in
society is sucked from the many into the
hands of a few like robin hood in
reverse they rob from the poor and give
to the rich
british billionaires have increased
their wealth
during this crisis hugely increased
their wealth by 290 million pounds per
day in the first year the pandemic we've
seen billions of pounds handed out
in crony covered government contracts
we've seen multi-billion pounds worth of
tax cuts for bankers even as banks are
recording record profit so some are
doing very well at the moment
so given all that's wealth
given
with the fifth biggest economy on earth
it's clearer than ever before that
poverty is a political choice always and
at this time of the cost of living
emergency and the conservatives are
choosing to push people into poverty
through this cost living crisis so that
more and more of the wealth in our
society goes to the wealthy take energy
for example bills
are rocketing
the tories scoff but the reality
faced by millions of people in this
country is that they won't
take kindly to having explained to them
by a conservative mpl in this debate
that actually food banks exist because
people don't have the cooking skills to
feed themselves actually food banks
exist because people don't know how to
budget it's completely out of touch
despite the afghani theatrics and it's
completely contemptuous of the reality
faced by millions of people in our
society the end fuel poverty coalition a
warning that the energy crisis could
leave over eight million households
unable to heat the home eight million
households in one of the richest
countries on earth
and this time gas and oil giants and
making 900
pounds profits every single second
yesterday with the queen's speech should
have been the moment
to make our energy system work for
people and not for profits that should
have included
a windfall tax
to raise billions
to lower the bills of millions but not
just that we should have seen the
introduction of price caps as we've seen
in france in france they've only allowed
bills to rise by four percent
not 54 percent as has been the case here
and we should have seen action to bring
the energy system back into public
ownership ownership as i say to get an
energy system that works for people and
not for profit but the prime minister
and his government are willing to accept
millions of people being forced into
fuel poverty because that to them is
more acceptable than the alternative of
reducing the profits of the oil and gas
giants we often hear discussions about
wage restraints
sometimes we should be having
discussions about profit restraints as
well during a cost of living emergency
but the government is on the side of the
oil and gas giants not on the side of
the vast majority of people in our
society so we need an emergency plan to
tackle this social emergency to tackle
this cost of living emergency instead of
doing nothing the government should be
doing everything it can to immediately
get money into the pockets of the
millions of people hit hard by this cost
of living crisis and that's why i've put
down an amendment
to
this queen's speech
to call on the government to deliver a
wealth tax bill
that bill would introduce the best ways
of raising taxes on the very wealthiest
in our society we could use the tens of
billions of pounds this would raise to
create a huge emergency fund a huge
emergency fund to support people to the
cost of living emergency that's the job
of government
that's the job of governments people
need security in their standard of
living people need security in terms of
being able to pay their bills and having
a roof over their head people need to
ensure and the government needs to
ensure that people
get enough to eat
have enough to eat their homes and have
enough to be treated with the respect
that they deserve but how obscene that
we're having this discussion in one of
the richest countries on earth and how
obscene the government has deliberately
squandered this chance to take the
action needed to support people in this
country facing a cost of living
emergency that never in their lives
they've experienced before it's at times
like this that people look to the
government to do the right thing and to
support them through the toughest times
this government true to its political
ideology has chosen not to do that and
has chosen to stand by and leave people
to it
i think that's unforgivable and i think
that a wealth tax should just be the
very start of taking action to support
people the many in our society
cheong world
thank you madam deputy speaker and it is
a pleasure to follow the honourable
member for leeds east and his passionate
uh calls for
action and madam deputy speaker i have
become accustomed to feeling
disappointment
despair and at times discussed in
response to government pronouncements
but this queen's speech is a new low
the people of newcastle central deserve
better than this low growth high tax and
increasingly high inflation government
under labour we had growth on average of
two percent each year
under the tories it's averaging 1.5
percent and forecast to go negative
the cost of living crisis brought about
by this government
is
has my constituents flocking to food
banks
the choice between eating and heating is
real in newcastle central child poverty
rates in the northeast rose by more than
a third to 37
from 2015 to 2019 and
61
of children in elsic in my constituency
are growing up in poverty in 2022
and what is the government's response
the queen's speech is remarkable for
what is not in it
not what is
no emergency budget with a windfall tax
to get money off people's bills as
labour has called for
no employment bill that the government
itself promised we needed a real plan
for growth to get our economy firing on
all cylinders with a climate investment
pledge and a commitment to buy make and
sell more in britain instead they hike
national insurance cut universal credit
they have real terms pay cuts for public
sector workers freeze the rate of local
housing allowance freeze the cap on
child care costs use universal credit
claimants on title to each of these
decisions makes it even harder for my
constituents to deal with rising costs
the problem madam deputy speaker is that
this government does not believe that
government can make a positive
difference to people's lives
and that leaves my constituents with
stagnating wages that leaves the
northeast regional economy without the
investment it needs that leaves
hard-working geordies facing massive
technological and economic change
without the skills they need it leaves
the time bridge appealing and our buses
infrequent and overpriced
and it doesn't have to be this way but
on deputy speaker because government can
can be a force for good it can look
ahead in plan not this government
obviously
but i want to show how it can be
different by looking at one bill which
actually is
mentioned in the queen's speech and
which really highlights this and also
where the government is actually
creating growth
that is to say growth in online crime
online the conservatives are the party
of no law and total disorder and the
home secretary did not even bother to
defend her government's recognition
record on this when i challenged her
earlier
madam deputy speaker i'm an engineer and
a passive passionate advocate for
technology and innovation
and it has truly distressed me
to see technology go from being boring
but useful
to exciting but exploitative
our constituents fear tech is managing
them tracking monitoring and analyzing
their every move and then serving them
up to be trolled exploited scammed
groomed or just bombarded with
advertising and misinformation
online harms are not some future threat
they are an established current reality
about which successive conservative and
liberal democrat governments have done
absolutely nothing
because they believed indeed promoted
the silicon valley libertarian lie that
governments could do nothing about the
internet
therefore allowing monopolistic
platforms to acquire more money and
power than many governments
this power is used to deny workers
rights in silicon valley and delay and
minimize regulation here successive
conservative and liberal democrat
governments chose to leave it to the
market
blinded by their belief that the state
was too slow or too stupid to regulate
to keep people safe and secure online
and not doing that while actively
cutting
the parts of the state whose job it is
to protect people such as the police and
trading standards
and we see the same dogmatic approach
now
in their attitude to the cost of living
crisis refusing to take action like a
windfall tax and instead cutting
programs which could help like the green
home scheme act just six months after it
was announced and yet madam deputy
speaker it is possible for governments
to take action the last labor government
saw the fast evolving communications
landscape of the late 90s consultated
widely and put in place
forward-looking regulation in the form
of the communications act 2003 which set
out a regulatory landscape fit for the
next decade
come 2013 and the conservative liberal
democrat government chose to ignore the
many calls for me and many others to do
something similar and it's no surprise
madam deputy speaker that the liberal
democrat deputy prime minister is now
facebook's president of global affairs
justifying the online harms that deliver
billions of pounds of revenue to that
company
the online safety bill in this queen's
speech won't be in place before 2023
so conservatives have left my
constituents unprotected and insecure
online for over a decade
and this much delayed bill still fails
in so many ways
fails to strengthen child protection
across the entire internet it fails to
properly address the harmful impact
social media can have on young people's
mental health it fails to ensure a voice
to victims of abuse and harm online
the bill needs to tackle disinformation
online it needs to close the loophole
which means people are not properly
protected from online fraud by ensuring
that all platforms have to take a
proactive approach to preventing
scams and the data reform bill uh
also in the queen's speech seems to be
more about taking away protections than
actually giving new digital rights and
the digital markets bill has no proper
enforcer
this government is constructing a
piecemeal ad hoc and at times knee-jerk
online legislative framework when what
we need is a comprehensive
cross-departmental
evidence-based forward-looking review of
digital rights and responsibilities so
that we can have a regulatory framework
that is fit for the future
this is the security and the respect the
british public deserve in the digital
age and it's also madam deputy speaker
mind
numbingly depressing that the government
is repeating its mistakes of a decade
ago ignoring emerging harms algorithms
artificial intelligence the internet of
things bossware
data dominance there's nothing in the
bill which addresses the
decentralization
inherent in web 3.0 reflected in the use
of blockchain as part of the future
architecture of the web
and whilst distributed ledger technology
has
many strengths there is also a
libertarian dogmatic view that the
blockchain can replace regulation in
government this is a lie and the
government needs to show that it
understands that and i see that it
clearly does not
and so we also need more emphasis on
people's rights on access to algorithms
and their regulation the metaverse poses
significant risks to children with
virtual reality chat rooms allowing
children to mix freely with adults
labor has long campaigned for stronger
protections for children and the public
online to keep people safe protect their
prosperity from scams and online fraud
secure our democracy and ensure everyone
is treated with decency and respect
governments can act this one refuses to
do so
madam deputy speaker to be competitive
in the global age we need to empower
everyone to be confident digital
citizens
that's an economic imperative an
investment now which will bear fruit for
decades to come
the government has failed to rise to the
challenge of the digital age just as it
failed to rise to the cost of living
crisis just as it failed to rise to the
challenge of covert of climate change of
child property they look at our northern
cities and see problems to hide from not
opportunities for investment
whether it is short-term or long-term
planning this government is failing
britain deserves better i look forward
to a labour government which is on the
people's side
lloyd russell
thank you madam deputy speaker
what a seller
of divisive
straw man bills that have fluff
and no substance and where they do have
substance they're nasty
and they're miserable
or they're in
complete reverse from what was suggested
only in the last session
planning
one example of that
one moment it was to give a developers
charter
a rebellion on the tory back benches
meant that suddenly is reversed and now
we have a nimby's charter suddenly your
neighbors will be able to vote on
whether you can have that loft extension
don't upset the joneses otherwise you
won't be getting that extra room for
your child
what a kind of world are we living in
absolute tosh
and then of course we have a bill
that will make sure mps can sit in their
offices in silence so they don't have a
noisy protester outside really
is that the extent of the government's
ambition
and a borders bill that sums up just the
failure of the home office
unable to process refugees and
applications properly
where they're waiting years
to get proper and decent outcomes unable
to create safe and legal routes for
refugees of which there are none
at the moment for the vast majority of
people in the world there are none in
fact for anyone outside of afghanistan
and ukraine there are no safe and legal
routes the only legal route
to claim asylum is to make an illegal
crossing isn't that stupid you would
have thought the government would fix
that tautology no instead what they do
is they offshore the problem they let
rwanda fix it because they can't get
their own house in order and of course
we see that because it's not just people
who are applying for asylum that are
suffering from the hands of the
mismanagement of the office ordinary
people can't even get their passports
from the home office so is the
incompetency in that department
and in conversion therapy
we have a bill that is completely
useless yes it will protect under 18
year olds
but every over 18 year old that goes
which are the majority that attend
conversion therapies of course will sign
a waiver
because they will be told if they want
to stay in their church in their
community in their friends and family
they will have to go on to it and they
will still have to go through conversion
therapy now there is a good argument i
think about including trans people in
about conversion therapy that's not
about saying that trans people shouldn't
have
psychotherapy and be able to discuss
their options as they go forward and
that there is
presented to them to the different
options to go forward and things are
slowed down rather than rushed up but
conversion therapy is when you enter
therapy with the idea that the therapist
is trying to force you into one
direction that is wholly unethical in
whatever form it is for trans people for
gay people for any form of therapy
actually if the therapist is forcing you
into a direction
the government's failure to ban trans
conversion therapy the government's
failure to ban conversion therapy full
stock for over 18 year olds is a real
missed opportunity my partner twice
suffered going through conversion
therapies in his long process of coming
out comes from an evangelical christian
background and it is caused huge amounts
of pain and agony i don't want other
people to go through that pain and agony
and the loophole there the government
have given i'm afraid
is just not worth
than the rest of the bill the paper it
will be written on and i'm deeply deeply
saddened by that and i hope i hope the
government will come forward with some
you go
grateful to gentlemen i'm interested in
his view is he is he proposing
that there should be an absolute ban
on conversion therapy
at all even if an adult
consents i understand the problem that
he's raising about societal and other
group influence so i'm genuinely
interested in in how we think she would
overcome that issue of of freedom of
association or indeed freedom of action
for an adult
i don't think any therapies should ever
have a prescribed outcome when you are
talking about psychotherapy processes of
course you can have friends persuading
you one way or another but that is not a
therapeutic program that that's the
difference anyway
the this bill in my view is a lock em up
kind of queen speech as well lock up the
refugees if they manage to get over here
because there are no other legal routes
for people to come you know lock up
protesters lock up of course people who
may be drug addicts and need treatment
and support rather than a rather than
actually a criminalization approach and
of course allow corporations to get off
the hook with tax dodging like they have
continued to do allow of course
corporations and the huge covid
covid scams that existed under this
government to go unpunished
and nothing really on actually clamping
down on those corporations that led to
the grenfell tragedy either no
forcing them to pay for the cost of
converting all those places
up and down the country but what we
could have seen
we could have seen a cap on fuel bills
we could have seen real progress on
social care integrating it into the nhs
we could have seen a saving of the union
which actually involved
confederalization of independent
sovereign states and regions of this
country coming together instead of the
continued blind approach of just trying
to pretend that the union's not in peril
and just forcing it further apart which
is what the conservatives have done
what it does injustice i'm afraid
all it does
is pretend
that there is no problem here
it pretends that there is no backlog in
the courts
it pretends that all people want is some
british bill of rights when they have it
it pretends that there is not a crisis
in the family courts it pretends that
there is not a crisis in the magistrate
system where they have cut
local magistrate courts up and down the
country in the last 10 years where
victims and people seeking justice can't
access a local court where often they
have to get a bus
that takes
half a day to get to the local court and
a bus back no access whatsoever and no
suggestion of fixing it
and even
where they do suggest some positive
things
it is too little
the one area where i do welcome some
progress
is on housing
and the renter's rights
that they are suggesting will come
forward in this parliament
in fact i did welcome it in 2019 queen's
speech as well and i welcomed it in the
2021
queen speech and of course i welcome it
in this queen's speech i would say
however this is the third attempt to
announce strengthening attendance rights
and ministers are planning to produce a
white paper consulting on that producing
a green paper getting all through all
the stages in this place or whilst
assuming there won't be a new term in
parliament or a new general election in
which will mean that all of that good
work is completely
wasted
i would implore the government to get on
with this process because every minute
delayed is another minute of private
renters being turfed out of their homes
and i quite literally mean every few
minutes researched by shelter shows that
every seven minutes in england and a vic
section 21 eviction notice is served to
households since the government first
committed to ending no fault evictions
that equals 230 000 private renters who
have been invicted from their households
for no fault of their own
every one of these events has their own
stories but just last week i had won a
private tenant for 13 years in her
current home has five children 18 to
seven years old but their landlady has
informed them that they have to leave
with a section 21 notice the council
will not help them until they get a
county court judgment by the way which
is another scandal because once they
have the counter court judgment against
them they've got a black mark on their
name and they can't actually rent from
the private rented sector so in this
cafes world this parent is petrified
about even being able to put a house
over her children's head she has the
money to pay the rent but will any
landlord or the council help her she
says she is terrified she has never had
rent arrears she's got two children with
autism one of them has hypermobility
problems and both attend special
educational needs in the city she's
worried she will have to move out of the
city with the rest of her family
and there is no legal redress for
compensation that they've been kicked
out to no fault of their own after 13
years of calling it a home i'm the chair
of the all-party parliamentary group for
renters reform and i should mention
we're meeting next week for those others
who want to join um and our group have
had time and heard time and time again
that the lives of renters are really
being harmed
so it is positive these moves
and they have agreed
to put a private rented property portal
i hope the lessons have been learned
from the rogue landlords register and
which the government predicted that
there would be 10 000 entries but after
two years of operation there are just 21
names on that register it's completely
useless if they're going to make the
next register work all landlords must be
on it every single landlord in this
country
everyone in here who is a landlord
everyone out there who is a landlord
everyone no exception
needs to be on that register and there
needs to be a score card against them
and if there is not it will not work for
people finally and most pleasingly out
of the housing section there is a new
landlord
ombuds person a housing ombuds person
this is music to my ears
but what is the detail going to provide
take the deposit scheme where there is
already a system of redress the deposit
scheme doesn't allow for president to be
set from one judgment to the next in
terms of deposit disputes so if you win
an argument about that level of mold was
the landlord's fault and not the
tenant's fault in the house two doors
down with the same landlord who holds
the deposit back and refuses to give it
you have to go through all the arguments
again and with a different ombuds person
you can have a different outcome you
cannot have justice like this minister
so an ombuds person in housing must have
president
for all other cases that it then sees
unless of course the president is
overturned through legal argument and it
must have open justice where you can see
the results of previous outcomes it must
look at rent because we now if you
abolish section 21 all landlords will do
is whack up the rent and kick tenants
out and the government's saying that
they will make it easier for landlords
to kick people out for rent areas not
going through the courts actually is a
worry in itself
so the system needs to not penalize
tenants if they seek to use the system
which currently happens in the county
court system mechanical system can take
months and months and months and almost
a year in some cases to even get a
hearing there is a real problem in a
backlog of our courts the government
have called the bill on housing and
renters radical and a radical approach
is needed i hope we'll see it thank you
jonathan gullis thank you very much
ma'am dave speaker may i say thank you
to you and to mr deputy speaker for
being so understanding regarding my
needing to be absent from the chain for
a period of time and being allowed me to
come back in to speak it's very gracious
of you and
it's always an honor to follow funnel uh
the gentleman from brighton came down he
has a a flair full of theatrics
absolutely and he's a gentleman i
certainly enjoy uh conversing with and
i'm sure his audition there for the
panto in christmas in brighton is
certainly uh going to get him many uh
many uh phone ringing but
mandate speaker the
people of stoke on trent north kids
grieving talk were delighted with this
queen's speech and they're delighted
with it because
it is talking about the very places that
they're proud to call home about the
very issues that when i was out knocking
doors in the recent local elections were
being raised with me on those very
doorsteps and obviously the theme for
today and the thing i will start with
regarding safer streets is clearly one
of those
and they were delighted that it's this
government pushing forward with the
police crime sentencing courts bill
which is going to see child killers
receiving a whole life sentence
killer drivers being given longer
sentences an end to the automatic early
release of violence and sexual offenders
but also
adopting a desecration and war memorials
bill which i brought to this house after
the shameful acts of vandalism upon our
union flag
at the cenotaph many uh well over a year
ago now in london and actually was
something that when i looked into and
noticed was happening not just in under
across our country and sadly even in
tunstall where we had a memorial to our
glorious dead was graffitied and thanks
to two fantastic young girls who went
along to clean it really brought to the
attention the importance of making sure
warm royals and the government added war
graves rightly are having that special
protection because whilst the monetary
value
would require 10 plus war graves for
example to be damaged for any uh offence
to go to a magistrate's court now we
have that offence to understand that the
emotional damage done for a community
because these war royals and war graves
are in every village every town every
city of our united kingdom and our
glorious dead should always have the
respect that they rightfully deserve and
it was just a shape just a shame that
when i brought this to the house
i had members opposite ridicule this
very piece of legislation as somehow a a
protection on statues rather than what
it was quite clearly about
were war royals and war grades to our
glorious dead and i hope
that that jumping on the twitter
bandwagon which i know the opposition do
like to do quite frequently is a lesson
learned and actually that they will now
come out and say it was absolutely right
to make sure
that they have those full protections
i'm also delighted to know that we'll be
having the draft victims bills because
girls rights to victims are so important
i think it's so easy in the criminal
justice system for us to focus on those
who are who are the offender and
sometimes can quite easily forget those
who are the victims and it's vital that
we make sure the victims not just have
their day in court but have that extra
support and welfare after any sentence
is given so they can rightly feel
recompensed for their crime taken
against them and
the nationality and borders bill is
exactly what the people of
stoke-on-trent north kidsgrove and talk
voted for when they voted for 73 to
leave the european union back in 2016
because they wanted us to take back
control of our borders and they wanted
to send a very clear message
that whilst they have absolutely no
issue with people coming to this country
legally
whilst they have absolutely no issue
with people for example coming from
afghanistan syria ukraine who are
fleeing persecution and they're seeing
that they do have an issue with people
choosing to come across as illegal
economic migrants from safe mainland
european countries like france putting
tens of thousands of pounds into the
hands of people smuggling gangs
fueling an industry that's taking on the
misery turning the english channel into
a watery grave meaning that
70 let's not forget of whom are men
making this very journey
that they are therefore seeing this
jumping off the queue and they do not
feel that sits right with them that's
not because they're not compassionate
stoke-on-trent is the fifth largest
contributor to the asylum dispersal
scheme
so therefore
they are happy to do all they can to
support those who are most vulnerable
and most in need what they want is
fairness and if someone is coming from
ukraine someone's coming from syria hong
kong or afghanistan that is fairness
people choosing to make that journey
unnecessarily is simply not right it is
jumping the queue and the british public
were delighted when i was out in stoke
on train north korean talk to hear that
we were taking action they are just now
waiting to see that first flight take
off and to make sure that policy comes
into fruition and until
and then we go into the public order
bill another fantastic piece of
legislation i think my friendly right on
remember oh sorry the honourable member
for ashfield was absolutely correct in
saying that the crusty woke warriors who
were busy gluing themselves to pavements
or into roads who are busy standing on
top of trains meeting people can't take
off people who are preventing others
from going to earn their money it is
simply not correct that that action is
allowed to go without full the full
force of the law being felt against them
there are plenty of ways you can
demonstrate
your feelings about wanting to solve
the climate change crisis without having
to go to those extremities where you
take
damage people's lives particularly when
we are
suffering with rising inflation the cost
of living and you're asking people
potentially to lose out on a day's pay
that is simply not right those people
need to be held to account especially
when and the policing minister has said
this from the scratch box they are
taking extremely dangerous action on
motorways risking the lives of men women
and children as well as themselves
it is simply not appropriate and is
therefore correct that we do this and
then we have the government's fantastic
ambition of 20 000 extra police officers
which over 30 and a half thousand have
been so far recruited and over 201 now
in staffordshire alone but what's
important i know the police minister
gets this is that we don't just have
these numbers that they are seeing that
transferred onto the streets and we are
very lucky in stoke-on-trent and
staffordshire to have got rid of the
absolutely pathetic former chief
constable who had absolutely no ambition
no drive no understanding of what the
people wanted or expected we've now
brought in the new chief constable chris
noble a fantastic chief constable who's
already completely drawn a new plan for
neighborhood policing in our local area
that means newcastle underlying will
have a new policing hub base there with
dedicated officers for the kids grove
and talk area as well as a look at how
the stoke-on-trent north policing area
which i also cover is going to work as
well which will be extremely well
received bobby's on the beat bobby's
engaging with local businesses schools
and communities but also making sure
that those response times are undertaken
this is all the type of things that
people want to see and then finally the
safer streets fund which is something
that i'm a full supporter of in
stoke-on-trent we've had a whopping over
two million pounds from four successful
bids my only gripe madam deputy speaker
is that none of that money's been in
stoke on trent north it's all gone to my
friends in stoke on trent central and
stoke-on-trent south so i'm greedy i
want my own pot of money for places like
coverage baton stall for small thorn who
outrightly want alley gates they want
more cctv new backdoors and front doors
because the blight of anti-social
behavior the blight of fly tipping is
something that i know that members
across this house will experience in
their constituencies and we need to make
sure that all the measures that can be
taken are taken to prevent that as best
as possible and therefore i look forward
to lobbying the minister lobbying stoke
on trent city council and staffordshire
police fire and crime commissioner ben
adams to make sure that those bids go
into the right place but we also need to
look at the consequences for those who
want to take antisocial behavior it is
easy
to blame the government and it's easy
for the public sometimes to moan at the
police but actually personal
actions are someone's personal
responsibility and those personal
individuals should be held accountable
for their poor choices but if it's in
the case
of someone under the age of 18
who is constantly having the police
knocking on that door speaking to those
parents those parents or carers are
taking no action to back the police back
the school or back a social worker and
saying that you need to have stricter
controls on the young person you're in
charge of then perhaps we should look at
making sure that we don't just have hiv
chain gangs for those who commit asb but
perhaps the household themselves are
made to go out and tidy up the community
and clean up the streets because if
they're having to suffer the
consequences of that delinquent poor
actions that feral youth who's acting in
such a poor way then perhaps the whole
household will take much more seriously
the need to understand that they need to
back our police back our teachers back
our social workers back our care system
which is saying that you as a parent as
a carer have your responsibility to play
to bring up your child or young person
in
care in a responsible way it's about
holding people accountable boundaries
are important i know that because i
spent eight and a half years before
being here as a teacher and as a head of
year i was in charge of attendance and
behavior as well as i'm sure the party
obviously will be shocked a trade union
representative on the shop floor proud
to represent in the nes uwt for that
time but in terms of other things
mandate speaker in this bill and i will
be quick so i appreciate anyone to be
cheeky with time the mental health act
reform bill is something that's really
personal to me i shared my story in a
daily telegraph about my own struggles
with mental health and i'm really proud
to be part of a campaign called no time
to wait led by my friend and a former
government advisor james starkey which
is calling upon the government to make
sure that we have a mental health nurse
in every single gp surgery across this
country helping to triage because we now
know that 40
of gp cases are specifically for mental
health and therefore we need to have
action on this and i'm delighted to have
the support of members from the labour
party like the honourable lady from
canterbury who appreciates not in their
place as well as members of the liberal
democrats and the royal college of
nursing and the daily telegraph and
minds a very important charity and i was
delighted that the chancellor hosted us
at number 11 downing street yesterday
for a reception to obviously share the
campaign aims and raise the awareness of
it and i hope that this is something the
government will take up and i see one of
the uh ministers from the department of
health and social care on the fro on the
treasury bench so now i'm delighted that
he's had that chance to hear that i look
forward to meeting with him and the
secretary of state to have those
discussions further it is simply
something that we have to come to terms
with and deal with quickly in terms of
the online safety bill i'm delighted
this legislation is also coming forward
we need to tackle those vile online
sites that coerce and advise people on
how to take their own lives and in stoke
on trent there was a young man called
brett stevens who was the
sadly the victim of this type of crime
and his mother angela brought this to my
attention and we've been engaging with
the department of culture digital
culture media and sports and it's
absolutely vital that that legislation
holds creates that new offense of anyone
who is encouraging or assisting
self-harm is held accountable by the law
as the law commission itself has
recommended because it's not right that
websites like that are able to do such
things and then we have our places in
leveling up and regeneration bill well
this is
this government was elected on this is
what stoke-on-trent has been long
overdue and waiting for after having 70
years of labor neglect and forgetting
where it is because the assumption was
it would just automatically vote for
them at every single general election it
took them to lose stoke on trent to
finally find where it is although it has
taken a little bit of a journey stoke
newington's where they thought it was
first they have finally made their way
to stoke on trent on a couple of
occasions and every time they've come
the conservative gains have been ever so
increasing in local elections and by
elections so thank you very much for the
campaigning that the opposition is
helping us to do with
and what i want to see
is with the planning
uh reforms that being undertaken is that
the government goes further than just
compelling landlords on the high street
to fill their shops after a year is
actually enforcing planning
strengthening planning enforcement to
make sure that if that landlord's window
is broken or dirty or if there's boom up
as there is sally out some of my shop
fronts if the signs are half hanging off
the landlord is held responsible and
tidies it up it is not appropriate a
private landlord allows the high street
to become neglected and ruined it is not
and therefore the state should give the
power to the local councils to hold
those responsible to account but i also
want the government to adopt my
10-minute rule build i introduced over
two years ago and reintroduced into
every uh new session since and i'll be
doing it again this time which is to
section 215 of the town and country
planning act which is to increase the
current fine of a maximum thousand
pounds on a rogue or absent landlord as
we have at price in kensington to
unlimited to allow a judge to determine
the seriousness of that fine but also to
increase the daily fine after that from
100 to 500 pounds so these rogue
landlords can actually be held
accountable and responsible
for their actions
we also
then have education mandate speaking we
have the post 16 and skills bill which
has been absolutely brilliant because
it's about time that we have that focus
on technical education and
apprenticeships but we need to make sure
apprenticeships work that's why we need
to reform the apprenticeship levy
because i think members from across this
house will agree the apprenticeship levy
is not working in the interest of
business and it's not enticing those
businesses to take on apprentices so we
need to make sure that a lot of money
sitting in a pot somewhere not doing
anything is actually doing what it
should be doing helping
those young people or adults who are
looking to reskill retrain and i'm
delighted to have jess in my office an
apprentice from talk pits who's doing a
fantastic job and we assume to be
advertising our new apprentice with
stoke-on-trent college soon because i
want to make sure that i'm leading the
way if i'm going to be calling
businesses to do it i need to set the
example but also the four billion pounds
into those skills with a lifetime skills
guarantee is superb and the higher
education bill with a lifelong loan
entitlement is already reaping benefits
and giving those people who need to
reskill retrain all want to have that
change is becoming very exciting as well
and the school's bill which is um
getting rid banishing the lazy culture
of low expectations and poor aspiration
is important as well with especially the
increase in literacy and numeracy up to
90
in those young primary school students
but there is one two things made up
speaker we're going for full
academization
good we're going full economization by
2030. it's about time that we do this
but the system there are some rotten
multi-academy trusts in our system i
know that as when i was a trade union
in my time and what we want is a
bill to make sure that the board of
trustees
of a multi-academy trust face an offset
inspection to look at their governance
structures to look at their accounts and
to look at their um how they're applying
their policies across the board because
if we want to make i want these to work
and if they don't work the party
opposite gonna say these are just more
unaccountable
and less transparent local education
authorities and i don't want the party
opposite to be right so that's why i
want to make sure that we get this
policy right and i hope therefore the
government will adopt my tenant rule
bill i'll be relaying it in this session
i will be seeking the cross-party
support as i got on the previous
parliamentary session for it because
it's about time that the board of
trustees are held to the same standards
as the teachers who work within their
profession but man speak i also wrote
not long ago about grammar schools as
well and i know that there'll be people
on my benches who will say you're just
dragging up an old age tory argument and
the party's opposite will be going oh
here we go a bit of blue on blue maybe
well i think it's grammar schools are
fantastic and i believe they're
fantastic because i saw with my own
mother who was the beneficiary of one my
own brother who's the beneficiary one
and those who i've met within
stoke-on-trent who were able to attend
one said it transformed their lives for
the better and i think it's so important
that we remember that whilst grammar
schools
60 of them are situated in 11 out of 150
local education authority areas which is
simply not right and that a child in t
side there is or a child in north east
doesn't have access to a single one that
is not appropriate and that is why i
hope that this government will be
working with myself to see how we can
lift the ban on grammar schools and give
parents that choice so a kid in
stoke-on-trent has the same choice as a
parent in kent thank you mandy speaker
uh jill fellas
thank you mr deputy speaker after 12
years of the conservative conservative
government they now promise that this
will be the queen's speech to fix
regional inequalities
forgive me if i do not take the
government words at face value we have
heard all this before
and just like before this government is
all talk and no action
first it was a long term economic plan
remember that
the party opposite cynically use that
phrase time and time again to justify
slashing services for those who needed
the most
then it was the northern powerhouse
let's check in on how that's going
major infrastructure projects scrapped
living standards down and inequality up
and when i say inequality that's quite a
word that you can sort of you know knock
about with a bit isn't it but it means
people and families and children living
in abject poverty and having no way out
of it let us be clear about that and let
us remind everyone again whose fault
that is
this government has been in power for 12
years and some of the rhetoric i have
heard today you would imagine it was
only invented this government two years
ago when these
honorable members talk about resetting
things and getting on with things what
they're actually doing is admitting that
they've got it wrong for the last few
years because if they'd have got it
right we wouldn't be seeing them coming
in with such policies now so i don't
think that's actually anything to
celebrate or talk about
and i want to move on now and say madam
deputy speaker the latest buzzword now
is leveling up
but just like all those other times
before the government is hoping that a
catchy slogan will be enough to distract
us from their chronic inaction
it is yet another piece of empty
rhetoric which we have come to expect
from the party opposite but their record
speaks for itself
in my constituency of sheffield
brightside in hillsborough we have borne
the full brunt of more than a decade of
tory cuts
the spending power of sheffield city
council has been
slashed by almost a third since 2010.
communities like mine don't need
catchphrases they need investment
to a particular area very close to my
heart further education has a huge
role to play if we are truly are to
level up we are sadly seeing wearing
trends in skills and education
in a recent survey a third of british
businesses said their workforce is
lacking basic literacy and numeracy
skills
our further education institutions go
above and beyond to upscale their
students
having worked in colleges for most of my
life i know that education is one of the
most powerful tools in lifting people
out of poverty
i have seen this in action in my own
constituency
sheffield college and long glace sixth
form college do fantastic work to ensure
that their students leave with the
skills they need to succeed
but this commitment is not being matched
by the support they need from government
the prime minister speaks about the
importance of getting people into
high-paid jobs but refuses to take the
action needed to get them there
more investments in further education
and post 16 education and careers is
needed and it is needed now
the government's further education and
post 16 reforms risk leaving students
who need the most help at risk of being
left behind completely
t levels are an important addition to
our education system however they should
not come at the expense of existing
qualifications which have proven to be
successful b takes are
taken by almost a third of 16 to 18 year
old students they help to ensure that
young people enter adulthood with a
level 3 qualification which is vitally
important when entering the workforce
rolling them back will undermine this
work it cuts back on student choice and
degrades the variety of qualifications
employers can look for
it could mean that students who do not
qualify for t levels end up falling
through the cracks
and will miss out completely in any
leveling up exercise should it even
exist
i'm happy to give way i i thank god very
much for giving way i i agree that i
think things like apprenticeships and
technical education hasn't been promoted
enough but does the honorable member
agree with me but it wasn't helped by
um the previous labour prime minister
but one
obsession with a 50 university target
and many people actually went to
university we've been better served by
doing an apprenticeship
i thank the under on honor and honorable
member for his
intervention but i would say to you your
government has been in power for 12
years and if you didn't like it why
didn't you do something before
lady knows she mustn't address the
honorable gentleman director i apologize
mr madame dr speaker uh
this this flies directly in the face of
leveling up instead of cutting b text
the government should be championing
them alongside t levels this is just one
example of the government's actions
failing to meet their rhetoric already
ministers are making excuses on
levelling up the levine of secretary
himself has spent the last week trying
to cover up his own failures and that of
the government
is trying to lead us to believe that
deepening inequality is purely a result
of external events like covid and the
war in ukraine but we know the truth we
know that responsibility for the
entrenched inequalities in our society
falls at the door of this conservative
government and their policies
pensioners are having to ride buses all
day to keep warm and families are
struggling to afford the basic
essentials but instead of stepping in
this government is stepping aside they
are too busy trying to cover their own
shortfalls to provide the support people
are crying out for
we all know why they're doing this
because just like the long-term economic
plan and the northern powerhouse
leveling up will one day be retired as a
political slogan with nothing to show
for it just deeper inequality and
worsening living standards
madame deputy speaker this government
has once again showed that it is all
talk and no action this queen's speech
is yet another missed opportunity
which fails to fix the deep-rooted
inequalities caused by 12 years of this
conservative government
they are out of ideas and out of touch
and hopefully following the dire
election local election results on
friday will soon be out of office
britain deserves so much better than
this
colleen fletcher
thank you madam deputy speaker
um
the first duty of any government is to
keep its citizens safe we heard that
earlier it was her opening remark as
well when she stood up to
start this debate
but the government i believe has failed
in that duty over the last 12 years
on the conservatives watch we have seen
police officers disappearing from our
streets a criminal justice system in
chaos and people feeling much less safe
in their own communities
the government's record on crime and
justice is utterly woeful
total crime is up charge rates are down
and victims appear
to be being abandoned
the queen's speech was an opportunity
for the government to finally get tough
on crime and the causes of crime
rebuild our broken criminal justice
system and make our communities safer
yet again they have failed completely to
grasp that opportunity
once more the government is chasing the
wrong priorities while ignoring the
criminality that people face daily
while there are vague promises in the
queen's speech to make our streets safer
there is little detail on how this will
tackle the real concerns that people in
coventry northeast have such as local
neighbourhood crime and persistent
anti-social behaviour that has such a
serious impact on both individuals and
communities in my constituency
over recent years we have seen
significant issues with anti-social
behavior on our streets from problems of
noise nuisance and neighbour disputes to
vandalism and the illegal use of
off-road motorbikes
more and more residents are now
contacting me to tell me that these
incidents are leaving them feeling
intimidated threatened and fearful for
their safety
sadly the government's record shows they
simply do not seem to understand or
worst or care how persistent anti-social
behavior like this can destroy
communities and blight the quality of
life
for residents this probably explains why
the government has failed to put in
place a coordinated national plan on
anti-social behavior for a decade
this has left communities in coventry
northeast feeling abandoned by this
government
while my local force west midlands
police has been badly let down and
hamstrung by a lack of resources with
both officer numbers and budgets having
been cut to the bone by successive tory
governments for more than a decade
the police in my constituency do a
wonderful job
and i'm always grateful for the updates
they bring me and they're very regular
however what is really apparent is that
they cannot do more with less money and
fewer resources worst of all we now have
what seems like a postcode lottery on
policing resources for example how is it
warwickshire police can have a dedicated
off-road bike team when the west
midlands does not and cannot this lack
of resources means there is an absence
of visible community policing on our
streets with fewer officers to reassure
residents deter criminality investigate
crimes and support victims indeed all
too often
residents tell me they rarely see
bobbies on the beat anymore while the
officers i have spoken to
tell me there are simply insufficient
resources to investigate
to investigate every crime i give way to
the honourable gentleman very grateful
for giving away and she rightly talked
about the plight of things like such as
off-road bikes which is an issue in
stoke-on-trent north korea's government
talk we have obviously section 171
notices which i just don't think of
working as a deterrent does the
honorable lady agree with that and does
she think that perhaps across party we
can try and find a way to toughen the
law in this area
i think
i think off-road motorbikes um and i i
in my constituency are being used in a
very very intimidating way when they
where they're almost
um escorting cars around um and then uh
not doing any actual harm to them but
intimidating people so much so
that that that you know a person in my
constituent had to stop at the side of
the road to gather himself to be able to
drive on and that is something that's
been that's been said to me
time and time again
um
through email
through visits in the community i
visited the police i had a meeting
with uh
with a police and crime commissioner
only two weeks ago a summit meeting
uh with the leader of the council and
other people where i spoke
um
about off-road motorbikes i mean what i
think
it would be useful if we could do
something what the what the police are
telling me what the police and crime
commissioner is telling me is that there
are not enough resources and they they
have to put the resources where
um where they need to and there are pots
of money aren't there there are say
there's the safer streets fund you know
there but but is that really the way
to tackle these problems i think it must
be done far broader um than it is now
and i think out of all of the
anti-social behavior
um the most
i have is on off-road motorbikes and i
know that this is
something that goes on across the whole
of the west midlands it isn't
something that only happens in mine
which is why i think we should
look at what we've given
to police forces and saying this is this
is a problem up and down the country you
know
we need to tackle this um i'd be i'd
work with anybody to try to tackle that
to to be honest
so in in a tacit admission of the damage
they have inflicted on policing the
government introduced the police uplift
program and while any uplift in officer
numbers is welcome let's be clear this
will still not take west midlands police
force back to pre-austerity levels of
policing we lost
2221 officers in the west midlands
during the austerity years and while the
force is due to get back through
the the uplift program 1 000 um over 1
200 um that still needs a shortfall in
the west midlands of of more than a
thousand officers compared to two two
thousand levels i've i've nearly
finished now so i i have given way
already
when launching the uplift program in
2019
the prime minister said i have been
clear from day one i will give the
police the resistance they need
if his rhetoric
is too much reality and if he is to meet
his own pledge to level up the prime
minister must return the thousand police
officers to the west midlands
sadly there was no commitment in the
queen's speech to either resource the
police properly or to tackle the
anti-social behaviour problems on our
streets effectively i fear that once
more on crime and justice this
government has failed west midlands
police and failed the people of country
northeast
speaker
i
want to address this and really from the
position of justice
um justice is
uh uh a light and shade
uh issue it's not all black and white
and
i think what has been really
disappointing i mean i'm i'm not
surprised i have to say
by this lackluster queen speech and
government programme and i'd not been
surprised by the policies of
conservative governments since i was a
teenager so
i'm disappointed that we are yet again
facing the same challenges that
were
visited on scotland when i was younger
but the tone from the government benches
today is one of a punitive government
that's focused on punishment not justice
and i think that's personified really by
the
behavior of the home secretary when she
opened this debate earlier with her
dismissive and graceless attitude
towards her counterpart on the
opposition bench
and it's really um
i i think
from my perspective this needs to be
addressed uh from that position of
understanding light and shade of justice
and
many of the drivers of criminality
are social in nature
and they are
things like
poverty destitution
grinding hopelessness
and
it casts my mind back to my
teenage years when thatcherism stocked
the streets of scotland and destroyed
many of the communities in scotland
proud mining communities industrial
communities
as
the cuts and closures were visited on
them i used to be a labour voter i was a
labour voter when i lived in london um
but when i returned to scotland um i uh
was um absolutely gripped by the
progress that had been made with the
evolution
and the team record revision as it was
known of alex salmon's
early snp government and they made
really significant advances in
improving
the quality of life for the scottish
people
and that is what seduced me and
encouraged me uh to believe uh in
scottish independence but of course the
other factor that drove me uh to that
conclusion
was the re-election with the enablement
of the liberal democrats of a
conservative government in 2010
and that motivated me sufficiently to
move out of the health uh
health service into frontline politics
um
the the uk government's legislation
doesn't fit the aspirations of scots
their immigration
policies and drive down
inward um migration and in scotland we
need more not less people
in terms of policing the streets i mean
you know
largely uh
crime and justices devolved in scotland
but the
the causes those drivers of criminality
they are the responsibility of this
place and it is this place that has
legislated to drive people into
deprivation and destitution
and the job of the police is made all
the harder in scotland because we don't
have the normal powers of an independent
country so a couple of uh key
issues of drug deaths we have a serious
problem with drug related deaths in
scotland
people don't waken up one day and say
i'm gonna become a drug addict
that is the result of grinding poverty
of hopelessness of lack of opportunity
and that is controlled by this place
and if we are to improve
the quality of life for those people
then we must have the full economic
powers of an independent country but we
also must make progress on moving drug
related uh
um problems from the criminal justice
system and make them a public health
issue i will goodly
erase that i'm grateful to know but i do
recognize that the nationalist
imperative is that all that is good in
scotland is down to the nationalists and
all that is bad is down to the uk
government uh but in terms of the what
he says about drug deaths i mean it
would be interesting wouldn't it to try
and understand why the problem is so
much more severe uh in scotland than it
is say for example in england or in in
wales uh given that i don't think
necessarily the uk government over the
last 30 or 40 years has discriminated
particularly between the
the two and it's certainly the case that
for the last 10 or so years over a
decade all the tools required to get on
top of that drug death form which i
acknowledge is very severe in scotland
have been in the hands of a nationalist
government um and and
presumably he is putting as much
pressure on them as he is quite rightly
doing on us to come together to solve
this problem
you're handy thank you
speaker i thank the gentleman for
the minister for that intervention i
think the point that i would make is
that
drug deaths are not an isolated
issue that exists in a bubble
they are driven and they opportunities
to correct them require the full
economic levers of an independent
country so whilst the problem exists
the remedy the remedy to that is
retained by this place
you cannot isolate those those kinds of
issues and i don't i certainly don't say
that all is rosie in scotland that an
independent country would um would just
flourish uh
you know spontaneously independence is a
gateway to different
choices different policies different
politics
it's not a panacea that's not the
argument that i'm making i'll go on to
cover some of the other points that he's
made as i progress
but the the other aspect is a very good
illustration of why an independent
country or why scotland needs the full
economic believers of an independent
country is the other issue that affects
crime and justice in scotland is that
harnessing scotland's
vast energy resources
must be to benefit the benefit of the
scottish people
not her majesty's treasury as is the
current situation
and so you know it leads me to ask a
question how can it be that in an energy
rich country like scotland our people
are fuel poor and hungry and our
pensioners survive on the lowest pension
in the devo are they developed world
and there are
uncomfortable truths for the government
benches
it is absolutely clear by this queen's
speech and the actions and words of the
members and the benches of opposite
that this government will prioritize the
profits of energy companies over the
well-being of the people they are
supposed to serve
the chancellor's economic policies is
making inflation worse not better there
are alternative choices and i will set
some of them out for you now the
chancellor could reduce council tax by a
quarter at the cost of 10 billion pounds
a year
that would reduce the retail price index
by one percent
he could halt skyrocketing energy bills
by 50 percent and that would cost
another 10 billion pounds but that would
be another one off the rpi
every time the rpi goes up so does the
interest payments to global financiers
on indexed linked guilt debt
1 rpi increase puts five billion pounds
onto those interest payments but equally
one percent off the rpi saves five
billion pounds so the chancellor if he
had a conscience and a government with
the political will could reduce energy
costs and cut council council tax
immediately
her majesty's treasury could finance the
additional 10 billion pounds with a
windfall tax on energy companies and the
profits that i mentioned a moment ago
so
saving 10 billion pounds to advance the
financial markets and 10 billion from a
windfall tax could fix much of the
problems that we are facing immediately
all it takes is the political will and
the determination to improve the lives
of the people you are supposed to serve
or i apologize for the government are
supposed to serve
what it makes clear and what is not
being said i don't think by anybody
today
but it has been said many times outside
this place
poverty is a deliberate political choice
scotland is replete with energy far more
than we could ever possibly need and our
people see absolutely no benefit
there are particular issues that are in
place though contracts for difference
and the asymmetric and uncompetitive
transmission costs that impede
any inward investment into scotland and
we should be
at the vanguard of the renewable sector
manufacturing industry and unfortunately
there is
precious little uh manufacturing
happening in scotland but it's not just
westminster so go back to the point that
the minister made a a moment ago it's
not just westminster that's at fault
the scottish government shamefully sold
off scotland and
licenses for relative pennies they set a
ceiling on the beds a ceiling for as
much smaller um uh license in the states
they realized i think it was four point
three seven billion pounds
uh a dollar dollar sorry three four
point three seven billion dollars seven
hundred million pounds on that point
will you give
i thank the honourable gentleman for
giving way i'm sure he wouldn't want to
inadvertently mislead the house but the
700 million pounds to which it refers
is for options to develop and it
completely ignores any future revenue
streams or indeed any royalties that
might come i'm sure he'd wish to correct
the record
uh neil henry i'm i i i think the owner
of jennifer for his uh his intervention
i think he's made his point clearly i i
don't wish to go uh back over
what i've said i'm uh i think
using up enough time um but there are
real people in need in my constitution
according to the constituency my uh
local food bank the cricket food bank um
they're operating costs monthly have
gone from 3 000 pounds to 23 000 pounds
and the the notion that this is some
kind of squeeze is an absolute fantasy
this is a cost of living catastrophe
people are in absolute desperation there
was a caller into lbc a working poor
gentleman who phoned in he can't afford
to feed himself for days on end he
prioritizes feeding his children and he
has been thinking about stealing clothes
for his children he is so desperate it
was absolutely horrendous and it cast my
mind back to my university days and the
heinz dilemma which is when a man who
has a sick wife is
forced to consider stealing the cure for
her
her illness because
the pharmacist will not cut the the
price or allow him to pay uh over time
and that is where we are
people are in absolute desperation and
that is the misery that the uh the greed
of the markets drive i knew that when
david cameron was elected as prime
minister things would be bad but i have
to say i didn't anticipate it would be
quite the horror show that we are
witnessing and i don't regret or
apologize for my sense of urgency over
scottish independence the prime minister
talks about compassion
people need
governments to deeds to match their
rhetoric and i hope we pray that
scotland's first minister comes good on
our promise for an independence
referendum next year provocation
will not
do
people are desperate and they need
action you want to prevent crime then
you need to lift people out of
deprivation
and that is the only true way to deliver
justice thank you speaker
speaker
um
no debate of this nature would be
complete if i didn't make a reference to
um space launch in sutherland
so it's not all bad and the bench is
opposite
we are profoundly grateful for the
government's assistance in bringing this
to the point where it is today and it's
been a great pleasure to have mr roy
kirk of hindsight enterprise sitting up
in the gallery for much of this debate
he's had to go home now but me being me
i'll make sure he gets a copy of hansard
on the fact that i've name-checked him
this is my only opportunity madame
speaker to speak over the next few days
on the queen's speech and therefore i'm
going to make three
general points which are fairly
broad
um
in the last few days just about every
single candidate standing in local
government elections in the highlands
those kind of standing in easter ross
the southern my constituency almost all
of them used a picture
of the oil rigs
in the chromatin firth and it's a very
very fine site it's a majestic site all
of us know very well indeed
and if you travel further north of my
constituency look east
you will see the beatrice offshore wind
farm
this produces enough electricity to
power a staggering 450 000 homes
now we have onshore wind farms in my
continuity we've got loads of them
and of course there is a a discussion to
be had about the merits of offshore and
onshore as many uh conservative rural
members will be aware of but this leads
me to my first point and it is to echo
the honourable member for corcoradian
can beat
which is that my constituents live cheek
by jowl with the symbols of british
energy production and yet we are faced
with a crippling rise in the cost of
heating their homes and i hope this
image bandwidth speaker brings home to
this house
the irony of where i live we produce so
much energy but we have to pay through
the nose for it
and remember this point too far too many
of my constituents have no choice other
than to use fuel oil to heat their homes
this is the knob of the problem
and this is why i am
horrified that the vulnerability have to
make and it's already been said in this
chamber perhaps it's a hackneyed phrase
the invidious choice between heating and
eating
so if the government does really believe
in another hackneyed phrase in leveling
up and helping the most disadvantaged
and i hope they do then solving this
particular energy problem is utterly
crucial and i personally intend to
pursue it in the most doggy fashionable
fashion possible
mandarin speaker in terms of leveling up
the contribution made by bbc and channel
4 in terms of bolstering local
independent production companies all
over the uk cannot be overstated
with channel 4's plans to provide
100 000 opportunities for young people
starting the media industry to invest 2
billion in nations and regions
content over the next decade and to
become a truly digital public service
broadcaster
the government's plans to sell it off to
the private sector i'm afraid severely
misjudged but i take confidence i take
heart and the fact that i know many
members opposite agree with this opinion
and you think of what has been produced
the paralympics it's a sin
dairy girls made in northern ireland
what benefit has that been to the the
economy of ulster back black to front
shows and features that have a british
hallmark and would not have been made if
channel 4 did not have the freedom to
prioritize public interest and purpose
over profit
now in today's times and many of you
have read this tim bevin who co-chairs
working title films has said and i quote
british films have always been quite
difficult to get made and the plans to
privatize channel 4 and scrap the bbc
license fee would be a travesty he also
said this
the british film industry and
independent productions have been
supported by these two institutions that
is our culture
we don't want to be making american
projects we want to make british films
he's absolutely right and man speaker
the fact is that english is one of the
most widely spoken languages in the
world
and is also a fact that the work of
channel 4 and the bbc
give our country soft power
internationally softball which can
hardly be imagined i've seen it myself
power is where i want to conclude on my
speaker i shall keep this contribution
short to help you out with this debate
the public accounts committee has drawn
this house's attention to the fact
that the royal air force will have 30
fewer combat aircraft by 2025
because of the decision
to retire typhoon early
and when you think that over the last
seven years we've spent
701 million pounds no less 701 million
pounds developing new radar systems for
typhoon that will not be ready to 2030
then you can see that there's something
desperately wrong with the way we are
planning to defend our country in the
future
these are killer facts
honourable members on all sides of the
house have rightly said
in the past that the plans to reduce the
size of british army are ill-conceived
when you combine this
with this kind of typhoon nonsense that
i described then you can see that the
united kingdom is surely in danger of
sending out entirely the wrong signals
to our friends and allies
particularly in a time when the dangers
we face are all too clear now more than
ever madame deputy speaker we must not
drop our god
so madame deputy speaker i close with a
reminder from the past
in the
early 1980s the treasury
imposed cuts on defense spending
one of which led to the decision to
remove
the royal navy
uh
antarctic vessel hms and deutsche from
the south atlantic
it is claimed by historians that that
decision was part of the reasoning by
argentina the united kingdom was not
serious
about defending the falklands
and therefore it was worth argentina
taking the risk of invasion
mandatory speaker
the rest is history and only
an exceptionally foolish state
does not learn from the past
jones thank you madame speaker i would
like to take this opportunity to focus
on a few key areas today i think the
queen's speech is arguably more notable
for what's not in it as it is for what
is in it and the biggest issue facing
our country and certainly most if not
all of our constituents is indeed the
cost of living crisis that is causing
great hardship in mathematical in romney
and beyond
what we needed more than anything
yesterday was a queen speech that
included measures to tackle the cost of
living crisis with at the very least an
emergency budget including a windfall
tax to get money off people's bills now
yesterday the prime minister hinted that
help would be announced in the coming
days only for the treasury to announce
in the following hours this was not the
case
both shocking and unbelievable in normal
times but as we know we are a long way
from normal times
at a recent discussion with my local
citizens advice bureau has highlighted
the growing hardship in my constituency
overall client numbers have doubled
queries around energy have increased by
250 percent this is evident from the
current fuel poverty crisis and is now
mainly around support to pay fuel bills
debt numbers have increased by 200
council tax debt is now the highest
issue with a 200
increase from last year
this is incredibly worrying as these are
household debts
probably the most worrying is the
massive increase over 500 percent in
requests for food bank vouchers and
other charitable support
yet there was nothing in the gracious
speech to tackle this growing crisis the
government is either not listening or if
they are listening they're failing to
act
the lack of compassion and action
is shameful
what is also offensive is that the
energy giants are announcing
their highest ever profits shell last
week over seven billion pounds in the
first quarter of the year and yet the
government refused to consider it a
windfall tax and at the same time as
we've heard over and over today people
are struggling to choose between heating
and eating
truly shameful
i'm pleased to see legislation around
access to cash
after years of delay we eagerly await
the details given that the government
has allowed 6 000 local branch bank
branches to close on their watch since
2015.
even many geographically isolated
communities without access to cash and
in some areas including triharis in my
own constituency post offices too have
walked away and left communities without
access to cash
pleased to see that the ban on
conversion therapy is in the the speech
it's long overdue
but it should be a complete ban with no
fudging or vague approach which will
leave loopholes which will no doubt be
exploited
i thank the olympic giving away
on the issue of access to cash
does the honourable gentleman agree with
me that the government should take
proper firm action to make the banks
work together to produce some sort of
common access some sort of real face
behind the counter
i would absolutely agree with that point
because i think we've seen too many uh
examples particularly in rural and
isolated areas where communities are
left without any access
to cash at all so the opportunity for
for banks and other financial
institutions to work together uh is
nothing long overdue
but deputies we gotta turn to the tory
record on crime which as we know is
shocking we've heard again today crime
is up charges are down criminals are
getting off and victims have been let
down by the conservatives not taking
crime seriously we've seen an 18 rise in
total crime over the last past two years
quarterly recorded crime is now at its
highest point on record 1.6 million as
vulnerable friendly shadow home
secretary uh told us earlier the overall
charge rate has fallen from 15.5 percent
in 2015 uh to just 5.8 in 2021 meaning
thousands more criminals getting off and
over one million thefts cases being
closed without a suspect being
identified and there's no sign of things
improving
anti-social behavior continues to blight
our communities i've spoken in in
previous debates about the difference we
had uh the period of the last labour
government when all local awards was a
county councillor in that time and local
wards had a police officer
and one or sometimes two pcso's per ward
we don't have to hark back to the times
of dixon and doc of doc green when
people knew their community bobbies we
had this uh in the period of the last
labour government up to 2010. at that
time the neighborhood policing teams
provided meaningful engagement and
deterrence in communities before issues
got out of hand we now have the same
size teams covering five or six wards
and the sheer lack of people on the
ground makes it impossible for them to
tackle issues effectively despite their
best efforts
labor would strengthen legal protections
for victims of anti-social behavior to
give victims of persistent unresolved
anti-social behavior new rights and give
stronger powers for police and local
authorities to shut down premises being
used for drug dealing or consumption
whilst we've had we've seen more police
officers been recruited we still have
thousands less police officers than
before the tories started cutting them
in 2010.
i'm grateful that that in wales we have
the support of the welsh labour
government who although don't have the
responsibility for policing as that has
not devolved they have provided funding
for 500 pcsos which has increased to 600
uh in this senate term
and madame deputy speaker before i leave
the topic of police and i would like to
put on record again the issue of the
apprenticeship levy paid by welsh police
forces in england funding for the police
educational qualifications framework
which includes apprenticeships for
uniformed police officers is provided
through the national apprenticeship levy
in short english police forces are fully
reimbursed by the government for the
cost of training police for police
officers in wales the home office has
reimbursed only half that cost leaving
wash police forces with a shortfall over
two million pounds
i'm grateful to know what happened and i
do acknowledge the issue that he's
raising but but i'm sure he would want
to acknowledge that while english
or the uk government does uh collect the
apprenticeship levy as he rightly points
out the money is passed to the welsh
government who then have declined so far
to pass it on
to the police forces who are affected
and he is right that the home office has
stepped in to fund it this year and in
the past but i would urge him to speak
to his labor colleagues in in wales and
forget to get them to pass on the money
which has been given to them uh after
being taken from the police forces in
the form of the levy
okay
that that yeah i think
that the minister really should go away
and do his homework this issue was uh
taken up by his colleagues in in the in
the wales office team and
correspondence has been exchanged i
appreciate it is a a long and a
complicated issue but it is something
the home office are responsible for and
should take the responsibilities and
fund the four police offices in wales
in the same way as the police forces in
england uh are being funded because
welsh police forces are being
shortchanged and that responsibility
does lie with the government
uh madame deputy speaker return to the
cost of living crisis
i would urge the government to
listen to the concerns we've heard them
today over and over again there is uh
an urgent need for for government to
listen and take action on things like uh
vat energy cutting that uh the vat costs
all energy bills uh the windfall tax
these are practical steps which have
been
offered to the government the government
really do need to take them on board
take action and take action now for the
sake of families right across the united
kingdom thank you very much
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
it seems like only a matter of weeks
since we were in this place fighting
against the uk government's no
successful attempts to restrict some of
our most precious and long-held
fundamental rights it seems like only a
matter of weeks because it is only a
matter of weeks
in the last session we battled against
the police crime sentencing and courts
act that will strip people of the rights
to protest amongst other terrifying
measures the judicial review and courts
act that has serious implications for
access to justice
and accountability of public bodies and
finally the nationality and borders act
set to treat asylum seekers and refugees
in ways which i can only describe as
nightmarish
it is exhausting to be standing here
today facing an almost identical set of
challenges in this legislative programme
rather than see this queen's speech as a
unique opportunity to help people tackle
the cost of living crisis and put some
compassion back into the system the uk
government is just adding to its attacks
on people's
rights a constituent and friend of mine
is called joanna and she's a cleaner on
monday she said this so wages have gone
up and my company added a wee bit extra
so not too bad but today i got my wage
slip and my national insurance
contribution is now more than my income
tax contribution and it's taken me back
to exactly where i was
exactly what i was earning before what
in this queen's speech will tackle the
issues everyone out there is worrying
about energy bills spiraling out of
control the cost of the weekly shop
absolutely
skyrocketing and the ever-present and
impending climate crisis
well there's nothing in this that
tackles it it's being left to the likes
of
one of my constituents mandy morgan who
dreamt up the scottish pantry network
and in the last year has opened nine
shops and what that does is it charges
people two pound fifty membership
for fifteen pounds worth of food and
it's fresh fruit and vegetables and
fresh meat and fish and it's not just
for poor people it's for environmental
reasons as well it's tackling food waste
so that you don't have to worry when you
go into these beautiful shops
that that somebody's going to know that
you are on your uppers
and i want to pay tribute to mandy
morgan for everything that she's done
and everybody and all the volunteers and
staff who work there there are troubles
ahead for them however because they are
struggling to access the foods that we
need to food and they're struggling with
increasing numbers of people needing
their help but instead of tackling these
the government is just attacking
people's rights and you know the old
saying that divide about dividing and
conquering so who do they
want people out there to blame for all
of this as usual is they already least
powerful often completely voiceless this
government thought it was perfectly
acceptable to mention those poor
desperate refugees forced across the
channel in the most perilous of
conditions alongside what they say are
plans to help the police make the
streets safer in the same paragraph
of the queen's speech it's a consciously
cynical ploy to conflate the two in
people's minds it's a deliberate attack
on asylum seekers and refugees it's this
tory government's shameless propaganda
that says anyone fleeing persecution and
trying to get to safety on these islands
is a criminal and it's working because
whilst there are many people on these
islands doing everything they can to
welcome and support refugees and i thank
them and i pay tribute to them and i
thank god for them
there are also many who repeat these
tropes that the government has so
cynically created it is cynical it is
deliberate and it is strategic you only
have to listen back to some of the very
similarly worded interventions in the
last debate on the nationality and
borders bill from some of the
backbenchers opposite who had never
shown an interest previously to know
that
but today the attacks have moved to
those of us who support refugees
i was disgusted to hear the home
secretary refer to those of us on this
side of the house as defenders of
murderers and pedophiles now i
understand that it's apparently okay to
do that in this place as long as it's
not directed at an individual so i am
going to be writing to her and i'm going
to be asking her does she believe me to
be a defender of murderers and
paedophiles and i would encourage
everybody in here to do that because i
think we deserve an answer
now this was also a queen speech primed
to reinvigorate the brexit vote but
perpetuating the myth that brexit is
somehow reclaiming our sovereignty is
just ridiculous
doing it at the cost of trashing our
rights is plain scary i want to talk
briefly on um three of the many bills
that i feel i'm most concerned about in
this queen's speech and first is the
bill of rights
no secret that the justice secretary has
a long-held disdain for human rights or
to put it another way people having
rights
his book the assault on liberty what
went wrong with human rights is
illuminating if not wholly depressing
and i'll give you one quote from it the
spread of rights has become contagious
well we can't have that that's my quote
not has the spread of rights has become
contagious and since the human rights
act has opened the door to vast new
categories of claims which can be
judicially afford enforced against the
government through the courts and let's
not forget the footage from the same
year 13 years ago which saw him look
into the camera and say i don't support
the human rights act and i don't believe
in economic and social rights well i do
as does my party which is why human
rights are entrenched in scots law i
thank my lucky stars that we have them
more so now than ever because they make
sure that we can all to some extent
stand shoulder to shoulder in society
that we share some of the same rights of
access to justice that we can all call
out the government whether it be this
one the welsh government the scottish
government past labour labour
governments future labour governments or
any public body when they act in a way
which undermines our rights who on earth
would not want to who would
want to do away with that these are not
some legal concepts out of reach for
most they're entrenched in our modern
psyche and people know that they can
rely on them to protect them at their
most vulnerable moments or when they
need to face the might of the state and
that is what the tories don't like they
don't want people to know that they can
be held to account in the courts they
don't want to be scrutinized and i
predict when they're out of office they
will perform a complete u-turn on this
exactly i do love the positive spin
though the bill of rights will defend
our freedom of speech really well just
as long as you're not outside this place
with a megaphone or stood at the gates
of a fracking site your freedom of
speech will end right there if the
members opposite get their way and it's
nonsense to imply that the perfectly
functioning human rights act
has somehow stifled our freedom of
speech when it has in fact codified
protections for freedom of both speech
and assembly under article 10 and 11 of
the echr as with so many pieces of
legislation forced through this place
reform of the human rights act has got
little to support has little evidence to
support much of what the government
claims there is an agenda there are
facts and then there are government
ministers determined to bend manipulate
and skew the evidence to fit
why should the government be allowed to
dictate who can access justice that's
completely at odds with the rule of law
and our international obligations
to anyone who's seeking refuge on these
islands for example and when will the
government realize this is not what
people want people are lying under
immigration control lands to stop
deportations
people are physically running to gather
together to protect others from border
force officers we all know about the
kenya about kenya street in pollock
shields but last week on the day of the
council elections snp council candidates
marianne mawicki and now councillor
samita kumar stopped campaigning for
themselves
and staged their own kenya street
protest along with activists from
edinburgh snp and hundreds of their
fellow citizens from all parties
and none when border force fans came
looking for someone and you just have to
look at the number of emails absolutely
flooding into our inboxes on the rwanda
plan and you know this is not what our
constituents want
and of obvious concern to anyone in
scotland is the adverse effect this bill
will have on the devolution settlement
the the rights enshrined in the human
rights act are at the very core of this
devolution settlement and as scotland's
equalities minister christina mckelvie
msp said this morning changes
must not be made without the explicit
consent of the scottish parliament the
scottish government wants to enhance and
extend rights protection the uk
government wants the opposite what could
the solution to that possibly be
i will no doubt be debating all of this
for many months and we may be exhausted
with it but we're very much up for that
debate but what i don't understand is
why anyone would believe that this is
somehow going to cut our ties with the
european courts rather than our rights
being brought home we'll be forced to go
to strasbourg to enforce them our human
rights should not be embroiled in the
tory brexit
fantasy and on the public order bill
madame deputy speaker it's no surprise
to see the 11th hour amendments to the
policing act
vehemently voted down by the house of
lords
returning in the queen's speech
is this the way it's going to work now
democratically rejected clauses will be
repackaged and grouped together to form
next year's legislation and if they can
do that after just a few weeks of being
told no what on earth is their argument
against scotland's right to go to the
people to revisit the question on
scotland's independence after nine long
years they are leaving themselves with
no arguments for refusing a section 30
order that will not stop them refusing a
quote of course but they have no valid
arguments it's one rule for the story
government and another for everyone else
it's a brazen thing for the home
secretary to do these were not clauses
that went unnoticed by the public they
sparked outro rage and protests during
the passing of the policing bill and
rightly so the government is deluded if
it thinks that the people who were
willing to stand outside this place and
risk arrest and imprisonment are going
to lay down and accept this public order
bill they are also deluded if they think
that the same people on this side of the
house and the members in that other
place are going to roll over and accept
defeat
one of the arguments that was put uh in
the house of lords uh around the clauses
that she uh refers to was that it they
hadn't been adequately scrutinized by
the house of commons
and that was the main argument why they
were knocked out so by bringing them
back we're going to be allowing that
excuse me but i'm interested in her view
as she will know there's a protest
taking place in scotland at the moment
outside a field depot where protesters
have locked themselves on does she
support the arrest and removal of those
protesters and their prosecution and if
they are prosecuted and convicted what
penalty does she think they should get
they're constantly doing this they're
constantly trying to suggest
that because we don't like these uh
draconian laws that they want to bring
in that we somehow support everybody's
right to do whatever they want without
any penalty so i'm not going to get
dragged into it
because actually what i wanted to do was
tell him that we will continue to fight
this because what they're doing is wrong
and no matter how dispiriting it gets we
will continue to fight them and today on
the 41st anniversary of the death of the
late great bob marley i'd like to use
one of his quotes to tell you why he
said people who were trying to make the
world worse are not taking the day off
why should i well we shouldn't and we
absolutely will not
if the policing act was a step too far
this bill is a leap into the realms of a
dystopian nightmare
can i take a moment madame deputy
secretary speaker to say how pleased i
was to see my friend and colleague the
member for the honourable member for
eastern barton sure uh back uh making
her speech yesterday and i i mean it was
quite emotional for all of us not least
for her parents and her partner her
fiance who were sitting up there
watching it and i was particularly
pleased to hear her express her support
for a fully inclusive ban on conversion
therapy for all lgbt people
and i absolutely concur with her nobody
should be subjected to conversion
so-called therapeutic therapy absolutely
nobody
and madame deputy speaker i'll finish my
remarks by saying that i'm i'm
disappointed of course much of this was
predictable but much of it is manifesto
pledges
these are not manifesto pledges becoming
reality they're personal agendas and
attacks on the most vulnerable people on
these islands and as i asked earlier
where is the compassion where is the
helping hand or the reassuring support
from a government which is at least
partly responsible for the cost of
living crisis scotland wants to do
things differently and i do appreciate
there are many members on the side of
the house who also want to do things
differently so we do want to offer that
helping hand we do want to act with care
and compassion and we do want to welcome
people in need not throw up the shutters
and turn them away and the scottish
government does do all of those things
but they do with one hand tied behind
their backs i'm ready for this year's
challenges but i'm rearing for our
independence referendum because
madame deputy speaker when the people of
scotland recognise that the only way we
can stop tinkering around the edges of
dreadful tory policies the only way we
can stop having to spend millions
mitigating the effect of those policies
thus leaving the scottish government
with a lot less money to do the things
we as a country want to do when they
reach the conclusion that the only way
to have full control over the kind of
country we are is to vote yes to
independence then that is exactly what i
predict they will do
hello lauren thank you madam deputy
speaker
what we know is that the backdrop to
this year's queen speech is one of real
concern and worry people up and down the
country
terrified as they work out how to manage
their ever thinning finances
working people
having to sacrifice
themselves to feed their children having
to choose between eating
and heating after 12 years of tory rule
we're seeing the fabric of our society
of our communities being ripped out
services decimated with no plan in place
to put this right
inflation
and interest rates going up and a
recession now looming
what are we supposed to say to our
children
and our young people how are we supposed
to reassure them that after 12 years of
this after 12 years of tory government
that they can achieve whatever they want
in their future and what is their future
for some children they've only ever
known a country in which a community
centre
houses both a food bank and a polling
station or where services are so
decimated that there is nothing to do
and nowhere to go consequences of this
tory government
they deserve better
cardiff north michael's digi deserves
better britain deserves better
and now after the local elections we
know
that the british people want
better the election results have told us
that
and i'm proud in cardiff north we've
gone from three labour councillors to
eleven
and now there are absolutely no tory
councils anywhere in wales
the tory's shattering results across
britain saw them lose nearly 500 seats
and include strongholds like monmouth in
wales once worth
westminster right here and i
want to
give a special shout out to cardiff
north's own paul fisher who did win a
seat right here in westminster against
the odds
labor is a renewed confident party but
the conservatives are tired mired in
scandal with their own candidates i'm
afraid even refusing to put the party
logo
on their election materials
right now people up and down this
country
are working hard
paying more but getting less
they need solutions not tired empty
rhetoric and political sound bites
and i am
inundated with emails
stopped on the street in cardiff north
and asked again and again what i can do
to get the story government to help
hard-working families families seeing
bills escalate and having to make those
huge sacrifices
madame deputy speaker one of my
constituents linda an elderly pensioner
who is struggling to make ends meet
told me what the government is doing is
torturous
and will
slowly kill people
and sinister words to be hearing
in 2022
the government's announcements yesterday
do absolutely nothing to help curb the
crisis that is crippling her
and others in our communities
here the prime minister is more
concerned with saving his own skin than
tackling the real issues that families
are facing
prices and taxes rising wages stagnating
opportunity this government has failed
to step up
and support struggling families at
every opportunity
where is a windfall tax on oil and gas
producers to save households up to 600
pounds or the much needed emergency
budget
but perhaps
the cost of living crisis is simply a
joke to this government we saw the
housing secretary take to the airwaves
this morning mimicking and laughing at
calls for an emergency budget
this isn't a laughing matter people need
real help right now
and meanwhile oil and gas producers
announced seismic growth
billions in their profits propped up by
this government and they themselves have
welcomed our suggestion of a windfall
tax to help
those hard working families
but the tories
aren't on the side of working families
15 tory tax rises in just two years is
evidence of that
and madame deputy speaker one of the way
ministers run their departments
creating chaos and confusion many of
them too busy focusing on the chaos of
their own internal affairs
they are letting criminals off the hook
letting victims down
and i'm afraid the hostile environment
of the home office is just stark
i know many civil servants hard-working
civil servants are doing the best they
can
under these difficult circumstances but
there is only so much they can do
under this disconcerting leadership of
this home secretary
it is clear this home
office is not fit for purpose
while innocent women and children in
ukraine
are being targeted gunned down beaten
raped murdered indiscriminate attacks
have continued to destroy homes
hospitals and schools
russian rockets
strike railway stations and people
are rightly fleeing the horrors
of war and seeking sanctuary
i feel very fortunate that under a welsh
labour government in wales wales is a
nation of sanctuary for refugees
and a super sponsor of those fleeing
ukraine
it is
absolutely heartwarming to see how many
people have come forward how many in
cardiff north have signed up for the
homes for ukraine scheme
but the incompetency of this home office
is having a human cost
as they continue to lose
applications of the families my
constituents are sponsoring
my constituent sarah
who actually stopped me in the street a
few weeks ago and has written and we
have tried helping is sponsoring that
ukrainian family with a severely
disabled son they've been unable to flee
because their son needs
extra
assistance and they were kept waiting
and waiting terrified because the home
office lost their visa application
another of my constituents maria who
sponsored a mother and baby
were in utter distress as a home office
error meant that only the mother was
granted the visa meaning she would have
had to leave her baby behind
it's this is unimaginable what a mess to
put these families
who are facing such horrors in their own
country through
and this chaos is not only impacting
refugees trying to enter the country but
our own
citizens here because of the tories
leveling down our communities
crime blighting our neighborhoods
because of the 12 years of chronic
underfunding
to our police forces to our local
communities to our services
victims of crime are being let down
criminals let off the hook when crime is
up 18
under this home secretary prosecutions
are down
criminals getting off and the
conservative
clearly not taking crime seriously
and the bills
announced in this queen speech do
absolutely nothing to change that
and after six years of waiting for a
victims
bill of victims law we've seen
time and time again
six justice secretaries and still nobody
under the tories hundreds of thousands
of more criminals being let off the hook
loot victims being let down but losing
faith
in this criminal justice system
this tory government playing with
people's lives
and out of 300
women across
england and wales
who are sadly raped
are only around 170 are reported
but it's just three
that make it to the court of law
and that's before we even look at the
failure of prosecution which has gone
down from 8.5 in 2015
to just
1.3 percent
this just demonstrates that victims are
nothing more than an afterthought from
this tory government
lastly man of deputy speaker what
of the climate crisis the biggest
challenge we're facing
and based on the queen's speech
yesterday one which this government are
hell-bent in ignoring just a few hours
ago
the guardian
published an investigation
which has found that oil giants are
secretly planning 195
carbon bombs these are short-term oil
and coal
projects that will produce greenhouse
gases equivalent to a decade
of co2 emissions from china the world's
biggest polluter
they would each result in at least a
billion tons of co2 emissions over the
lifetime and have catastrophic global
impacts
and yet nothing announced yesterday by
this government will help avert climate
catastrophe we have a government who is
so caught up in their own mess they're
sending us
along a path to our own destruction we
need leadership on this
and the gap between the government's
empty promises and real climate action
is disturbing
failure to put sustainability and net
zero at the heart of the government's
new legislative agenda is a betrayal to
future generations
delivering net zero and nature recovery
is the only way to protect people and
planet and create valuable well-paid
highly skilled jobs and resilient
communities
the energy bill announced in the queen's
speech yesterday is
welcome but will it include those
important elements that we do need to
see
will it invest
in those crucial green jobs
prioritizing energy efficiency for
example that is critical to tackle the
cost of living crisis
by 2025
energy efficiency
clean heat and renewables alone
could replace four times the gas we
currently import from russia
the energy bill
is a chance to make right the absences
from the energy security strategy
prioritizing renewables and energy
efficiency measures that offer a win-win
for consumers business and the
environment
we need a mass retrofit program
slashing household bills cutting
emissions and investing in skills
and we know that new onshore renewables
are six times cheaper than the cost of
running gas plants
but we have yet to see a single piece of
evidence that further licensing in
either the north sea or through fracking
would increase uk energy security
or lower bills no more warm words
we
are a once in a lifetime
chance to get this right
it is imperative that this government
matches deeds with words
this queen's speech is little more than
a vanity project delivered with the
intention of winning back favor with the
public
instead of neglecting and decimating our
communities letting victims
down letting criminals off the hook
let's invest in a nation that we can be
proud of and only labor can do that
speaker and it is indeed a
pleasure just an opportunity to speak on
our emergencies programme for government
for this session
there are
uh that was here many things to be
welcomed and since i am by a large a
positive person i will start off with
those so i very much welcome the
commitment by government to the modern
slavery bill i know it's one that i
pursued and supported the honourable
gentleman and the far side and others in
this house
and it's good news that they that will
we will see the end of the use of
dubious supply chains uh and labor and
the uyghur muslims are of course one of
those groups of people that we're trying
to protect so when we talk about justice
as our topic for today madam daddy's
been this is a massive step forward in
doing just the right thing and i fully
support it i also welcome the minister's
commitment on two occasions to questions
that we've had from this side from our
party in relation to to
those who preach the gospel and
preachers in the streets and the
minister has given us that commitment on
two occasions again i welcome that i
also welcome the secretary of state's
commitment earlier on today uh when she
the honourable lady referred to to the
187 million pound for effective support
there is some clarification is not but
the second state was very keen
that which should be that the
contacts have been made with here on the
northern ireland assembly to see how we
can make things better um and i also and
and very much welcome the national
security bill because
this government our government has been
very clear on how they address the
issues of national security and when
it's taken on terrorists whether it be
isis dash ira or indeed uh the the
terrible atrocities by russia
in ukraine this government our
government stands firm and i and i thank
him for that
um i also welcome the support for
nuclear power stations again when i
asked that northern are being given
consideration as the only part of the
united kingdom
of great britain in orlando that doesn't
have their own power supply and i
welcome a change in planning although i
do have
at a distance uh look at that how that
will work if someone can object uh and
the problems that they would be there
but but there isn't a planning um
commitment to uh providing up for
affordable houses and i'm really hoping
that that some of that will trickle down
towards us in northern ireland where the
planners appear to have a refusal as a
standard unless there's an exceptional
case made to prove why they can't
legislatively prevent
however i my note of caution and that
must be that it cannot be implemented to
prevent agricultural growth
and our food sustainably both and see
the the honorable
right honourable minister sitting beside
and i know that her commitment the
illuminati's commitment is to for
agriculture growth and food
sustainability as well i also very much
welcome very much welcome the commitment
to addressing the issues and i spoke to
the secretary of state earlier on today
about uh the issue of those who block
the roads uh super grew their hands land
top of two trains uh and basically are
obstructive um now i
i'm a prude i've protested on many
occasions all legally uh but uh and i
was born in a decade whenever protesting
was there was a norm uh my honourable
friend for example referred to earlier
on uh so i understand the importance but
i also understand this
that you can't stop people getting to
work you can't stop uh nurses turning up
for their jobs you can't stop a man
earning his money and you can't stop
either and i do express some concern
where i read it in the press last week
where lily was uh
fined and jailed for uh taking her child
to school
i've spoken to the minister i do really
hope that that matter can be reviewed
and satisfactory as well um and the
other member for bracknell referred to
the review of cold cases um i think i
was a quite an interesting point i'm a
great believer not coming from northern
iron i'd like to see those who uh the
cold cases where nobody's been being
remainable uh can can
uh be advanced again
i i come voluntarily speaker to to
because debate is about delivering
justice
we need to deliver justice uh for the
northern ireland protocol
it should have been made a priority
there's no other way of putting it
government has repeated time again that
the good freddie agreement is at the
heart of negotiations and i support that
but have repeatedly failed to prioritize
northern ireland's constitutional pace
within the united kingdom accountability
in relation to protocol lies with
westminster and is crucial to the
political stability of northern ireland
at the prime minister in the city of
state listen to the concerns of the
people the cost
increase of an increasing number of
goods in northern ireland as a clear
result of their protocol that should be
prioritized by the brexit freedoms bill
in order to remove these restrictions
forced upon us by the eu so i remain
disappointed that we didn't see it but i
remain encouraged by the fact that the
prime minister has our meetings uh and
and also then at the secretary of state
for um the foreign office has also said
in the papers in the last two days that
they intend to take action now
i've heard it before my deadly speaker
but the action uh with the words of
action i believe in actions of action so
i look forward very much to seeing
what's going to happen in the next
period of time and release that and and
i know it's not an easy job to do but i
very much look forward to it
just give an example again mountain dew
speaker this is one of my constituency
surprise shops in every corner of the
province told me he was speaking to some
of his nationalist friends people with a
different political opinion
and they are friends of his and they
asked would the dup bi party uh be able
to get the protocol sorted my friend
said to him quite brightly says that go
speak to your own mp he says well my
auntie's and as his mp and he says uh he
wouldn't like it if i spoke to him so on
behalf of all those people from whatever
um um religious persuasion and whatever
political uh um opinions they may be
across the province i then once again
asked that if they've been crippled by
the protocol which they are then in this
chamber um i think the tales that those
people have told us in belfast last week
the elections uh are quite clearly said
that a message all unionists candidates
oppose a perform protocol
and on the numbers of those uh uh uh
vastly outnumber uh unions outnumber
those of a nationalist point of view
they are facing raising costs for power
transport for goods increasingly the
state of hassel they are sourcing from
other places whenever they want to buy
their goods from the united kingdom and
from the mainland so we need action to
rectify this the mistakes made and i
listened to
with great respect to the right of the
lady yesterday and and and some of her
comments
when she said that she negotiated the
daily thing that she had designed and
dated to respect the northern position i
wholeheartedly disagree with her as did
my uh
the member
for lagan valley and the member for east
london during as well we were
sacrificing the security we have paid
enough the brexit freedom bill must be
given us back our freedom and i believe
that freedom to buy british goods must
be part of where we are we want the same
opportunity as they have elsewhere
there's a little wonder that my right
honourable friend um
for lagging valley is waiting to see the
substance of scrapping the protocol and
not more suggestions of tweaking it's
not tweaking we want to a essay i think
the paper said it has to be absolutely
done away with and that was what they
the foreign secretary was saying and one
businessman said to me we are trying to
rebuild that their covert network yet if
we build on an unstable foundation uh it
could be biblical in this uh speaker but
it won't be the structure will tumble
the northern iron protocol is not a
stable foundation unless we have one
soon businesses will crumble and the
cost of living will skyrocket further so
again i ask government to do the right
thing
and i put it on record
if we're going to deliver justice
and that's what we're about everyone in
this house who delivering justice then
the justice has to be in an ordinary
protocol it's ditched
the stormline only works with consensus
we don't have a system of majority rule
which many of my friends on these
benches have pointed out over the past
few years we have power sharing if
unions are not on board then there can
be no power sharing let's get it right
and get our people into positions on a
stable foundation
this is a priority and it shouldn't be
um a a priority should not be cultural
expressions in an irish language for
instance it should be allowing people to
be hate their home feed their family
access medical care and those pushing
for limited finances they've been spent
in such ways uh need to go into the
states and pensioners bundles and look
these struggling people in the face so
every person actually spoke to every
right honourable member every honourable
member who has spoken mentioned about
the cost of living and rightly so but we
must address all of those issues and we
need to do it well one last point madam
that we speaker is in relation to to the
queen's speech and to the legacy issue i
i am the writer ability uh very kindly
let me intervene owner yesterday i want
to put it on record uh my concerns about
the the legacy if it doesn't address
totally fully and and
in a very impressive fashion
those who have lost loved ones in their
troubles i think of many uh people that
i know madame deputy speaker
i think of them often i think of the
valentine four i have three of those
boys i knew
extremely well uh murdered that i will
be at a church service on sunday to
remember them some 32 years after they
were murdered nobody made accountable i
want justice for those families i say it
because they're my constituents but i
say it because i mean it as well i want
that justice for stuart montgomery who
was murdered outside pomeroy many many
years ago yet he was only a 10 year old
just out of the police training college
uh never anybody made accountable for
him i want justice for those in the morn
who were murdered
in a violent way i want justice for
those in in the albert corn i want
justice for the the dark day gospel hall
all of those those those cases were when
no one was made accountable from the ira
for what they did
i want uh
justice for those who carried out the
king's mill massacres the umber atrocity
i think those are things that i need to
say i want justice for my cousin kenneth
smith who was murdered by that right no
one ever made it accountable for him so
when it comes to the legacy the legacy i
want from this government is a legacy
for my constituents for my families for
my relatives for the people of northern
ireland who have want justice for those
who murdered their loved ones and have
never seen anything happening for
our mother's cares are the same
regardless of their political persuasion
or religion and each deserve compassion
respect and above all truth
so i feel concerned that this bill will
not provide us an advantage to see the
detail of all the legislation and listen
to the views of the victims who do not
have law centers behind them or millions
of public money but who simply miss
their loved ones and don't want them to
be forgotten these people have paid a
daily cost and we can't leave anyone
behind why so it's clear that northern
ireland must move forward together i
welcome the economic crime bill and
welcome the mental health reform act i
watch that to see how that goes others
have spoken of it and i conclude with
this matter that is bigger
i welcome our majesties gracious address
but i'm asking
her government to do the right thing by
us in northern and do the right thing
constitutionally for us but also do the
right thing practically direct funding
to help the cost of living address a
willingness and educate our children put
political aims in the back burner and
practically work towards ensuring that
every home can afford hate light and
food rudimentary things and yet things
that are too many too many homes for
they must choose between and this icon i
believe cannot be accepted in any region
of this glorious united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland always
better together thank you
uh shadow secretary of state steve reed
thank you madam deputy speaker can i can
i start by thanking colleagues on this
side of the house who have made some
really thoughtful uh contributions to
this debate those are the honorable and
right honourable members for murtha
tithville and romney cardiff north
coventry northeast sheffield brightside
and hillsborough brighton camptown
newcastle of pontine central leads east
stockton north preston newcastle of
pontine north bristol east saint helens
north and of course my right honourable
friend the member for normans and
pontefact and castleford they have made
clear
in this debate madam deputy speaker that
the conservatives are a party that has
got high on tax and are now also soft on
crime
what a sorry situation for a party that
once proudly stood for the precise
opposite of the record they now hold
this conservative government took 21 000
police officers off our streets
they closed courts and created a backlog
of nearly sixty thousand cases
and they targeted cuts on the youth
services that prevent crime at source at
every stage in the criminal justice
system
this government has let criminals off
and they've let victims down and now we
have this thin
meager queen speech offering nothing to
put that right
the conservatives have promised and
we've heard this from members on this
side of the house this afternoon the
conservatives have promised a victims
bill in every queen speech since 2015
yet seven years on this bill has still
not appeared in parliament and yesterday
we were promised only a draft bill
meaning it will take even longer to ever
become law a victims bill should be at
the center of the legislative program
not an afterthought because this
government's let victims down for far
too long it is
scandalous nothing short of scandalous
that only 1.3
of reported rapes ever results in a
prosecution the other
98.7 percent never reach court and in
those rare cases
where a prosecution actually happens the
average delay in getting to court has
now exceeded a thousand days for the
first time ever
rape survivors deserve so much better
than this
letting an offender
walk free for nearly three years
especially when so many of them live in
the same neighborhood as the person they
attacked is a major contributing factor
as to why so many cases are dropped at a
time when rape involving a knife has
gone up by nearly 10 percent
this government has effectively
decriminalized rape
now the home secretary
mentioned pedophilia
in her opening speech
let me i'm sorry she's not in her place
now but let me respectfully remind her
it was her party that ignored the child
victim of the predatory former
conservative mp for wakefield and
allowed him to stand as their candidate
she might
reflect on that before she debases
herself with slurs against other parties
ever again
labor
has you didn't hear i'm afraid what the
home secretary said from the dispatch
box those comments are directed at what
she said uh and she debased her office
in the way that she said it
i meant of course madam speak the
speaker the honorable lady
labour has already proposed a victims
bill that puts victims and survivors
back at the heart of the criminal
justice system the government refused to
work with us and we can only conclude
after seven years of delay and delay and
dither low prosecution rates and eye
watering court delays they just don't
care about victims
a fundamental part of supporting victims
is to make sure you catch the criminals
that offended against them in the first
place but this government's police cuts
are so extreme that they have
effectively decriminalized many of the
crimes that worry people the most they
fail to prosecute 93
of reported robberies 95
of violent assaults 96
of thefts 99
of reported rapes and 99.9
of reported cases of fraud
shops and supermarket managers say the
police don't come anymore to arrest
shoplifters so there's been an explosion
of shoplifting to order the criminals
march in and they unload what they like
off the shelves i i'd suggest the
honourable gentleman goes and speaks to
some supermarket managers in a
constituency because the criminals march
in and unload what they like off the
shelves and there's no one to stop them
if there aren't enough police because
the conservatives took them off the
streets then they can't catch the
criminals it really is as simple and
common sensical as that
now fraud
is the fastest growing crime of all
scammers target people's life savings
and bank accounts with ever more
intricate online schemes we've recently
even seen low-life criminals set up fake
funds claiming to be helping ukrainians
when it's just fraudsters fraudsters
helping themselves to decent people's
money yet the business secretary of this
conservative government tells us fraud
isn't a real crime no wonder their own
fraud minister resigned in disgust at
the government's failure to take these
serious crimes seriously the government
is also letting down the victims of
violent crime custodial sentences for
knife offenders have fallen to the
lowest level for seven years and almost
half of all knife offenders dodged to
jail because the conservatives broke
their election pledge of two strikes and
you're out
i know from my time madam deputy speaker
as a council leader how to cut violent
youth crime my counsel
my council reduced it by even they might
scoff and laugh but my council reduced
it by a third in 18 months and the way
i'd suggest he listens to this the way
we did it was by investing in better
support for parents
more more community-led projects that
divert young offenders away from crime
and tougher enforcement against law
breakers it works
but this government has done the polar
opposite they presided over a 70 percent
cut in youth service funding that's left
some areas with no funding at all zero
funding they've closed 750 youth centers
they've sacked four and a half thousand
youth workers who did vital work
steering the most vulnerable young
people away from crime
now
drug and alcohol addiction lies behind
many criminals offending they steal to
feed their habit and their habit often
makes them more violent you'd expect any
serious government to tackle this but
the conservatives have done the opposite
the house of commons library found that
100 million pounds a year less was spent
on tackling drug and alcohol addiction
in the three years to 2020 thanks to
this government a decision that is right
now fueling crime
under the conservatives a prisoner is
more likely to leave prison addicted to
drugs than when they first arrived the
think tank reform tells us that one in
seven prisoners are now addicted to
drugs more than double the figure of
five years ago under the conservatives
our prisons have become colleges of
crime that breed offending instead of
places of punishment and rehabilitation
that prevent it
it is alarming how many serious
criminals walk out of jail at will in
february this year the dangerous sex
offender paul robson walked out of hmp
north sea camp in march
the murderer shane farrington watched
out of hmp thorne cross
the honorable gentlemen should take
responsibility for their record after 12
years in power the government this
government should never have allowed
such dangerous criminals to be placed in
a low category prison where they could
simply walk out and menace the public
with drugs and violence running out of
control in our prisons we are seeing
more prisoners leave prison to commit
even more serious crimes uh afterwards
over the last decade
685 ex-offenders have been convicted for
murders committed after they were
released more than a third of all of
those murders were committed between
2018 and 2020 showing that the rate of
the most serious reoffending is speeding
up under this government now terrorism
worries everyone in this country we've
heard some really we heard some really
heartfelt uh contributions today from
members talking for instance about the
horrific attack that targeted young
people at the manchester uh arena and we
remember those victims with great sorrow
in our hearts
of the last four major terrorist attacks
three were carried out by prisoners
released on licence and one by a serving
inmate so it beggars belief that the
justice secretary wants to blunder ahead
with his ill-conceived plan to rip up
protections against terrorism in his
bonfire of british people's rights this
country's security services have
explained
in the times that his plans will make it
harder to deport dangerous foreign
terrorists and in some cases terrorists
could get away with their crimes because
of the reforms included in this queen's
speech our security services give
evidence to the british courts in secret
for terrorism cases that's necessary so
their sources and operations are not
exposed to the terrorists they're
tracking down but under this
government's disastrous proposals these
cases would have to be heard in
strasbourg at the european court where
secret evidence is not allowed rather
than expose their agents the security
services would be forced to drop cases
and let terrorists walk free this
government's warped ideology threatens
to put the british people at greater
risk of terrorist attacks and it is our
job on this side to stop them doing that
madam deputy speaker this government has
gone soft on crime
they don't prosecute criminals because
they cut the police by 21 000 they don't
punish criminals because they don't
catch them in the first place our
prisons have become drug addicted
colleges of crime and the government cut
the diversionary programs that knock
low-level offenders off the crime
escalator so they then progress onto
more serious forms of offending labor's
approach would be so very different we
would put victims at the heart of the
criminal justice system with a
strengthened victims bill we would make
offenders pay back communities with new
community and victim
payback orders that stop young offenders
in their tracks and we would let victims
choose the work offenders have to carry
out we crack down on drugs in prison and
keep dangerous prisons in high security
prisons they can't walk out of and we
would set up new neighborhood crime
prevention teams in every community
bringing together police youth workers
mental health services and importantly
victims representatives to tackle the
causes of crime and anti-social behavior
while the conservatives sacked the
police we backed the police and we'd put
more of them back on the streets
catching criminals
under this prime minister
crime is up 18
and prosecutions are down 18
perhaps it's no surprise this government
has gone soft on crime when it's led by
people who break the law themselves
the leader of the opposition has
promised to resign if he is issued with
a fine for breaking the kobe lockdown
rules the prime minister broke those
laws repeatedly and shamelessly yet he
hopes to cling on to office
this sends criminals a very dangerous
message if the prime minister doesn't
obey the law why should they this
government is led by law breakers who
believe that laws are for the little
people no wonder they've gone soft on
crime no wonder they are letting
criminals off and letting victims down
he needs to kick my house
madame deputy speaker it's my pleasure
and great honor to close this day of
debate on the gracious speech with a
particular focus on preventing crime and
delivering justice
now the last two years madame deputy
speaker have been immensely challenging
but thanks to the effort of public
servants across our criminal justice
system the public have been protected
and justice has continued to be served
as minister for crime and policing i did
want to start by paying tribute to our
brave police officers for their tireless
commitment to keeping the public safe
which has remained steadfast throughout
the immense challenges of the pandemic
as we continue our covert 19 recovery
and as a joint minister between the home
office and ministry of justice i know
that hard work and dedication has been
no less evident at the other end of the
system from our court staff legal
professionals and the judiciary their
efforts have kept the wheels of justice
turning so we can drive down the court
backlog rebuild a better stronger system
and bring swifter justice for all
now madam deputy speaker i have listened
to today's long debate with interest and
i'm grateful to members of all sides for
their contributions
it is clear that there was a common
theme across pretty much all the
speeches this afternoon which is a
strong concern shared by the government
about the cost of living challenge being
felt up and down the nation
bringing difficult choices in houses and
homes across the country
the government has moved quickly to
inject 22 billion pounds through various
means into people's pockets particularly
focused on those households who have
less money to spend on a daily basis and
i know that the chancellor and the prime
minister are monitoring the situation on
a daily basis it is the case that over
the next few months the cost of living
is going to
challenge
uh even more uh given the forecast of
the bank of england and it's
the duty of all of us in government to
do what we can to alleviate that burden
on our fellow citizens
this however madam every speaker is of
course a queen speech which lays out a
legislative agenda for the next session
rather than a budget which would lay out
a fiscal or taxation agenda and i'm
confident that when it comes to that
point the chancellor as he has done in
the past will do what he needs to do to
support households in this country
now madam deputy speaker we had a
variety
of contributions this afternoon that
fell broadly into three uh categories
first of all the constructive
beginning with my uh friend the member
for bracknell
who talked about antisocial behavior in
his constituency a theme that we heard
from a number of members
we had the three graces from ashfield
peterborough and dudley north
who expressed strong support for the
public order
bill that will be coming forward very
shortly and in particular for the
general theme expressed pithily by my
friend for peterborough who said that
criminals should be scared of the law
not citizens scared of the criminals
that's a sentiment with which we uh
heartily agree
uh my honourable friend for stroke
stoke-on-trent north gave his usual
vigorous
and wide-ranging contribution to the
debate uh which illustrated quite neatly
uh why his part of the world is becoming
a conservative stronghold
um
by every uh with every month that passes
um
our friends from the uh
other side of the irish sea um in
northern ireland uh also gave
constructive and i think thoughtful uh
contributions uh support again
for the measures we're taking on dealing
with
guerrilla style protests but i heard
very clearly their concerns about the
northern ireland protocol and i know
that the prime minister northern ireland
secretary and the uh foreign
commonwealth secretary are all engaged
very intensively on trying to solve the
problems that that protocol is bringing
to that part of the uh the country
uh happily uh from the opposition
benches the member first and helens
north took us through the very welcome
renaissance uh in helen's fortunes a
town i know well from my upbringing in
the north west uh although he seemed to
miss the bit in his speech where he was
grateful for the government contribution
to that particular renaissance not least
the 360 000 pounds
that the council received to help with
rough sleeping
in the town with which they've been
remarkably uh successful
and then
my
the honourable gentleman for caithness
sutherland and easter ross who similarly
was very gracious about the government
work in his constituency which is
bringing i hope great prosperity and
success to his part of the world um and
i'm grateful for his contribution
then i'm afraid madam deputy speaker we
had a variety of contributions which
were all variations on a theme
of everything conservative bad
everything fill in the blank my party
excellent good brilliant uh silver
bullet style
solutions
uh the member for bristol east who seem
to be happy that protesters
should be punished through the civil
courts but not through the criminal
courts
which is a rather confused stance my the
honourable lady for newcastle uh north
uh who really needs to reflect on the
the various problems that she
uh raised with crime in her
constituency in her city which really
should be the priority of the labour
police and crime commission and i hope
she will have an assertive conversation
with her as she was assertive in her
contribution
the member for oxford western abington
um who put the blame for members of the
of action ford having catching covert uh
down to the government uh strangely um
uh hopefully they will recover soon
always good to hear from the member for
leeds east um excellent to know that the
carbonite heart of the labour party is
beating strongly
uh fear not my friend your time will
come again we all hope
um
a vigorous contribution uh from uh the
honourable jennifer brighton uh kemptown
uh which inside that kind of um accepted
attacks on us i thought there was some
thought thing some food for thought
there um on some of the perhaps more
sensitive issues that we're going to
have to face uh during this
session
a couple of members from the west
midlands not least the member for
conference tree north east putting the
fall in police numbers in west midlands
please down to the government whereas in
fact there is very little we can do if
you have a labor police and crime
commissioner who does not prioritize the
maintenance of police numbers over the
last 10 years there are lots of police
forces across the country
there are lots of police forces
across the country who already have
the highest number of police officers
they've ever had in their history not
least the not least the metropolitan
police and that's because those who've
had uh custodianship of the finances of
that force over the last decade or so
made the right choices i cannot
compensate for the poor choices of
police and crime commissioners made
during the last years much last 10 years
much though i would uh like to
and i hope that when we reach the end of
the successful recruitment of 20 000
police officers which i forecast we will
do towards the end of this
year uh that people will reflect on the
decisions they made over the decade and
where it has put them at the end of the
uh
process and then finally uh the member
for cardiff north who seems to have
failed to realize that our commitment to
net zero i'm proud to say is a matter of
law
um and cannot be avoided by this
government or indeed any subsequent
government
and that brings me uh madame deputy
speaker that brings me madam deputy
speaker to the chief
uh dystopians uh the front bench uh pair
um the the the closing and the member
for uh for coyden uh central who went in
for some kind of weirdo rant at the end
uh filled i'm afraid
uh with misrepresentations and am i
allowed to say half truths
um i don't know if that's um uh
parliamentary language or not um so
the the strange thing is man of deputy
speak that so eager are they to attack
so uh uh
eager are they to to push
um for uh all-out frontal assault that
they forget the collateral damage
uh that in their speech they attack the
police
all those brave police officers callous
um
and uncaring
that home office the thousands of home
office staff are unfeeling
um and similarly inefficient and callous
about those who seek their
services
and that even most of them represented
by labor police and crime commissioners
attacking their colleagues for their own
uh lack of thought uh and care
um
their
general speeches don't really i think
require uh a detailed response uh not
least because it's the same attacks that
we heard in the run-up to the 2019
election as i say all variations on a
theme and i suspect uh we'll get the
same result at the next election unless
they change their tune and finally madam
deputy speaker we did have three i
thought very thoughtful
um uh contributions which uh struck me
in particular first the member for poole
um who uh
not just on on crime and justice issues
but raised the old-fashioned
issue of monetarism as a key part of our
economic approach something of which i
have a
a strong sympathy and no doubt that will
come to the fore as we look towards our
cost of living challenge the member for
don valley
who i'm very interested in this all
party group on on men and boys i think
he put his has put his finger on a
particular issue which has been
neglected and his uh
analogy that if we had a thousand cars
and three went wrong uh we wouldn't damn
all those thousand cars we would try and
work out why the three had gone wrong i
think it's a very strong one and i hope
that he and i can work together in the
months to come to solve some of those
problems that we are seeing in the
criminal justice system undoubtedly with
men and boys and then the um uh
honourable lady uh from edinburgh for
whom i have an enormous amount of
respect she obviously had to go through
the uh the standard attacks on the
conservative party to satisfy central
command in scotland uh but actually
um
but but actually
um her thoughts on the bill of rights uh
on conversion therapy and indeed on on
rights online rights i thought were
well worth listening to uh and gave
pause for thought um and i will
certainly be sending a copy of her
contribution to this debate to those
various ministers so they can consider
what she said um she's obviously a a
legal brain to be reckoned with and so
we should do exactly uh that
now uh madame deputy speaker it was hard
to discern uh in amongst the
in amongst the fury uh from the front
bench on the other side uh what they
were likely to support in the coming
session but i am pleased uh that our
part of the government universe we do
have a number of bills which i think
will make a significant uh difference
the british people a national security
bill that will enhance the safety of the
public and our vital interests and those
who seek to do the uk harm making good
on our manifesto commitment to make sure
security services have the power they
need i assume the front bench will
support that the through the protect
duty bill we're going to introduce new
legal requirements for public locations
and venues to ensure they're prepared
for protection from terrorist attack i
assume they will support that a public
order bill um i know they're going to
support the public order bill because
the leader of the opposition was calling
for more assertive action during the
recent fuel protest so i expect to see
support through the lobby for that an
economic crime bill we've already heard
from the front bench that they want to
support that and we hope to work
constructively with them in making sure
that we are all safe online and that
we're able to deny the proceeds of crime
uh from those who wish to make money uh
from exploiting our fellow citizens an
online safety bill which has been
subject to a lot of discussion in this
house and elsewhere um as to how we
should start to police the online world
in the same way that would police the
offline world no doubt there will be
challenges along the way but i'm sure
i'm sure uh we can reach a settle view
and i'm grateful particularly the
honourable member from from newcastle
for her contribution on algorithm she
will of course remember that we i think
are the first government of the world to
have a register of algorithms that can
be looked at by those who understand
them i'm not saying necessarily would
but who can examine them and i think the
scope for the house to come together uh
to both protect the vulnerable and in
particular children uh but also make
sure that we deal with offending online
the modern slavery bill
uh which i know will garner support from
across the the house a number of members
on all benches uh mentioned their desire
to strengthen protections in that
particular area a victims bill
which has been a little bit of time
coming but i'm glad to say we'll be laid
i hope shortly in draft form for
pre-legislative scrutiny um as it should
be
everybody wants to put victims at the
heart of the criminal justice system we
have done enormous amounts to support
victims over the last couple of years
spending significant money on support
mechanisms for them but there was always
much more we can do although madam
deputy speaker while we do want victims
to be supported our primary aim is that
there should be fewer of them um and the
work we're doing across the whole of the
criminal justice system and policing uh
will achieve that and then finally madam
deputy speaker the bill of rights
which should ensure that our human
rights framework meets the need of
society it serves commands public
confidence
and where
perceived and actual abuses of our human
rights laws are ended
we can restore a bit more common sense
to the justice system we need to
strengthen our common law traditions
particularly now as we exit at the
european union and we have to reduce our
reliance on strasbourg case law madam
deputy speaker um as my right over from
the home secretary set out earlier in
this debate the first job of any
government is to keep its people safe
that is why we're delivering ambitious
reforms to do just that cutting crime
delivering swifter justice and making
our streets safer we are backing the
ever-growing numbers of police with the
tools and support they need making
senses tougher for violence and sexual
crimes strengthening victims rights and
restoring confidence in the criminal
justice system and we will make sure
that we strike the right balance
in our human rights framework so that it
meets the needs of the public and
commands their confidence
to strengthen our traditions of liberty
particularly the right to free speech at
a healthy dose of common sense and
curtail abuses of our justice system and
i commend the government's program on
crime justice to the house
madam definitely speaker i beg to move
that this debate be now adjourned
the question is that the debate be now
adjourned as many as our of that opinion
say i
the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
standing order number
150d
says the speaker shall put forth with
the questions necessary to dispose of
proceedings
on a motion
to implement a sanction
recommended by the independent expert
panel
i call the leader of the house to move
the motion formally
let's move forward
the question is as on the order paper as
many as our of that opinion say i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
i'd beg to move that this house do now
adjourn the question is that this house
do now adjourn alicia keynes
thank you madam deputy speaker when
people think of leveling up what often
comes to mind is cities have been left
behind areas of the north as industries
have changed and towns where
inequalities are often blatant and
impossible to miss
but how often are the needs of rural
communities considered within that
discussion because i know they're
largely absent from the media debate on
this issue and i suspect in whitehall
they rarely get to look in that's the
crux of why i stand here this evening
rural communities can be forgotten no
more because too many of them have been
left behind and they deserve to be
leveled up too
now one-fifth of the uk's population
live in rural areas so this debate is of
great consequence to so very many
because we too need support to access
the opportunities our communities need
to succeed
but i recognize it's not straightforward
because in rural areas poverty is often
hidden barriers to social mobility can
be more difficult to observe in rural
areas and it does cost more to deliver
services in rural areas
another key issue is that deprivation is
used as a key determinant of funding but
with no recognition to the fact that
rural poverty should be considered
within this because of the added cost of
accessing services in rural areas which
deprives many of access
a focus on policy making on urban and
industrial growth has come at the
expense of those who do not live in
large cities and this has been made all
the worse due to under investment in
critical infrastructure and local
government and funding particularly in
areas in the east midlands would my own
friend give way very happily thank you
very much indeed you're making an er
the honourable member is making an
excellent speech and could i perhaps
highlight one one point um that
leicestershire county council for
example during this year's funding uh
settlement um and nationally they get
128 pounds a person but in
leicestershire only 85 pounds per person
my very uh beloved colleague is
absolutely right and when it comes to
this i believe that if leicester she was
funded the same amount of surrey they
would get something like 140 million
pounds more into their budget which i
will come on to in more detail shortly
so i think of er raising that
madam deputy speaker i beg to move that
this house do now adjourn when she's his
house to now john ellis he can't
start again
if i just explain them we have to move
the motion again at seven o'clock please
continue
where you left off
there we go right there we go i'm happy
to be giving more time that's not a
problem
um so yes i thank my friend for her
intervention
um
rural prosperity has been stifled and
the rural powerhouse campaign estimates
if we were trying to close the rural
productivity gap
it would add 43 billion of gross value
added to our economy
so today i stand here with some very
simple requests for the minister that
the government makes sure it doesn't
leave rural areas behind
that it promises to level up rural areas
that he sends a delegation of civil
servants to my constituency who could
pop across the border to his own
constituency to see the challenges faced
by our rural authorities
that he considered the creation of a
rural capital investment fund that i
would come on to and that he establishes
a rural deprivation unit within his
department
absolutely okay can i first of all
congratulate development for rutland and
melton for bringing this forward and as
a uh
the mp for a real constitutional next
frankfurt the very subject matter donald
one of these referring to is one that's
very close to my heart and and i i thank
our congratulatory and bringing that
forward because we making that all the
end so wanted i look forward to the
minister's response of course uh does
honorably not agree that there are many
rural businesses
that are ready to be successful online
if only they had more support
specifically designed to help those
dealing with rural areas
and that some of the prosperity funds
should be allocated to specialists in
rural business to provide training and
support for others
i couldn't agree more and as part of
that they require more support to have
the broadband access they need to be
able to establish and grow these
businesses which i will come on to
shortly now the uk share prosperity fund
is a central pillar of our leveling up
agenda and i welcome this fund it
rightly has a focus on local
stakeholders and letting local people
have their say there are some concerns
that i've have discussions with about
the harbor melton and rutland councils
i'd like to raise
firstly rural districts and local
authorities have been prescribed
relatively small proportions of funding
now this isn't a surprise to many of us
but i hope it can be rectified as we go
forward
secondly local flexibility risks being
constrained by the pre-specified
outcomes of the fund and finally the
yearly spending requirements limit our
ability to maximize investment spend
over the funds duration
now for it to have its most success we
have to focus on those long-term
investments but a closer inspection
budget red book shows there'll be no
dedicated ring fence funding in the
share prosperity fund for rural
businesses and that will hit communities
like his and mine hardest
now share prosperity begins the
recognition that different areas have
different needs and i know the minister
my good friend knows my constituency of
rotten melt in the veil harbour villages
very well
in many ways our communities are the
same they are idyllic we have an
enormous sense of community the big
heartedness and friendliness is
heartfelt and deep we have picturesque
rolling hills of england upping and one
of my three towns was voted the best
place to live in the east midlands
melton was named the sixth we have
industries that people might not
associate with rural areas samworth that
makes the majority of sandwiches in this
country arnold wills they make the
majority of belts in this country hanson
cement quarry mars petcare cs ellis an
amazing national haulage company and of
course our stilton and pork pies are
enjoyed around the world and beaver
fruit farm as well
now we love and we want to protect our
rural way of life but we need support
because delivering services in rural
areas is more expensive rural economies
are more susceptible to skill shortages
and physical and digital connectivity
lag behind other parts of the uk and the
geographical spread of our communities
can obscure the nature of these issues
are facing people
now looking at the relative affluence of
some parts of rottendame elton that
means that some pockets of deprivation
are too often overlooked by government
policy and that is the detriment of
rural communities
many people may not know but rutland
ranks in the bottom 10
for social mobility in the entire
country and i believe that rurality
plays a large role in that alongside
insufficient government support now i
know the secretary of state is
especially interested in tackling these
pockets of deprivation and this is where
a rural deprivation unit within his
department would make a fundamental
difference this would help them consider
and understand the complex nature of
rural inequalities and make sure that
local investment plans take this into
account
it would provide a renaissance for our
rural communities
now on the issue of local government
funding which the honourable lady
prolofer rightly raised for too long
communities in leicestershire and in
rutland rottendame elton have come
second best despairingly leicestershire
is the lowest funded county council per
head in england
while rutland county council are
expected to raise significantly more
revenue through local taxation than
other local authorities in england and
the east midlands as a region has the
lowest level of public investment of any
region in england
now how can we have shared prosperity
when long-term funding resettlements are
so unfavorable to rural areas it's a
bold and ambitious agenda but how can
our councils do more with less
i desperately no we desperately need and
deserve the funding we need
now looking specifically at rotten
county council that has been an
effective unitary authority for many
years and we are proud of our
independence we are ranked number one on
the impower index the highest performing
council on adult social care in the
country
but we forecast a budget gap for 2023-24
onwards
we are required to raise a shocking 80
percent of our revenue through taxation
the national average for councils is
just 60
that means that ban d property in
rutland is two thousand two hundred
pounds a year and this is the council on
the worst ten percent for social
mobility in our country
we receive 331 pounds less government
funding per household than other
councils we have the highest council tax
in the country that is not good enough
and it is not fair
and then we look to leicestershire
county council in which melton and the
vale and harbour parts of my
constituency sit as i touched on earlier
if lcc was funded the same amount of
surrey they would have 104 million
pounds more to support people across
leicestershire that cannot be right
we need their funding
and i'm pleased to secure productive
meetings between rutland county council
and the minister of state for levelling
up and i here and i hope that future
funding settlements will be provided
earlier to allow for better local
planning but they also need to be richer
my leicestershire colleagues and i have
worked tirelessly since our elections to
try and get the department to pay heed
to this unfair imbalance and i know it's
not easy and i know it's not
straightforward and i know budget would
be required but we have to rectify these
injustices and i have raised them time
and time and again and i hope the
department pay attention to them
now moving on to rural transport
strong transport links are all the more
critical in rural settings and it's
fantastic the share prosperity fund is
taking transport into account
now after 40 years of promises and hopes
and let down dreams together the
minister's department
the melton mobile distributor road is
finally being built in my constituency
it is going to transform the town centre
of melton and bring 160 million pounds
of investment into our amazing town
however
we have wider rural transport concerns
that continue
community renewal is highly dependent on
good transport services but we've had
recent reductions in all of our
transport services threatened to
undermine our rural growth it melts on
the end of the number 19 bus between
melton and nottingham has been cut
because it was being underused but also
because it wouldn't be financed anymore
workers and students are no longer able
to get from rural melton to nottingham
for work or for uh or for educational
opportunities businesses are suffering
and particularly those with special
educational needs and in rural areas
those special educational needs suffer
so often because it is so difficult to
access the services they need now i'm
hopeful that i can mitigate some of the
loss of that bus service with the
reinstatement of the train service from
melton to nottingham there is currently
no direct service we have to go through
my honourable friends constituency
through leicester and the government
kindly provided 50 000 pounds of funding
to look at my proposal to reopen it and
i would politely ask the minister to
remind his colleagues at department of
transport we're waiting to hear back on
our bid having made our business case
now in rutland centre bus is only
continuing the rutland flyer bus in the
707 routes after demanding additional
subsidies from rutland county council
given what i've just said about our
funding issues in rutland you can see
why having to subsidize a bus route is
an additional burden the council cannot
take on
now the government's promised to bring
forward new arrangements for rural
transport in the summer and i urge them
to act now to support faltering rural
transport services because that will be
defensive very happily please i'm very
grateful to my honourable friend for
giving away and can i congratulate her
on securing this very important debate
on support for our rural communities
leveling up across our entire united
kingdom must include our rural
communities on our efra select committee
we are in the midst of an inquiry on
rural mental health and the evidence
that we have taken much of the stresses
and pressures on rural communities are
exacerbated by rural isolation and then
things that happen in rural communities
whether it's animal disease outbreaks
whether it's flooding um and and
connectivity issues where people can't
get from a to b and my homophone is
making that point passionately
would my honourable friend agree with me
that the government central government
should work with local government to
make sure that funding is allocated to
rural communities to really try and
mitigate against rural isolation by
funding rural bus services by funding
broadband and making sure people can be
connected and stay together
my honourable friend hits the nail on
the head whether it's combating
loneliness or connectivity or business
opportunity all the 150 ukrainians who
are going to settle my constituency and
have already started over the last few
weeks the 431 square miles of my
constituency are very difficult to
navigate when there are no bus services
now coming onto digital connectivity we
do have a digital deficit in rural
communities and onward and the nfu
highlighted in 2021 only 20 of people in
rural areas can access broadband speeds
above 24 mbbs now that's not good enough
and i welcome that i was able to get
rutland in the first tranche of places
in the country that will receive full
fibre optic that's fantastic that
gigabit um but
we need it for more communities
excuse me madam speaker
across the community i promise i do not
have copied
looking at job retention in rural areas
and if we are to give rural areas the
tools they need then we have to make
sure people know that they can remain
locally for jobs and i touched on some
of the amazing employers in my
constituency earlier
um but to tackle these differences we do
need long-term ability to think for our
local authorities and i'm concerned that
unless the shared prosperity fund can be
used to address the root causes of rural
inequality it will have a limited impact
on our communities and that's why the
country land and business association
has called for the creation as a
separate fund for rural capital
investment and i would urge the minister
to consider this rutland and melton are
currently developing a joint leveling up
fund bid and it reflects the varied
nature of our communities and business
interests and i look forward to
championing that in parliament
now coming to health and emergency
services and the very good friends that
one can make in this place
the government has rightly identified
health as one of the key pillars of
leveling up
um a report in 2019 showed that while
older people in rural areas experience
reduced rates of mortality poor access
to services is driving health inequality
and i believe that living in the
countryside you can have the most
incredible healthy and happy lifestyle
but poor access to services is a
meaningful challenge now since being
elected the mp i have been fighting for
a second gp practice in the town of
melton mowbray because i believe that
latham house medical practice is the
most over-subscribed surgery in the
country
if nothing changes 45 000 people
will be served by one practice
that cannot be right i was told on my
election it would take me over a decade
to get us a new gp practice and that's
not good enough for me and it's not good
enough for the people of melton and i've
been working hard melton borough council
especially our leader council joe orson
our chief executive ed de coverley as
well as our clinical commissioning group
chair andy williamson to make sure that
we get one and we don't wait 10 years
for it
in rutland there are also wider health
challenges
rutland memorial hospital i promise to
save it and i now have that commitment
from the ccg that it will be saved but
we need investment so that my elderly
community do not have to go to leicester
which takes them at least an hour to get
ongoing care for chronic conditions we
need new funds we need to invest in
community hospitals indeed at that
dispatch box yesterday the prime
minister championed the fact that he had
fought for community hospitals when he
first came to this place so i hope that
he will listen and take heed to the fact
that we need to do it now
we also face challenges around
cross-border working uh constituents of
mine in rutland access services in
peterborough in lincolnshire in
kettering in northamptonshire in
leicester in the vale they access
services in leicestershire in
nottinghamshire in lincolnshire we now
have finally a requirement that they
have to share this information across
border but there is more to be done
finally i welcome wholeheartedly the
shared prosperity fund's emphasis on
community and place as the minister
knows our motto in rutland is molten
imparvo much in little and we have
abundance of pride in our county from
rutland water which i invite every
member of this house to visit indeed one
colleague grabbed me earlier today and
said it's don't dry in your constituency
i said yes it is do you know that's
where they launched the gunpowder plot
from he said no i didn't but i did once
i beat it aren't you lucky to have that
in your constituency i said yes i am he
then went on to list a number of other
villages and towns in my constituency
and how lucky i was it is an amazing
place to be
we have our rotten show ground that does
events like bird fare but recently we've
had an incredible two archaeological
discoveries the first was the amazing
roma mosaic found in a farmer's field
just 15 minutes from my own home which
tells the story of achilles and hector
now it's changed our understanding of
roman britain because in so many movies
britain at that time was hordes of
barbarians and we now know we have these
amazing mosaics it's described as one of
the most significant discoveries ever
made in the uk
then only a couple weeks later the
discovery of 180 million year old
ichthyosaur the uk's largest and most
complete record of the marine reptile
which i had the privilege of touching
while it was being dug up
now surely funding from the share
prosperity fund could go towards the
promotion of these discoveries because i
have no doubt that the scale of them
means we deserve a heritage museum a
heritage trail major investment in our
tourism industry that would help
counteract the fact we do not get enough
local government funding allow us to
stand on our own feet that's all we're
asking for but we need the investment
from dcms and i hope we can make it a
reality
melton 2 has much to celebrate and pride
a place we all know it's the rural
capital food and we have some of the
best farmers in the country who
pronounce the world renowned goods such
as the melton mowbray port pie which yes
i promised in my maiden speech you would
hear much of and i have clearly not
failed to deliver on that
there is stilton tuxedo and tebbett the
oldest producer in the world long claws
and dairy the world's best ale is
produced in by around corner brewing in
melton award-winning brains region they
didn't win the international award i'm
afraid uh cedentro
cedentro side which again as a one wards
samosa walla we make amazing samosas
we're also the leading producers of
paneer cheese and tofu for the japanese
restaurant market
we are the world's capital of food and
food heritage is in our blood we can be
the home of food tourism with help from
the government so i would like to pay
tribute to the melton borough council
and leicester and leicestershire
enterprise partnership who set up the
new food enterprise centre last year
and particularly the new stockyard that
was launched only two three weeks ago
which will provide a new opportunity as
a haven of food and drink within my
constituency
now to finish up minister and deputy
madame dr speaker i previously stated
that the shared prosperity fund can
deliver outcomes bigger than the sum of
its parts but i wonder if the minister
can elaborate on ways in which we as
memphis can access this fund i was
recently contacted by the trustees of
barodan village hall and of the last six
years six years they've been working a
plan to replace their aging villain
village facilities
the grants they hope to replied for have
been wiped out by covert we've
recognized that we are asking for more
in a time of less but they are looking
into applying to the community ownership
fund to restore their village hall the
next bidding round is in may and i think
they would be a fantastic fantastic
candidate for community and place
investment priority so i hope that i've
put that very much on his radar
i would also point out to him that i
have been fighting now for at least 18
months for defra to open its office
outside of london in melton because it's
not just that melton needs defra defra
needs melton it should not be that our
policy officials are relying on field
visits to meet farmers and to understand
the rural way of life
we are in the final three to home dephra
it is melted mowbray peterborough and
york what do you notice about that two
cities and one rural town only one is
the rural capital of food defra should
come to melton and it would get a
wonderful home and wonderful support
from my colleagues
in conclusion madam deputy speaker for
far too long rural areas will be left
behind to the detriment of our society
this is grossly unfair to the ministers
constituents and to mine we have a
leveling up agenda that allows us to
finally tackle these inequalities
but we have to be honest about the scale
of the challenges
we need a fair funding settlement for
rural local authorities
we need investment in rural transport
and digital infrastructure we need
improved rural health services improved
rural mental health services and a long
term plan for rural culture
we can do this and then all of the
communities of rotten melt in the veil
and harbor villages will have the chance
to succeed
we are currently both rutland and melton
tier two priority areas in the leveling
up fund so give us a chance to succeed
support us and in february the secretary
of state offered to come to rutland to
see hand the opportunities that we have
but also the challenges that fake face
our local authorities so i'd ask the
secretary of state to come my colleague
is always welcome to pop across the
border and join me
and i hope that we can recognize that
when rural communities prosper so does
the rest of the uk and i hope that we
will not have to have a debate like this
again during my time as the proud member
for under mountain
oh thank you madam deputy speaker and
i'd like to start by congratulating my
honourable friend the member for rutland
and melton for securing a debate
on this important uh topic and for her
superb uh speech and the important
contributions from members for
strangford and my honourable friend for
uh and also the uh honourable friend uh
for penrith in the border who was making
some similar and important points in the
debate just a couple of weeks ago now we
should start madame deputy speaker by
recognizing that there's many many
positive things happening in rutland
melton and the parts of the harbour
district that she uh represents and many
of them are happening because of my
honourable friend
she's been a relentless champion for
fair funding for rutland and
leicestershire she secured the melton uh
murbay distributor road which is
absolutely key to leveling up melton
after 40 years of discussion she and
local colleagues have finally made it
happen uh
memorial hospital been saved after the
commitment she secured from the ccg
she raised broadband and i'm pleased
that her efforts on this paid off and
put rutland in the very first trash of
gigabit upgrades in the country and my
friend also helped secure um a 150 000
for community hub in thurnby and uh uh
uh 550 000 for public frisbee from our
community ownership funds and i look
forward to drinking them at some point
and of course her local authorities have
also benefited uh for funding from the
uk uh shared prosperity fund uh rutland
melton leicestershire are receiving over
5 million
of uk sbf funding with rutland getting
over a million harbor over 2.1 million a
melton just shy of 1.2 million on top of
that leicester show is receiving nearly
3 million in multiply
uh funding now on the shared prosperity
fund she raised a series of important
questions about flexibility and rurality
and i want to address them directly
even the last labour government
acknowledged that spending on regional
economic policies should have been
brought back from brussels and decided
here but they never managed to bring it
back or get the eu to agree to that now
we do have uh control back we can do
things differently and compared to
previous eu funding the shared
prosperity fund will be radically more
flexible and much more locally led under
the last labor government funding was
given to remote and unelected regional
rdas based far away from rutland melton
under the shared prosperity fund it will
be given to individual districts and
elected local leaders so much more local
in addition bureaucracy will be slashed
and there will be far more discretion
over what money is spent on eu
requirements for match funding which uh
impacted on poorer places in particular
will be abolished and the eu system with
payments in arrears multiple rounds of
auditing multiple rules and lengthy
application documents which all made it
difficult for small voluntary local
groups in particular will all be swept
away and under the eu funding only very
narrowly defined set of things could be
funded now under the shared prosperity
fund the investment priorities
deliberately cover a very wide range of
possible local interventions precisely
because that's what local leaders said
they wanted from us whether it's digital
connectivity buses skills improvements
to high streets community events sport
festivals the choice for the first time
will belong to local leaders and local
communities and rural communities will
be empowered to set and deliver against
their own priorities through the fund
shaping it locally not applying to a
remote rda based in a city far away
so in terms of allocations the shared
prosperity found matches in real terms
the previous uh spend in each uh lep
area and we were conscious of the need
for continuity for undergoing programs
that's why we made that decision
however within those left areas we've
used the same index of community renewal
that we developed for the community
renewal fund and one reason we use that
is exactly because it unlike previous
funding formulas explicitly recognizes
the challenges of rurality and sparsity
to tackle the very unfairness that my
honourable friend has raised and the
shared prosperity fund is only one of
the funds that we're using to give
financial firepower to places the 4.8
billion
leveling up fund just recently opened
for its second round and that could be
used to boost some of those fantastic
rural food businesses my honourable
friend mentioned or it could be used to
make the most of the incredible cultural
discoveries she
mentioned she noted that rutland melton
were in tier two and again that is
because the index for living up fund
recognizes the challenges of rural and
poorly connected areas in a way that
previous governments haven't we've also
created new funds like the community
ownership fund which particularly help
rural communities where those hub assets
are so important to villages and smaller
places on top of that 3.6 billion towns
fund is regenerating communities up and
down the country and there is more to
come with the 1.8 billion brownfield
fund mainly still to be allocated which
will help drive regeneration and save
valued green
thank spaces very much um he mentioned
their community ownership funds there is
a pub in statham in my constituency who
having seen the success of the bell in
frisbee would like to do the same with
the red line can i ask when the next
funding round will be opening because i
know there's a key to the department to
learn from previous rounds to help
people applying for the next round of
that community ownership fund
it will be opening extremely shortly i
will uh take that offline with my
honourable friend and we have indeed
tried to learn some lessons to improve
it from the first round now
my honourable friend raised a number of
other critical issues in particular she
talked very powerfully about the need
for more gp surgeries i wholly agree now
the leveling up and regeneration bill
published today responds to exactly that
issue and the campaigning by her and the
other mps here this evening
we must make sure that development
always comes with the infrastructure
that is needed
section 106 has seen money handed back
to developers which is intensely
frustrating for local communities
projects become outdated by the time the
money is available money can't be
adequately pooled add up to major
projects it's not a transparent system
it doesn't reflect the community of the
effect of development because you can't
pool funds properly
the new infrastructure levy we are
proposing through that bill will change
all that it means more money for local
communities more of the benefit of
development for the local communities
not just developers more local control
is what it is spent on as well and
matching that new housing to the
infrastructure that is needed a
vulnerable friend also talked about
digital connectivity in the challenges
of rural areas also her success in the
early rollout we're investing five
billion pounds so it's hard to reach
areas can get give it speeds and over 67
of uk premises can now access gigabit
capable broadband which is an enormous
leap forward from july 2019 when
coverage was only eight percent a
spectacular transformation and the
billion pounds that we're investing in a
shared rural network will particularly
help improve mobile signals in rural
areas like rutland and melton so that my
honourable friend can spend even more
time until the 847 lobbying ministers
brutally effectively
my honourable friend talked of course
about the critical issue of
local government
finance the overriding ambition of
government is of course to keep bills
low by giving councils the tools and the
firepower to keep
taxes low while offering first-rate
services to their residents and of
course the
russian invasion of ukraine
impacts on that and makes the cost of
living even more important our local
government finance settlement for 2223
does exactly that by uh providing an
additional 3.7 billion of funding to
local authorities including support for
adults social care reform which is of
course critical for rural areas with all
the populations in my honourable friends
constituency that translates into a cash
terms increase in cost spending power
for harbor of six percent compared to
last year for melton a 9.3 increase and
for rutland a 7.4 increase and for
leicestershire county council 6.9
increase compared to the previous year
and that new funding we've made
available is the largest cash terms
increase in grant funding provided
through the settlement in the last 10
years testament to the support we're
affording to councils in every corner of
the county especially those outside our
major towns and cities my honourable
friend is quite right to say that these
things could always be improved and she
will continue to power forward on this
agenda i'm sure but
i i should i will give away one more
time it was just their brief to touch on
uh i just wanted to point out the
minister is a neighbor of mine and i
wish to point out that without him i do
not believe we would have made the
progress we have made on fair funding
within this country within improved
settlement so whilst he cannot publicly
uh lobby for his own constituent market
harbor i know that all leicester mps
wish to put on record their gratitude to
him and whilst i cannot ask him to agree
i will therefore instead ask him to
confirm that he will continue to keep
his eye on funding for leicestershire
rotten going forward
madam dick did you go no i'm not
entirely sure what to say an answer to
that question um so um i should i should
say instead that i should like to uh
to finish and to thank my honourable
friend for bringing this very very
important issue to the house today
the rural economy doesn't always get the
attention in the past it hasn't had the
attention or the credit that it deserves
and governments who undervalue rural
communities and would do so in their
peril and we will never ever ever do
that now when i was in upping them on
market day just the other day you know
you see all the attractions and the
wonderful things about my honourable
friends constituency the incredible
vibrant uh town center it's a wonderful
wonderful place but we as a government
also see the challenges right we see the
challenges of maintaining those rural
bus routes we see the challenges
of an older population it's wonderful
that rutland has the highest male life
expectancy in the entire country but of
course that brings with it the higher
cost of looking after well
a group of older people
rural places don't have the momentum
that larger cities have had because of
the changes to a services-based economy
over the last 20 years that have helped
capital cities and large cities
particularly at the expense of rural
areas and we're conscious of those
challenges we have made unprecedented
changes to funding formula to recognize
the challenges which for too long as my
honourable friends had have been
neglected but under this government uh
we are addressing those things and just
to disagree with wanting moral
friendships worried that sometimes these
things are forgotten in government i can
promise her they will never ever be
forgotten in this government thank you
the question is this house do now
adjourn as many as our of that opinion
say aye
the eyes have it order order
you